So, fast gar nicht verklickt zu Beginn dieser Sendung.
Maus gerutscht.
Nur kurz Maus gerutscht. Was soll schon?
Aber das ist jetzt die Live-Experience für unsere Live-Hörer.
Denn ich bin ja viel zu, wie soll ich sagen, nicht arrogant, sondern...
Überhitzt, es ist warm.
Nee, das auch.
Selbstbewusst.
Nee, das Gegenteil davon.
Größenwahnsinnig schüchtern.
Auf jeden Fall fallen mir nicht mehr die richtigen Worte ein.
Das kann man schon mal festhalten.
Also, ich würde mich ja schämen für so einen Fehler, deswegen nehme ich den
dann in der finalen Version einfach raus.
Ja, das sind die Perks des Live-Hörts.
Das sind die Perks des Live-Hörts, genau. Das heißt noch Freak-Show.
Das kann nur die Freak-Show sein. die, wie mir vor kurzem wieder bewusst wurde,
schon ganz schön lange on-air ist.
Wir sind 2008 hier gestartet.
Da ist schon einiges zusammengekommen. Ein Wunder, dass es sie noch gibt,
dank des Adapters. Des Adapters.
Aber auch der hier die fahnehochhaltenden Regulars wie Ralf. Hallo Ralf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und Roddy natürlich.
Ja, einen schönen kühlen Abend wünsche ich.
Genau. Und zu Gast haben wir heute live aus dem Internet den Malik.
Eis, Eis, Baby. Hallo.
Jetzt müssen wir hier Konfetti-Kanone starten. Genau. Und mein Name ist Tim
Brittlaff. Das wisst ihr alles schon.
Und ja, du hast schon ein bisschen links und rechts her geschwungen,
als du die Intromusik gehört hast, Malik, und was war dein Eindruck? Kannst du das?
Kann ich es kennen oder was? Suno ist die Frage.
Könntest du den Stil benennen?
Oh, jetzt hätte ich mal zu Roddy geschieht. Natürlich irgendeine spanische,
klassische, aber ob das dann Faux oder irgendein Latin, da bin ich nicht gut leider.
Also ich kann jetzt die Geschichte erzählen, wie ich mal in einem Salsa-Club
irgendwie Bands abgemischt habe und Kanal 12 vom Mischpult kaputt war,
weil das Mischpult nämlich direkt unter einem Abwasserrohr stand und das leckte
ein bisschen und der Kanal 12 musste dann dran glauben.
Ja, das war ein sehr angenehmer Club. Sie haben auch, bevor der Abend losging,
immer die Tanzfläche nochmal gewischt.
Da hat die Putzfrau dann ins Putzwasser nochmal eine große Flasche Cola reingekippt.
Und mit diesem Zuckerwasser wurde dann die Tanzfläche gewischt,
damit sie ein bisschen mehr Grip hatte.
Also ich habe ein komisches Verhältnis zu dieser Musik, muss ich sagen.
Das hatte so Buena Vista Social Club-Vibes. Die Älteren unter uns ganz erinnern.
Ich würde auch das ganz klar als Son kategorisieren.
Also Son ist ja so dieser kubanische spezielle Sound.
Trotzdem hat man, also das Album heißt Rumba Congo und die Artists heißen Konkubanas.
Und ihr werdet es schon geahnt haben. Nothing is real. sondern das ist alles mal außer AI.
Da wir hier vor gar nicht so langer Zeit die ersten AI-Sound-Generator-Experimente
hinter uns hatten, dachte ich, könnte man das nochmal einwerfen.
Ja, ich fühlte mich damals ja sehr missverstanden. Siehst du,
jetzt ist es ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem geworden.
Wie fühlt es sich missverstanden von uns?
Ich hatte ja irgendwie so zehn Freakshow-Songs irgendwie generiert.
Also wer das nachhören möchte, das ist glaube ich immer noch ganz cool,
so ein Jahr alt. War das im Sommer letzten Jahres, glaube ich.
und jetzt werden halt ganze Alben damit produziert und war doch schön was.
Habt ihr denn alle,
Malik, du als Musiker du hast doch deine bestimmten Meinung zu ja.
Ja, ich hab eine neue Band die heißt The Velvet Sundown ihr könnt euch jetzt
unser neues Album auf Spotify anhören ich glaub wir haben jetzt grad die 400.000
monthly listeners geknackt ich find's geil, was soll ich sagen die Kohle prasselt
rein, ich muss nicht mehr Amps schleppen, perfekt Perfekt.
Okay, für alle, die jetzt noch nicht ganz mitgekommen sind, wahrscheinlich ist
das auch etwas, wo Tim drauf angespielt hat.
Es gibt gerade ein weiteres AI-Phänomen in der Musikwelt.
Nachdem alle Suno, Udio und so weiter ausprobiert haben, gibt es jetzt eine
Band namens The Velvet Sundown.
Über die weiß man halt nichts, aber die zwei, drei Bilder, die es von denen
gibt, sind so clearly AI.
Also alle sehen etwa aus wie ich, wenn ihr euch das vorstellen könnt,
aber ich spiele nicht wirklich dort, deswegen müssen sie AI sein.
Wer sollte sich so eine Band anschauen wollen?
Ne, anschauen kann man sich die natürlich dann auch nicht, ne?
Gut für uns Live-Musiker, aber tatsächlich ist da jetzt dieses Album von denen,
hat massive Zugriffszahlen auf Spotify, aber es gibt halt, also die Band ist
wie alt, drei Wochen oder so.
Also es gibt einfach keine Vorgeschichte, kein Drumherum, niemand kennt die
Leute und die Bilder sehen weird aus.
Ich werfe da mal jetzt einen beliebigen Link mal in unseren euren Slack.
Ja, ich habe ja auch schon ein paar gefunden, die sehen in der Tat weird aus.
Also allein schon der, ja, das ist so AI as it can be.
Ja, genau.
Also eine Meinung, ich finde es noch so ein bisschen schwierig,
weil ich bin ja so mit einem Bein Nerd und interessiert an dem ganzen Kram und
wir nutzen AI alle und es wird eine Commodity und es wird überall sein.
Auf der anderen Seite habe ich auch eine Band und da ist man dann Urheber und
dann denkt man sich, okay,
wo wird der ganze Kram trainiert, das habt ihr auch alles schon dreimal rauf und runter besprochen,
was ist mit der rechten Lage und was ist mit der Zukunft so und ich glaube,
ich sehe das ja auf der einen Seite als hochproblematisch wie alle Creator und
alles, was ich in meinem Leben mache, ist Creator sein auf allen Ebenen,
Grafik, Videoproduktion und so weiter. auch Musik.
Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Auf der anderen Seite, ja,
es kommt immer eine neue Technologie, Dinge verändern sich, es gibt davon Vorteile.
Ich glaube, was ich global sehe, ist A, die Bands haben kein so richtig großes
Problem, denn für das Live-Erlebnis hilft die AI halt erstmal noch nichts.
Du stellst halt keine Roboter dahin.
Vorerst. Also für das Gefühl. Ja, auch dann ist ein Festival erstmal noch nicht dasselbe.
Und die Zeiten, wo irgendwie Bands noch von CD-Verkäufen und irgendwie Streaming-Gebühren
gelebt haben, sind irgendwie vorbei, oder?
Also ist es nicht ohnehin so, dass man eigentlich nur noch durch Live und Touren
Geld verdient heutzutage?
Touren haben im Prinzip nie Geld verdient, nur mittelbar. Das muss man vielleicht unterscheiden.
Also du bist froh, wenn eine Tour auf null rauskommt, auch wenn sie groß ist,
sondern womit du verdienst, ist eigentlich Merch.
Und alles andere an Side-Hustles, je nachdem, also wenn du jetzt ein Artist
bist, der irgendwie gute Werbekooperationen machen kann oder so,
dann ist es sowas, aber eigentlich tatsächlich, wenn ihr Bands unterstützen
wollt, drückt ihnen Geldscheine in die Hand oder kauft ein T-Shirt.
Und zwar im Konzert, ne?
Am besten beim Konzert, aber also wir machen zum Beispiel unseren Bandshop selber,
also ich verschicke den Kram aus meinem Wohnzimmer, damit ist es dann quasi
egal, aber genau, je mehr zwischen Personen du hast, desto problematischer für die Band.
Legst du dann auch mal eine Originalunterhose dazu? Oder ist es noch nicht so weit?
Das ist ein unsichtbares Line-Item und nicht ganz billig.
In jedem Sipten Ei.
Also wir haben ja eine Sängerin Kim und wir haben tatsächlich schon,
als es drum ging, okay, wir bräuchten jetzt mal irgendwie für den nächsten Step
mal 10.000 oder 30.000 oder wie
viel Euro, man kann da unendlich Geld versenken, hat sie auch schon über,
Fußfotos auf Onlyfans nachgedacht oder so.
Man muss halt nehmen, was man kriegen kann.
Oh Gott, tut mir so leid.
Okay, ich bin mal so frei und werfen.
Den Fame und die Significant Others.
Mega viel Fame. Darf ich Shameless mal dazu aufrufen, unseren Fame zu erhöhen?
Weil es ist so, die eigentliche Währung für eine Band heutzutage ist ja,
welche Zahlen du auf Spotify hast und welche Zahlen du auf den Socials hast.
Denn wenn da die Zahlen hoch sind, kannst du zu irgendeinem Konzertort oder
zu einem Booker oder zu irgend sowas gehen und sagen, guck mal, wir sind relevant.
Deswegen, was einer Band, ohne dass man Geld bezahlt, am meisten hilft,
ist tatsächlich, die Klickzahlen hochzutreiben und deswegen werfe ich gerne
mal unseren Insta-Kanal, das ist der für uns relevante,
hier in die Freakshow-Shownote-Dingens rein.
Da bitteschön. Wenn ihr Bock habt, uns zu unterstützen, dann klickt auf diese
Insta-Profilkiste und abonniert und dann könnt ihr es auch direkt wieder muten.
Aber wenn wir demnächst mal so die tausend knacken würden...
Benutzt du Instagram?
Ja, ich bin natürlich einer der beiden Social Media Fuzzis in der Band,
das ist für uns natürlich das Haupt-Tool.
Ernsthaft.
Also Malik postet da jetzt nichts von seinem Essen, aber die Band,
das ist das Haupt-Tool zu den Leuten.
Wir haben auch fünf andere Kanäle, aber das, was funktioniert und das kristallisiert
sich ja immer so raus, ist definitiv bei uns Insta.
Liegt wahrscheinlich an der Alterskohorte, die wir ansprechen. Mitte 20 bis Mitte 40.
Facebook ist komplett tot. Mit der letzten Band war Facebook total relevant,
das ist vorbei. Komplett vorbei, machen da gar nichts.
Und TikTok, dafür sind wir ganz zu alt. Oder keinen Bock drauf.
Ich finde das furchtbar.
Aber wir bedienen es natürlich, wir werfen da was rein, aber Insta is the game right now.
Aber Instagram ist doch genau derselbe Terror wie TikTok eigentlich, oder?
Nee, ich würde sagen, es ist der aufgeräumtere nicht so Terror.
Instagram ist aufgeräumter.
Viel aufgeräumter. Genauso wie Threads, der mit einer der besten Twitter-artigen
Clients ist, die ich je gesehen habe.
So gestalterisch und so. Ich benutze es auch nicht aktiv, aber sie haben es sehr gut gemacht.
Also die Zeiten, wo sie nicht mehr ihre eigene Webseite gestalten wollen bei Facebook und Co.
sind echt vorbei. Also das haben sie hinbekommen.
Da muss auch kein flüssiges Glas bemüht werden. Da reichen klare Icons und konsistente Oberflächen.
Shots feiert. Na gut, also wir halten fest, die künstliche Intelligenz beschert
uns im Wochenabstand neue,
Bedrohungsszenarien und begeistert einen irgendwie im gleichen Moment auch noch.
Wir werden alle Kinder losbleiben.
Es ist wirklich viel der ganzen Debatte, ich hatte jetzt auch gerade mit Linus
mal eine ganze Sendung nur zu dem Thema gemacht und ich will das jetzt hier
auch gar nicht so weit ausbreiten, aber generell einfach vom Gefühl her muss
ich sagen, das ist ein super,
schwieriges Thema, weil auch wenn natürlich viele Leute jetzt völlig aufgeregt
sind und sagen, oh Gott, KI,
wie könnt ihr nur und wir werden alle sterben und so, ja, alle werden arbeitslos
und es wird keine Musiker mehr geben und der Tag hat nur noch drei Stunden.
Ich meine, diese ganzen Weltuntergangsformulierungen gab es im Prinzip immer
und die Gesellschaft hat immer auch irgendwie gekopt damit.
Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wie das aussehen wird, aber naja,
mal schauen. Aber ich sehe...
Abschließend, ich sehe, dass die Musiker generell im letzten Jahrzehnt doch
extrem unter den Bus geworfen worden sind.
Man kann natürlich immer sagen, ihr müsst euch ja anpassen und die Zeiten ändern sich und so.
Das stimmt natürlich auch, weil das müssen ja auch alle machen.
Aber ich glaube, niemand musste sich im Wochenrhythmus so schnell immer wieder
neuen Zeiten anpassen wie Musikern, die ja nicht gerade unbedingt von einem
hohen Niveau des Einkommens in der Regel starten.
Und das ist schon bitter irgendwie. naja, das wird's.
Ja, also die Musik, also die eigentlichen Kreaturen, außer in Ausnahmefällen,
waren ja sowieso schon ganz am Ende der monetären Verwertungskette bei Musik.
Also das haben ja die Labels und Managements und alles, was da drüber hängt,
ja schon hervorragend eingerichtet.
Und ich finde, was Spotify angefangen hat, nämlich, dass die ganze Monetarisierung
Richtung Daniel Eck, dem Chef, am Ende geht. Also im Prinzip verdient Spotify.
als Company und damit viele, viele andere nichts mehr, also dass sich das so
zentriert auf sehr wenige Player, das ist bei AI ja im Prinzip noch stärker.
Das ist ja nicht nur, hey, wir haben hier einen Job, sowas wie Musikvertrieb
oder Musikveröffentlichung, die wir zentralisieren und übernehmen.
Oder wie bei Uber, sowas wie Taxifahrten weltweit, fangen wir jetzt an,
auf uns zu konzentrieren.
Sondern AI konzentriert ja einfach, so wir wollen alle eure Jobs.
Außer es ist Krankenschwester, oder? Weißt du, was ich meine?
Also ich meine, eigentlich ist es ja so, oh, du bist Grafikdesigner oder du
willst eine CD machen oder du willst ein Video produzieren oder du willst einen
Hollywoodfilm machen oder du willst einen Podcast machen, wo Leute über Themen
reden oder, oder, oder, du bist Journalistin oder, ihr wisst, was ich meine,
alles ist ja am Ende Kohle für Open AI und zwei andere.
Also es ist halt einfach, die Konzentration wird noch viel stärker.
Ja, na gut. Schauen wir mal, wie das weitergeht.
Wir haben ganz viele Themen heute. Machen wir doch einfach mal weiter erstmal mit Feedback.
Und da bleiben wir kurz bei KI, weil es wurde dann auch von einem anderen Hörer
tatsächlich auch korrekt KI-Spam bei uns geschickt.
Entdeckt zur letzten Sendung. Und das finde ich insofern sehr interessant,
als dass ja quasi Spammerei hat ja auch viel mit so Kommunikationskosten zu tun.
Als es billig wurde, das massenhaft auszusenden, wurde es eben auch massenhaft gemacht.
Und Podcasts sind bisher eigentlich immer so ein bisschen verschont geblieben,
weil dann muss man sich ja den Kram vorher noch anhören und das führt in der
Regel zu höheren Kommentarqualitäten und lädt jetzt nicht so die Spammer so
ein, beziehungsweise man kann die Spammer dann relativ gut rausfiltern.
Jetzt gab es einen, der fing so an. Die heutige Sendung, also es bezieht sich
auf die letzte, die heutige Sendung war wieder einmal vollgepackt mit interessanten
Themen und Diskussionen.
Luca hat spannende Einblicke in sein Hackathon in der Ukraine geteilt,
was wirklich inspirierend war.
Ihr merkt schon, die Diskussion über die Ankündigung von Apples WWDC war wie
immer lebhaft und voller unterschiedlicher Meinung.
Das Spielchen mit dem Tier ist über Physical Interface.
Das hat die Sendung zwar in die Länge gezogen, aber es war unterhaltsam und
hat Potenzial für zukünftige Folgen.
Wie denkt ihr über die Verwendung von VGA in modernen Kleinstrechtern?
Aber dann so der totale Break, weil dann geht es auf einmal auf Englisch weiter
und dann so ja, hier, dieser geile Dienst und super und so weiter.
Da merkst du, dass es richtig wie der Algorithmus bricht, beziehungsweise einfach
nur auf den Content rangeworfen wurde.
Da ich ja jetzt die ganzen Transkripte auch immer in der Webseite habe,
weiß ich eben nicht genau, ob der jetzt einfach, also ob es sich tatsächlich
aufs Audio bezieht, ich vermute mal eher nicht.
Das Transkript wurde gelesen, es wurde dann irgendeine Response generiert, das war dann halt das.
Das ist auch so das typische, der typische Podcast-Samourizer-Kram.
Und merkt ihr ja schon, wie wir schon zu Experten werden, wie wir das schon
so raushören, also am Ton irgendwie, ne? Das ist irre.
Naja, nice try, better luck next time.
Da muss euch schon was Besseres einfallen. Wer hier einfach die Sendung über
den grünen Klee lobt, kann nicht echt sein.
Dann gab es noch einen sehr schönen Kommentar zum Thema Pussy-Telefon.
Keine Angst, ich werde das scheiß Thema heute nicht auspacken,
habe ich zumindest nicht vor.
Aber es gab einen schönen Kommentar von H.U.K.
Und dort kam auch nochmal AI zum Einsatz. Weil ich merkte so, okay, aus Finnland,
Und hat es aber auf Deutsch geschrieben, aber es war so ein bisschen,
ich habe es laut vorgelesen und dachte mir so, so kann ich das laut nicht vorlesen.
Also habe ich mir es dann durch ChatGPT nochmal quasi so, versuche mal rauszufinden,
was hier wohl eigentlich das Wort war, was gemeint war und mach mal sozusagen den Kommentar neu.
Also ist jetzt eigentlich der echte Kommentar. Er liest sich im Blog ein bisschen
anders, aber so ist er schlüssiger.
Das nur so als Anmerkung und als Thema, wofür man das noch alles gebrauchen kann.
Zum Thema Pussy-Telefon. In Finnland sagt man umgangssprachlich Pilo Puelin.
Also so steht das jetzt da. Ich weiß nicht, aber das spricht man wahrscheinlich
nicht so aus. Was wörtlich Muschi-Telefon bedeutet.
Ich habe diesen Ausdruck zum ersten Mal in einem beruflichen Kontext gehört.
Er ist besonders witzig, weil sowohl Pilo, umgangssprachlich für Vagina,
als auch Puelin, ein Klammern-Telefon, mit dem gleichen Lautbeginn. Typischer Fachhumor.
In der Standardsprache nennt man so ein Gerät einfach Bide Suiku. Also Bidet-Dusche.
Leider halten die originalen Handstücke der klassischen Bidet-Duschen von oras.fi
nur etwa fünf Jahre, lassen sich nicht reparieren und kosten neu zwischen 23 und 30 Euro.
Zum Glück gibt es günstigere Alternativen mit stärkerer Federkraft.
Das Handstück enthält ein Ventil, das den Wasserdruck regelt,
aber nur, wenn der Wasserhahn geöffnet ist.
Deshalb muss die Wandhalterung der Bidet-Dusche über dem Wasserhahn angebracht werden.
Ob eine korrekte Montagehöhe tatsächlich verhindert, dass ein älteres Ventil
undicht wird, weiß ich allerdings nicht. So, Experten aus Finnland.
Hört auf Experten aus Finnland. Ja, postet ihr Telefon morgen bei euch.
Ich sag euch, es wird euer Leben ändern. Nachhaltig.
Soviel dazu.
So, Ralf.
Ja.
Du wolltest auch einen Kommentar oder mehrere Kommentare aufgreifen.
Jetzt eigentlich hier erstmal nur zur Tierlist kommen wir hinterher noch.
Ja.
Was uns da alles um die Ohren geworfen wurde. Ich wollte nochmal zwei,
drei Sachen sagen zu einer etwas längeren Thread-Kette zum Thema Drohnen für die Ukraine.
Da wurde uns im Kern vorgeworfen, dass das vielleicht doch etwas arg kritiklos
gewesen wäre und das sei ja gar nicht so sicher,
dass es dann überhaupt nur drohend für irgendwelche Verteidigungszwecke und
Aufklärung und ob das nicht auch durchaus in Kampfeinsätzen eine Rolle spielen könnte.
Und das stimmt, das haben wir in der Sendung nicht besonderlich weit ausgetragen.
Ich bin aber auch der Meinung, dass wenn man sich mit dem Thema wirklich differenziert
und ernst auseinandersetzen will, ist wahrscheinlich die Freakshow dann doch
nicht so ganz der richtige Kanal und wird da eher auf Tims UKW-Podcast verweisen.
Wie lange hast du da Ukraine jetzt schon drin? Im Prinzip exakt seit erster Kriegswoche.
Ja, seit drei Jahren.
Ich begleite das so alle paar Wochen, bis Monate, je nachdem wie die Taktung ist.
Und die höre ich in der Tat auch seit der allerersten Sendung dazu.
Und dort gibt sich dann doch ein allgemein Bild heraus aus der Gesamtsituation,
wo ich sage, also ich werde jetzt keinen Vorwurf machen, wenn er Drohnen für
die Ukraine produziert.
Als Vater habe ich da jetzt auch nochmal eine ganz andere Sicht drauf.
Ich finde das gerade total schwierig, wie man, wenn man Kinder hat,
eigentlich mit dem Thema umgeht.
Und jetzt gar nicht grundsätzlich mit im Sinne von so, was erzählt man denen
und guckt man irgendwie Nachrichten und wie erklärt man denen die Welt,
sondern einfach so eine ganz grundlegende Frage.
Für mich war immer völlig klar, ich bin einigermaßen strammer Pazifist immer
gewesen und dann werden die Kinder natürlich auch so erzogen.
Was heißt das jetzt irgendwie Pazifist? Also ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt,
1990, Zweiter Golfkrieg, habe ich zum Beispiel in Bochum auf der Straße Schüler-Demos
gegen den Krieg organisiert. Also schon so ein bisschen aktiver so in dem Bereich gewesen.
Und jetzt sitze ich hier im Jahr 2025 und frage mich so, ist das jetzt eigentlich
eine Einstellung, die noch so in diese Welt reinpasst?
Und all diese Sicherheiten, die man so lange hatte, kein Kriegsspielzeug und
immer überall nur ganz viel Kontext und die andere Perspektive, aber auch,
ist das jetzt eigentlich etwas, was ich noch ernsthaft irgendwie an meine Kinder
vermitteln möchte oder muss man irgendwie sagen, naja,
vielleicht bereitet man die mental schon mal besser auf die Bundeswehr vor,
weil das ist das Einzige, was hilft.
Und das finde ich persönlich super schwer zu entscheiden und glaube also weder,
dass dieser Podcast noch ein Kommentarbereich dann in dem Blog dazu irgendwie
ein geeignetes Thema ist, dann solche Themen zu beackern und würde also dann dafür werben,
dass wir das vielleicht in anderen Kanälen dann lieber tun.
Also jederzeit diskutiere ich da gerne drüber, aber das ist auch für mich persönlich,
finde ich, ein super schwieriger Themenkomplex.
Ja, ich meine, es ist natürlich so ein bisschen eine bundesrepublikanische Krankheit,
finde ich, dass wir da so ein merkwürdiges Verhältnis haben.
Ich meine, wir haben uns natürlich lange durchgemogelt mit, ja,
wir machen ja keine Kriegseinsätze, wir geben ja nur das Geld dafür und wir
bauen ja immer die Zelte und die Wasserinfrastruktur und schicken Helme,
wenn es gut läuft, genau.
5.000.
Und da haben wir uns natürlich auch alle ganz ordentlich in die Tasche gelogen.
Und das ist halt so ein bisschen so ein Sonntagspazifismus gewesen,
der eben vor allem nicht von der Realität groß herausgefordert wurde.
Und jetzt werden wir aber von dieser Realität herausgefordert und die ist halt einfach mal real.
Wer sich auch nur ein bisschen mit diesem Krieg dort beschäftigt,
weiß, dass es kein lokaler Konflikt ist, sondern das ist sozusagen wirklich
diese imperiale Attitüde Russlands, ist einfach...
Ein Problem. Das geht nicht irgendwie gegen den einzelnen Russen oder so,
aber es ist halt schon so,
dass dieses Land jetzt einfach 20 Jahre einer krassen Propaganda ausgesetzt
wurde und dazu eben die Machtinstrumente so verändert wurden,
dass jetzt ein Alleinherrscher sagt,
ich bringe euch jetzt hier alle um im Namen der Größe unseres Reiches.
Und das ist das, was da stattfindet. Und das ist halt definitiv der größte Krieg
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und wenn es so weitergeht, dann holt ihr den irgendwie auch noch ein,
was die ein oder andere Statistik betrifft.
Und wenn wir uns dann hier darüber unterhalten, wie man irgendwie einem Land,
was einfach gerade überfallen wird,
wo täglich irgendwie hunderte von ballistischen Raketen und Drohnen über den
Städten niederprasseln und wirklich jede Nacht einfach überall Häuser einstürzen,
dann finde ich das einfach nur legitim.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich auch die Aufregung über Gaza
zu Recht auch groß gewesen.
Wird aber dann irgendwie komischerweise in der Öffentlichkeit ganz anders bewertet.
Also ich will das jetzt auch nicht ewig rausziehen, aber wir haben da einfach eine klare Haltung.
Und die klare Haltung ist halt einfach, dem Land muss geholfen werden.
Und ob jetzt eine Drohne Medizin an die Front bringt oder eine Bombe,
macht in diesem Krieg wirklich keinen Unterschied, sondern geholfen wird auf beide Arten und Weisen.
Das ist doof, das ist traurig, das ist furchtbar, dass es so weit hat kommen müssen,
aber es ist nun mal einfach der Fall, weil da halt irgendwie Horden über die
Grenze gekommen sind und anfangen irgendwie die Ukraine zu überfallen und ich
finde es völlig legitim und angemessen da zu helfen.
Naja, vor allen Dingen, also ich habe das vor allen Dingen über Mastodon mitbekommen, wo halt ein User,
ich nenne es mal, gestänkert hat und ich habe da dann auch irgendwie drauf gehauen,
weil ich das irgendwie nicht passend fand, so zu tun,
als würde man jetzt irgendwie dadurch, dass man Drohnen baut,
irgendwie plötzlich zum Mörder unschuldiger russischer Soldaten werden,
Die ihr Geld damit verdienen, irgendwie in dieses Land zu kommen und alles platt zu machen,
was sie in die Finger kriegen und Butcher und die Bombardierung,
die tägliche, die zeigt einfach, so ist es halt nicht.
Also die Russen würden die Ukraine komplett platt machen, wenn sie könnten.
Können sie aber halt nicht, weil Leute Drohnen bauen und insofern hilft es.
Ja, ich würde gerne eine Sache mal öffentlich sagen.
Mir wurde ja eben Meinung unterstellt, die mir in dieser Diskussion,
die man noch vor einem Jahr sehr viel gehört hat, so komplett untergegangen ist.
Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob diese Stimmen jetzt verstummt sind von den,
ich weiß nicht, sind es Linke oder Pseudo-Linke oder Sarah Wagenknecht,
dieses ganze Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen.
Also dieses Getue, wir machen es so wie in den 80ern, hat ja damals auch geklappt
und da habe ich mich immer gefragt bei diesen Fernsehdiskussionen,
warum sagt nicht mal jemand das Allernahliegendste und das ist einfach dieses,
also um auf dieses Wort Selbstverteidigung zu kommen,
so Frau Wagenknecht, wenn Sie nachts an einem Park vorbeigehen und da wird gerade
irgendjemand brutal überfallen, was tun Sie?
So, sie haben eine Schrotflinte in der Hand. Was tun sie?
So die Fragen von Kriegsdienstverweigerern in den 80ern.
Ja, so.
Also ich habe die nicht gehört.
Aber was ich meine, das ist so einfach, wie kann man überhaupt sowas diskutieren?
Hier geht es ja um Nothilfe, also Notwehr auf der einen Seite bei der Ukraine
oder Nothilfe jetzt von unserer Seite.
Und das ist ja in keiner Form verwerflich oder verboten, sogar wenn man sich
als Pazifistin oder Pazifist bezeichnet.
Ich würde mich zum Beispiel nicht als Pazifist bezeichnen. Ich glaube,
ich habe zu viel Kampfsport gemacht in meinem Leben, um einfach zu wissen,
was passiert, wenn du die Deckung nicht hochnimmst.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich auf andere Leute zugehe und denen eine reinhauen möchte, überhaupt nicht.
Friedliebend ja, aber Pazifismus um jeden Preis, wenn ich das jetzt auf die
Spitze treibe, geht halt schief, sobald jemand anders ein Bulli ist.
Und das ist ja genau die Situation hier. Wie auf jedem Schulhof.
Das haben wir doch alle in irgendeiner Form erlebt.
Und dass da überhaupt Diskussionen drüber existieren, das macht mich noch fassungsloser als der ganze Krieg.
Ja.
So, Meinung rausgelassen, Dankeschön.
Ich denke, okay, ja, es ist super. Ich denke, wir lassen das jetzt auch mal
so stehen, könnten wir uns ja noch Stunden dran unterhalten,
aber das mache ich dann vielleicht dann doch besser bei UKW.
So, aber wir haben da zumindest Haltung.
So, kommen wir zu den etwas genüsslicheren Themen. Haben wir auch ein paar, keine Angst.
Womit fangen wir an, Reif, ich war bei dir zu Besuch.
Tim war bei mir zu Hause.
Ja.
Was seltener vorkommt, als man annimmt, weil wir irgendwie gefühlt Berlin-Nachbarn
sind, die hier 400 Meter auseinander wohnen.
Ja, ja, mit so zwei kleinen Schreihälsen ist man ja rund um die Uhr beschäftigt.
Ja, genau, weil Ralf sich ja in der letzten Sendung verkündet hat,
eine Switch 2 zugelegt hat und die wollte ich dann auch mal ausprobieren,
habe ich dann auch ausprobiert. Mario Kart habe ich ausprobiert.
Und?
Und jetzt erzähl doch mal den
Hörerinnen und Hörern, wer denn den ersten Grand Prix gewonnen hat, Tim.
Weiß nicht, wer hat denn den ersten gewonnen?
Ja, ich, du Nase. Nachdem du da voll die Welle gemacht hast.
Ich habe mich überhaupt nicht dringeworfen.
Du hast auch nicht den Grand Prix gewonnen.
Ich habe die erste Dreierstrecke Grand Prix gewonnen, ja natürlich.
Und dann hast du alles auch, also die ersten drei Rennen sind ja zusammengefasst
dann immer so ein Grand Prix.
Ich habe zwei, ich habe die ersten beiden, die überhaupt gefahren sind,
habe ich gewonnen. Die ersten beiden Strecken.
Du hast erst angefangen, überhaupt Auto zu fahren, also die Steuerung von der,
Bewegungssteuerung, äh, von der Körper.
Naja, wenn du das falsch konfigurierst, ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe Mario und K.
Das probiert.
Ich war definitiv der Beste an dem Abend. Das steht vollkommen außer Frage.
Jetzt ist ja die eigentliche Frage, wie fand ich es denn? Und ich muss sagen,
im Nachgang war ich gar nicht so begeistert, weil das braucht wohl noch ein bisschen,
Gewöhnung für mich, war einfach da ist ja so viel los also es ist einfach,
so ein bisschen wie der Unterschied von Alien zu Alien 2,
ja also in dem ersten irgendwie gibt es so ein Alien und das bringt dich irgendwie
zu Weißglut und im zweiten ist irgendwie auf einmal überall Aliens und Und das
bringt dich auch völlig um. Das ist irgendwie ein ganz anderer Ansatz.
Beides hat so seinen Thrill.
Und ganz ehrlich, der Abend war noch nicht genug.
Der Kaufreiz war nicht da bisher. Weil mir das Mario Kart noch ein bisschen too much auf einmal war.
Du sagst also Mario Kart alleine ist für dich kaufausschlaggebend.
Ja klar, ich spiele nur Mario Kart.
Nö, da haben wir das geklärt.
Das ist das Spiel, wo man anderen hinterher fährt.
Ja, wo man Autos fahren muss.
Genau, also Prinzessin retten kommt eben nicht in die Tür.
Und nicht über die Bananen fahren.
Ich mag auch das normale Super Mario und so Galaxy und so. Das ist auch okay.
Aber ich spiele eigentlich wirklich nur das.
Also ich finde das interessant, weil so ja, es ist hektisch.
Aber ich fand jetzt das Mario Kart 8 vorher auch schon super hektisch.
Also das ist für Leute meines Alters auch schon irgendwie der totale Overkill.
Von daher. ob man da jetzt,
ob da noch jetzt so viel mehr irgendwie an,
Störungen und Verwirrungen irgendwie auftaucht so könnte ich jetzt bei mir nicht
sagen also ich hatte die These aufgestellt in der letzten Sendung,
wenn du mir jetzt irgendwie beide Titel nebeneinander stellen würdest irgendwie
auf einem Screen, der jetzt irgendwie nicht 4K oder sonst was ist,
hätte ich glaube ich Schwierigkeiten da jetzt den Finger drauf zu halten,
was jetzt welche Version ist.
Was, echt, wirklich? Oh Mann, ne, das neue Mario Kart ist crowded.
Also da standen ja viel mehr Cards.
24 oder so. 24 statt 12.
Und das ist wirklich richtig, also das macht einen Riesenunterschied aus.
Also wenn es ein Setting gäbe für nur 12, dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich erstmal einstellen.
Aber es ist halt jetzt eine Stunde. Ach tatsächlich?
Ja, ich glaube, das kann man einstellen.
Umso besser. Ich werde es mir nochmal überlegen. Ansonsten, es sieht schick aus.
Diese Open-World-Sache habe ich da so ein bisschen ausprobiert.
Das ist so mit diesen Herausforderungen und so, ja, weiß nicht.
Aber was wirklich gut ist, ist dieses Ausscheidungsrennen, weil das bringt wirklich
nochmal eine ganz andere Spannung mit rein.
Also das ist dieser Modus, den es vorher nicht gab, wo man halt fährt und dann
ist glaube ich ein Parcours in so vier Teile geteilt, ist das so?
Das sind vier Teile.
Vier oder fünf Segmente.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall verschiedene Segmente. Und man muss dann halt erstmal
unter die ersten so und so viel und dann wieder vier weniger und so weiter kommen.
Und dann am Schluss muss man zu den letzten Vieren gehören, glaube ich.
Genau.
Um überhaupt eine Chance auf den Sieg zu haben. Ja.
Und die Hinteren werden halt vom Besenwagen eingekehrt.
Wobei, da musst du auch sagen, ja, hat meine Familie ja wirklich voll geliefert
und wir waren die ersten vier Plätze dann.
so schlecht waren wir da nicht ach und Geschwindigkeit meintest du noch die
150 sei quasi schon so ja stimmt.
Es ist schneller also die 150 ist das neue 200 also sie haben jetzt sozusagen 200 weggelassen was.
Ist denn die 150 und die.
200? das ist ja Kubikzentimeter das ist wie man früher Leistung angegeben hat
bei Fahrzeugen du weißt ja PS?
nee so Hubraum statt Spoiler Statt Kilowatt irgendwie.
Und damals. Jetzt gibt es nur noch 50, 100, 150 macht es ein bisschen einfacher.
Ich finde das auch besser, so aus drei auswählen und sie haben es halt sozusagen
den langsamen schneller gemacht und 100 ist das neue 150 und 150 ist das neue 200. So was.
Ja, also wir werfen das jetzt so als Familien-Event immer noch ganz gerne mal
an, aber keiner spielt jetzt irgendwie systematisch die Open-World-Sachen durch,
auch ich nicht, also dafür ist es dann irgendwie nicht spannend genug und du
hast irgendwie keinen Fortschritt oder sowas, dass du ihn irgendwie auf der
Karte sehen würdest, das hast du schon abgehakt oder so, das ist so irgendwie,
da fehlen mir auch so ein bisschen so Gamification-Elemente irgendwie.
Das spielt man auch nur alleine.
Das kann man nur alleine spielen, das ist ja auch für einen großen strategischen Fehler.
Wobei das halt wahrscheinlich nicht so ganz einfach hinzukriegen ist,
wenn dann zwei auch versuchen, zeitgleich irgendwie dieselbe Challenge zu machen
oder so, aber mein Gott, was weiß ich schon.
Aber Open Worlds sind immer schwierig. Also da sind schon ganz andere dran gescheitert.
So, wir haben den Rainbow Parcours jetzt auch freigeschaltet.
Der ist in der Tat auch wieder sehr hübsch.
Der aus dem Film. Und ansonsten wird bei uns aber nur über Pokémon gespielt.
Valix, spielst du denn sowas?
Also, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben eine Konsole besessen.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich auch erst sehr spät in meinem Leben. Das kann auch kommen.
Ja, also deswegen, ich kann mit, früher heißen die Paddles, jetzt heißen die
Controller und allem Ähnlichen überhaupt nicht umgehen. Ich bin ja so ein C64 Amiga Joystick-Kit.
Und heutzutage ist es halt bei viel zu selten Overwatch oder früher eben so
diese ganzen Blizzard-Games, was es da gab.
Also nicht die Open-World-Kram, sondern wie heißen die normalen Dinger?
Hier Warcraft. Nicht World of, sondern Warcraft, Starcraft, diese Sachen.
Und heute für so Casual-Games ist es auf dem Handy eigentlich nur,
ich gucke, wie es heißt, wenn ich es öffne, weil ich den Namen vergesse,
von Supercell Clash Royale.
Also das ist dann so mein zwischendrin daddeln. Aber ich habe auch noch nie
eine Switch in der Hand gehabt.
Deswegen kann ich gar nicht mal sagen. Also Nintendo, ich habe gar keinen Bezug zu Nintendo.
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Ich finde ja wirklich,
Nintendo ist wirklich die Ausnahme in dieser ganzen Gaming-Welt.
Es ist so ein bisschen so wie Disney im Film,
gibt es so ein Nintendo im Spiel und Apple bei den Computern also es gibt immer so einen,
Sonderplayer, der so über die Qualität und,
über so einen eigenen Charakter kommt Disney Filme,
du weißt einfach so die haben so einen Appeal so einen speziellen den muss man
nicht mögen, aber sie haben ihn,
die Singerei und der Aufwand und das Charakterding und die Storys sind schon
irgendwie auch immer sehr geil gemacht Nicht alles, aber sehr viel ist sehr gut.
Und bei Nintendo, ich finde einfach Nintendo fantastisch, weil sie irgendwie
die einzigen sind, die so ein Spielerlebnis machen, was sowohl für Kinder als
auch für Erwachsene passt, ohne dass man die ganze Zeit alle umbringen muss.
Also ich finde das einfach fantastisch.
Deswegen mag ich halt auch Mario Kart so.
Also dieser Gedanke da irgendwie durch die Gegend zu bolzen und irgendwie mit
Schildkröten um sich zu schmeißen, das ist einfach fantastisch.
Und egal wie sehr irgendwas explodiert, es gibt nur große Purzelbäume und ein
bisschen Aua Aua und Vögel im Kopf und dann ist man auch schon wieder unterwegs
und das passt irgendwie.
Man stirbt da nicht und man tötet da auch nicht und das ist irgendwie alles wunderbar verspielt.
Ich habe glaube ich in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung schon erzählt,
ich mache jetzt gerade nochmal meinen ersten richtigen Durchspielaktion von
Last of Us 2 und das ist so 180 Grad das Gegenteil von allem,
was Nintendo halt irgendwie macht.
Das ist glaube ich eines der deprimierendsten Spiele, die ich je irgendwie angefasst
habe. Das ist quasi, von Anfang bis Ende produziert das nur schlechte Laune
und schlechtes Gewissen und Depri-Stimmung.
Aber das muss man natürlich spielen.
Das erzeugt dann halt auch irgendwie etwas in allem, was dann Mario Kart bei
mir zumindest nicht produziert. Von daher muss das jetzt auch mal sein.
Ich glaube, Tim, auch unbesehen tatsächlich, dass das so ist bei Nintendo.
Das höre ich auch überall raus, wenn Leute davon reden.
Ich habe gerade überlegt, ob ich einfach noch immer gefangen bin in meiner Reaktanz
aus Amiga-Zeiten, weil ich ja immer Diana Sisters gespielt habe.
und nachdem ich jahrelang begeistert Diana Sisters gespielt habe,
kam irgendwer an und sagte, das ist ja jetzt kopiert worden.
Da gibt es irgendwelche Brüder auf dieser anderen Konsole und die hießen irgendwie
Mario und wie heißt der andere?
Luigi.
Und dann weiß man, das ist ja eine Unverschämtheit, wer ist dieses Nintendo,
wie können die mein Lieblingsspiel kopieren?
Und Diana Sisters ist halt die 1 zu 1 Kopie von Mario, whatever.
inklusive Level-Design und allem, aber wir wussten ja nichts,
wir hatten ja nichts am Krieg, nicht mal Internet.
Deswegen, innerlich habe ich wahrscheinlich immer noch einfach so eine Reaktanz,
die haben Diana Sisters kopiert, verdammte Schweine.
Obwohl es andersrum war, ne?
Obwohl es sehr andersrum war.
Die Chris-Hülsberg-Musik hat einfach gewonnen, oder so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich habe das, da bin ich ja schon wieder vom C64 weg gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
1987 ging das los.
Das haben wir bestimmt schon noch ein paar Mal gefeiert. Aber Chris Hülsbeck,
Hülsbeck ist richtig, ne?
Hülsbeck, ja.
Einer der besten deutschen Komponisten aller Zeiten. Hat, glaube ich,
wirklich nichts gemacht außer Computerspielmusik.
Oder hat das auch irgendwie mal so links und rechts nochmal probiert.
Aber das ist also die totale Bank des Amiga-Zeitalters, was der für Melodien
rausgehauen hat. Fantastisch. Also da gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwo...
Habe ich erwähnt, dass ich mal bei dem zu Hause war?
Du warst bei Chris Hülsberg zu Hause? Nichts Ahnen mit deiner Freundin.
Ja, ich war, nee, nee. Nee, nachts eingebrochen bei irgendwem und dann.
Nee, nee.
Ich habe einen Schulkameraden, muss man ja sagen.
Das ist Jens Schönfeld. Der ist so der Papst des Retro-Computing.
Es gibt, kann ich auch mal für die Interessierten den Link da lassen,
icomp.de. Das ist so der eine Anlaufort, wenn du irgendwelche C64-Erweiterungen
heute noch kaufen willst.
Der entwickelt aktiv Erweiterungen für C64, ich glaube Amiga,
ja auch Amiga auf jeden Fall und Atari ST und auch Ersatzteile und so.
Also wenn du irgendwie den Chip so und so nochmal brauchst, gibt es glaube ich
nur Jens und mit Jens waren wir damit auch auf so Demo-Partys und sowas,
weil wir hatten so Demo-Gruppen, Amiga-Demo-Gruppen und so weiter und er kannte aber,
ich glaube aus seinem Heimatort oder weil er da irgendwie involviert war,
er kannte halt Chris Hülsbeck und Chris Hülsbeck war noch nicht ganz so berühmt, wie er dann war.
Also wir waren so 18 oder so. Also wir reden von 1992.
Ich weiß nicht genau. Oder mir war der vielleicht nicht so bekannt.
Und irgendwann, da hatte ich doch gar keinen Führerschein oder so,
da fuhr ich mit Jens, fuhren wir irgendwo hin und wir machten einen Abstecher
für eine halbe Stunde zu Chris, um irgendwas abzuholen oder so.
Ich weiß es wirklich nicht mehr. Oder auf dem Weg zu einer Demo-Party.
Und dann waren wir da halt irgendwie. Es war auch gar nicht irgendwie besonders,
da ist auch nichts passiert oder wir haben nicht als Erste die neue Giana Sisters
2 Musik gehört oder so, gar nichts.
Und wir waren halt bei Chris Hülsbeck und dann so Jahre später kam mir dann
so, warte mal, den Namen kennst du doch.
Also das war wirklich meine 15 Seconds of Fame für Chris Hülsbeck,
die ich komplett verpasst habe.
Ich habe kein Selfie, ich habe nichts. Es war einfach, man war halt bei Chris
Hülsberg, es war irgendwie nett, war nerdy, wie bei uns allen,
ein Raum voller Kartons von Computerspielen und irgendwelche Geräte.
Also so wie die Meta-Ebene jetzt auch noch aussieht, nur weniger aufgeräumt.
Ja, also der...
Grüße an Chris, wenn du das hörst.
Der deutsche John Williams, der Computerspielmusik.
Gab es nicht noch irgendwie, es gab da noch einen anderen berühmten C64-Dings,
ich habe gerade mal geguckt, der Hülsberg hat ja irgendwie erst angefangen,
als ich da schon wieder weg war, das habe ich ja alles gar nicht mehr mitbekommen.
Es gab da noch so einen anderen,
Fällt euch da nichts ein?
Nee.
Wüsste ich nicht.
Ja, es gab noch andere, die sehr gute Musik... Aber ob deutsch, weiß ich nicht.
Ah ja, Rob Hubbard gab es noch.
Rob Hubbard? Ja, der war aber nicht deutsch.
Aber der hat sich ja bei LucasArts gemacht.
Er hat aber auch geniale Sachen gemacht, der Rob Hubbard.
Richtig. Genau, so Monty on the Run und Commando und so.
Commando war dieses Spiel, was ich nur gespielt habe, weil die Musik so geil war.
Ansonsten.
War das Spiel komplett scheiße.
Aber die Musik.
War so geil wir mussten es einfach immer wieder spielen.
The Last Ninja auch so ein Phänomen fantastische Musik dass ich mich heute an
den Namen erinnern kann sagt alles.
Man darf sich ja hier wiederholen du hast das Spiel immer wieder gespielt weil
du die Musik hören wolltest das ist ja etwas was man sich heutzutage so richtig
nicht klar macht dass das erforderlich war,
weil es ja keine einfache Möglichkeit gab,
die Musik anders abzuspielen oder auch nur aufzunehmen.
Also klar, man könnte so einen Kassettenrekorder, Mikrofon neben dem Computerlautsprecher
halten und wenn man ein bisschen besser drauf war, kriegte man das vielleicht auch mit Kabeln und so,
aber so auf dem Computer mal eben irgendwas doppelklicken und abspielen,
so wie wir das heutzutage machen, beziehungsweise wir haben es ja noch nicht
mal vorrätig, wir holen es uns ja eh gleich aus dem Netz, Aber das ist ja quasi
jetzt irgendwann auch normal gewesen.
Aber das war dann tatsächlich so ein bisschen auch der Beginn meines Computer-Hackings gewesen,
weil ich irgendwie dasselbe Problem hatte und dann haben wir einfach die Musik
aus den Spielen raus extrahiert.
Also wir haben sozusagen die Spiele decompiled und dann geguckt, okay,
wo ist die Musikroutine und dann haben wir quasi alles andere weggenommen und
nur diese Musikroutine als Standalone-Programm gemacht, sodass du einfach nur
ein Standalone-Programm hattest, was du starten konntest und dann kam halt die Musik.
Mucke rausziehen hieß das bei uns.
Aber das musste man auch machen, also anders ging es ja nicht.
Ja, aber nur wegen dieser Begeisterung, also ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen,
das ging uns ja genauso und deswegen war das so ein bisschen dann die Triebfeder,
ordentlich mal so die Assemblierung und solche Geschichten so machen,
was ja schon ein bisschen Arbeit ist, aber es war irgendwie ein geiler Sport
auf jeden Fall. Naja, gut.
Anyway, dann würde ich sagen, schießen wir doch mal weiter.
Wer mag den Ball aufnehmen.
Weiß nicht, machen wir noch Feedback irgendwie?
Wir machen nachher noch das Feedback zur Tierlist. Wir haben ja wieder eine
Tierlist am Start. Ralf wollte noch eine Tierlist machen, weil es ihm so gut
gefallen hat letztes Mal.
Und deswegen werden wir dann auch die Kommentare noch zur letzten Tierlist nochmal nachlegen.
Und bis dahin hauen wir mal unsere kleinen Sachen weg.
Dann würde ich mich melden, und zwar weil wir ja schon bei Musik sind.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich einen neuen Amp gekauft. Genau genommen ist es kein
Amp, wie man ihn kennt, mit Box dabei, sondern halt nur der Verstärker selber.
Und zwar gibt es da einen Wahnsinnigen, der heißt Bluk, Stefan Bluk,
glaube ich mit Vorname, weiß ich nicht. Also der Typ…,
Der ist der komplette Nerd und der hat es also geschafft, so ein Bodentretmaschinen-Dingsi
zu bauen, wo tatsächlich eine Röhre drin ist.
Und das ist wirklich ein Röhren-Amp zum auf den Boden legen,
wo man unten ein Kabel einsteckt, dann kommen 100 Watt raus.
Und es klingt wirklich sagenhaft, das Teil.
Also ich bin sowas von angetan.
Mein Problem ist, dass der Amp, den ich habe, der macht gerade so Abrauchanstalten.
Ich muss den irgendwann dann mal auseinandernehmen
und alles nachlöten und Kondensatoren tauschen und so weiter.
Dann geht er bestimmt auch wieder, die Röhren sauber machen und so.
Ist ja Analogtechnik, kann man ja alles reparieren.
Aber jetzt habe ich halt erstmal dieses Teil an den Start gebracht und benutze
halt einfach den Lautsprecher von dem Amp, den ich bisher hatte.
Und der klingt fast ein bisschen besser.
Also das ist schon… Also Amp.
Wir reden jetzt von Gitarrenmusik.
Wir reden von… Ja, das hätte ich vielleicht dazu sein.
Ein Gitarren-Amp. Ja, weil ich meine Amp kann ja… Gitarren-Verstärker.
Ein Gitarren-Verstärker. Das Teil ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Ding,
weil es ist tatsächlich weitestgehend analog,
hat aber auch so ein paar Digitaleffekte drin, wie zum Beispiel einen digitalen
Spiralhall und nochmal so eine Art digitale Röhrenvorstufe.
Also es ist wirklich sehr, sehr weird, aber er klingt gut.
Er hat keine Latenz, also zumindest keine, die ich wahrnehme und ist einfach
großartig und ist robust und man kann einfach überall mit hinnehmen und fertig.
Spannend.
Ich habe das Ding in der Mercury Edition und zwar ist die Mercury Edition die, die,
mehr so nach 60er, 70er Jahre klingt, vielleicht ein bisschen 80er weil das
Ding nicht so heftig übersteuert, den gibt es noch in einer, wie heißt die andere ähm,
Die Ridium Edition heißt sie. Das ist eher so für den geneigten Metal-Konnoisseur.
Also der, den ich jetzt habe, der hat drei Verzerrungsstufen.
Eine, die nennt sich Vintage, klingt auch ein bisschen Vintage.
dann eine, die heißt Classic.
Das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Geht so in Richtung, würde ich sagen,
so AC-DC und dann noch ein Modern.
Das geht dann schon eher in Richtung Metal.
Und ja, also ich kann den wirklich empfehlen. Und das Teil, das ist wirklich
super robust. Das ist auch nicht so schwer, wie das Teil aussieht.
Aber er ist halt auch so, man stellt ihn auf den Boden und dann tritt man da
drauf und hat dann mal clean, mal nicht clean, mal mit Hall und fertig.
Also es tut wirklich einige wenige Dinge sehr gut.
Und da bin ich ja großer Fan davon. Es gibt auch keine Software,
um das Ding irgendwie einzustellen oder so.
Sondern man stellt ihn hin, dreht an den Knöpfen und dann tut er.
Does it go up to 11? Ja, nicht so richtig.
Aber dafür haben sie ein Sichtfenster für die Röhre.
Dafür haben sie ein Sichtfenster für die Röhre, genau.
Damit es auch true ist.
Den einzigen Kritikpunkt, den ich hätte, ist, dass da ein bisschen viel blaue
Leuchtdiode verbaut ist.
Blaue Leuchtdioden, das hatten wir vor über zehn Jahren, glaube ich,
schon mal in der Freakshow, gehen halt gar nicht.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Also das ist ein bisschen schade, aber ansonsten, und er hat auch die Fußtreter,
die leuchten, auch so ein ganz klein bisschen, wenn sie nicht getreten sind,
Also man findet sie auch wieder auf einer dunklen Bühne und so.
Sieht deutlich, ob sie getreten sind oder nicht. Also ich bin wirklich sehr angetan.
Ja, ich habe meine Gitarren jetzt an die Wand gehängt im Wohnzimmer,
damit ich täglich sie anschauen kann und ein schlechtes Gewissen entwickeln kann.
Sehr gut, so muss es sein.
Das ist schon der halbe Mitleid-Crisis.
Ja, ich habe so eine schöne Les Paul da hängen.
Du hast dir lieber Motorrad.
Ja, ja, ja.
Hänge das an die Wand und kriege ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich finde das Ding faszinierend. Auch den Preis tatsächlich.
Das kostet ja irgendwie 870 Euro, das Ding.
Und das finde ich interessant, weil das ist ja die Gegenbewegung zu dem,
was sonst alle anderen machen. Ich hatte bei meinem letzten Besuch in der Freakshow
ja mal erzählt, wie meine Band das inzwischen alles so macht mit den digitalen
Amps, die extern gesteuert werden.
Das müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal alles aufwärmen.
Und ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen zwischen den Welten.
Das können die Hörerinnen und Hörer jetzt gerade nicht sehen,
aber wenn man genau auf den Beamer guckt, dann sieht man hinter dieser Gitarre,
die da steht, sieht man noch einen Röhren-Amp stehen.
Da sieht man zwei goldene Ecken davon hervorblitzen.
Das ist der Amp, den ich habe, seit ich 18 bin. Also hier ist eine Gitarren-Kombo in meinem Wohnzimmer.
Kombo deswegen, weil da eine Box verbaut ist und ein Amp, sodass man einfach
eine Gitarre dran steckt und dann hat man Lärm.
Und dieses Ding habe ich jetzt gerade für Geld nochmal general überholen lassen,
weil jetzt bin ich 51, wie lange habe ich das Ding? Eins im Sinn, viele Jahre.
Da sind die Potis natürlich irgendwann mehrfach durch. Also ich habe zum zweiten
Mal, glaube ich, die ganzen Potis tauschen müssen. Aber der funktioniert halt,
wie Roddy sagt, Analogtechnik, kann man immer wieder reparieren.
Das ist halt ein altes Radio und das läuft so. Und deswegen bin ich so zwischen den Welten.
Ich bin zwischen, ich habe so richtig alt und analog und da ist das Spiralhall
halt eine echte Spirale, die da drinnen rumschwingt.
Und in der Band haben wir halt nur noch alles digital und wird nur noch Computer
ferngesteuert und Zeug. Und dieses Ding geht ja genau den anderen Weg.
Da hat sich jemand gedacht, ich mache jetzt ein relativ hochpreisiges,
aber kompaktes Oldschool-Gerät, aber auch für den echten Live-Einsatz.
Und das habe ich lange nicht gesehen. Also, dass da so jemand sozusagen Innovation
bringt bei dem Thema, was nicht bedeutet, komplett digital mit AI. Spannend.
Ja, also die Endstufe ist auch digital, sonst würde das auch nicht funktionieren.
Deswegen ist es so eine ganz merkwürdige Chimäre, aber so rein von der Usage,
vom User Interface ist es wie ein analoger Amp und fertig.
Ja, sweet. Spielst du denn damit auch live, live? Alle Hunde tot?
Sagen wir mal so, wir hatten ein Gig geplant.
Deswegen habe ich das Ding dann auch relativ kurzfristig rangeholt.
Wie gesagt, weil mein bisheriger M. Zicken gemacht hat.
Und dann stellte sich aber heraus, dass der Veranstalter von den Nachbarn Stress
bekommen hat und hat kurzzeitig den Gig wieder abgesagt.
Insofern habe ich ihn noch nicht live gespielt, aber ich werde ihn dann live
spielen, wenn es soweit ist. Wenn es eine Antwort ist.
Ich dachte gerade, berühmte letzte Worte, jeder Band. Wir hatten einen Gig geplant.
Naja, der wurde, aber wie gesagt, er wurde vom Veranstalter abgesagt, nicht von uns.
Ja, okay.
Und es tat ihm auch fürchterlich leid, aber es war halt Stress irgendwie.
Ja, cool.
Genau, spiele ich da auch alle bestimmt. Das wollen ja immer alle hören, insofern.
Es hilft ja nichts, wenn man nur einen Hit hat, dann muss man den halt spielen.
Muss man spielen. Ich gucke gerade, ich habe den mal gerade rausgesucht für
die Shownotes und sehe gerade also der, ist das euer Account?
Nein, das ist nicht unser Account. Irgendjemand hat den da hochgeladen.
Okay, weil es war, dieser Account hat 22 Abonnenten, aber 16.000 Aufrufe beim Song.
Ich habe gedacht, okay, das ist ein Hit.
Sehr schön.
Alright, wo wir gerade bei Gadgets, die wir uns gerade gekauft haben,
hast du da auch gerade noch ein Gadget?
Ich habe auch noch ein Gadget.
Möchtest du zuerst?
Ja, ich mache mal schnell.
Ja.
So, das ist also, ihr erinnert euch, wo Roddy hier seine Wärmebildkamera angeschleppt hat?
Wo ich dachte so.
Kommt jetzt wieder so ein, wie man hier sieht, Segment?
Jetzt kommt im wahrsten Im wahrsten Sinn des Wortes kommt das jetzt, genau.
Weil ich war sehr neidisch und dachte so, diese Kategorie Geräte,
die man nicht wirklich braucht oder man hat erstmal keinen Use Case,
bis man sie hat und dann findet man vielleicht doch einen.
Ich habe mir das hier zugelegt. Ich habe jetzt hier ein ungefähr DIN A4.
Wie man hier sieht.
Oh, ah. Ungefähr,
DIN A4 groß. Die Packung, seht ihr schon, was es ist?
Es hat einen Griff.
Es hat einen Griff und Knöpfe.
Ich hoffe, das muss man nicht irgendwie anal einführen, weil so sieht es gerade aus.
Lass uns überlegen.
Ich glaube, das bringt keine Punkte.
Wie sieht das aus? Man ahnt schon, das Ganze hat ein Display und man hat aber
einen großen, stabilen Griff und jetzt hat man hier eine kabelartige so Schwanenhalskonstruktion.
So was Stethoskop. Eine Stethoskop-Kamera.
Eine Endoskop-Kamera.
Wo muss man das reinmachen?
Das erzählen.
Ist das jetzt die Ergänzung zum Pussy-Telefon?
Erst gucken, dann reichblasen.
Und spätestens jetzt sind die Hörer froh, dass sie kein Bild haben.
Also, ich mache mal eben hier vor der Linse die...
So, und jetzt sehen wir in der Tat, dass ich also einen Schwanhals habe. Wie lang wird der sein?
Meter.
Magst du uns diesen Produktnamen benennen oder ist der noch geheim?
Endoskopkamera heißt das Ganze.
Das ist doch kein Produktname. Von Temu.
Das ist eine Produktkategorie.
Aber wie sollen, achso, der Produktname selber meinst du?
Ja.
Endo Plus von Shang Hong oder was?
Das ist in der Tat vom Aldi. Und zwar.
Auch Aldi, schöne Dinge.
Die Aldi Nord-Ferex-Endoskopkamera.
Ja, exakt. Für 29,99 Euro.
Nein.
So, und genau, also ungefähr ein Meter Schwanhals. Dann halt geht das in dieses
Handgriffstück ein mit einem relativ großen Display.
Das Display ist in Farbe. Ist also auch nicht nur schwarz-weiß, sondern in Farbe.
Und man kann halt vorne, also grundsätzlich Endoskop, ja, mit einer kleinen
Kamera an Orte vordringen, wo man normalerweise nicht drankommt.
So, kennt man eigentlich aus dem medizinischen Bereich.
Das war der Anlass.
Und ich wusste in der Tat nicht, dass es das so für den zivilen Gebrauch jenseits
von Medizin auch ganz normal so gibt.
Und ich hatte aber nämlich ein Use Case, wo ich dachte, das ist mir jetzt genau diese 29 Euro wert.
Und zwar mein Waschtrockner.
Dein Waschtrockner?
Mein AEG Waschtrockner.
Lass mich raten, es hat die ganze Zeit die Lampe aufgeleuchtet,
dass das Flusensieb gereinigt werden muss und du hast das Flusensieb schon 10
mal gereinigt, aber er piept immer noch.
Ja, so in etwa. Beziehungsweise, also er hat noch nicht mal irgendwelche Fehlermeldungen
geworfen, sondern er trocknet einfach nicht mehr.
So, also erstmal, was ist ein Waschtrockner? Ihr kennt Waschmaschinen, ihr kennt Trockner.
Ein Waschtrockner hat die Verheißung, beide Schritte in ein und demselben Gerät unterzubringen.
Hab ich gerade erworben.
Und ist es denn auch, was für ein Modell und was für eine Bauart?
Wie eine Bauart?
Naja, schon.
Welche denn?
Ob da eine Wärmepumpe drin ist, hinten, oder ist es über Abluft?
Die Trockenwirkung. Das sind ja die beiden.
Ich habe einfach Miele gekauft. Ich weiß, wenn man eine Waschmaschine kauft,
kauft man eine Miele. Alles andere ist Unsinn.
Das habe ich auch bisher so gehalten. Keine Ahnung, ob man dafür zu viel Geld ausgibt oder nicht.
Bei mir funktioniert seit 30 Jahren AEG.
Ja, damals war AEG auch noch gut.
Nehmen nur vor Kriegsgeräte.
AEG habe ich eben genau und zwar, warte mal, welches Modell ist das hier? AEG 9000.
Gewisse Abschweifung findet statt.
Ja, es wird sich gleich so und das Besondere an dem ist nämlich Sensi 3 oder sowas,
dass der halt, genau, also Wärmepumpentechnologie, das heißt also die Flüssigkeit,
wird eben nicht dann bei irgendeinem Rohr, wo man dann wieder was anschließen
muss oder sowas gemacht, sondern das Gerät verdaut quasi die,
Feuchtigkeit aus der Wäsche selber.
Ohne, dass es also auch in die Raumluft übergeht und irgendwie dann der Raum,
in dem das Ganze steht, irgendwie dann total vor Luftfeuchtigkeit irgendwie birst.
Und das ist einer der ganz wenigen, die das haben.
Aber der Vorteil eines Waschtrockenes ist doch, dass er sowieso an einen Abwasseranschluss
angeschlossen ist und das Wasser da einfach entsorgen kann.
Ja, aber nur, wenn es flüssig ist.
Naja, es kondensiert ja.
Ja, aber nur dann, wenn du eben auch die Wärmepumpe da drin hast,
die eine kalte Fläche macht, um das Wasser dann von Dampf wieder zurück in flüssig zu.
Ah, dann habe ich das wohl.
Wie auch immer. Uns wurde versprochen, das sei also das totale rechts unten
Modell in Bezug Waschtrockner.
Aha.
Das war auch sehr, sehr teuer. Heißt? Was haben wir bezahlt? 1400?
So irgendwas um den Dreh. Und nach einem Vierteljahr hat das halt nicht mehr
getrocknet. So wäscht noch super.
Alle Fussel, Siebe regelmäßig gereinigt. Alles kein Problem,
aber er trocknete halt nicht mehr.
Und das ist dann immer so der Moment, wo ich dann überlege, okay,
ist das jetzt irgendwie was elektronisches oder ist das eher was mechanisches
und bei allem, was dann irgendwie mit Strom zu tun hat, da hole ich dann doch lieber.
Expertin, aber wenn es irgendwie so in Richtung naja, könnte auch irgendwas
mechanisches sein, irgendein Sieb, was man halt irgendwie übersehen hat,
dann mache ich das doch auch ganz gerne selber und gucke erstmal,
wo kriegt man es aufgeschraubt und dann kann man halt dann aufschrauben,
das ist also oben die Deckel ab und dann sieht man.
Dass also dieses Teil eine komplette Fehlkonstruktion ist.
Weil das eigentliche Fusselsieb ist oben, dass man es gut rausholen kann und gut reinigen kann.
Ist also nichts, wo man jetzt irgendwie was groß einführt oder sonst wie macht,
sondern man kann also das ganze Fusselsieb quasi so rausziehen und dann vernünftig reinigen.
Und da ist aber, damit das Ganze irgendwie cool wirkt, ist ein Federmechanismus
drin verbaut in diesem Fusselsieb.
So dass man also nur, wenn man einmal auf so einen Knopf drückt,
dann springt es einem so ein bisschen entgegen und dann kann man es ganz entspannt rausziehen.
Wäre aber gar nicht nötig, weil man könnte es auch einfach oben an der Kante
festhalten und rausziehen, ohne dass man diesen Federmechanismus bräuchte.
Der Federmechanismus sorgt aber dafür, dass zwischen diesem Fusselsieb und dem,
wo dann eigentlich hinterher die Abluft weitergeht, eine Lücke entsteht.
Und diese Lücke diffundiert einfach die ganzen Fussel.
Das heißt also, das ist nicht dicht dadurch, dass da zu viel Druck auf dieser Feder drauf ist.
Und das habe ich alles mal irgendwie, das Internet sagt dasselbe,
Ja, also das ist quasi ein bekanntes Problem.
Man fragt sich, warum konstruiert man sowas?
Und ich wollte jetzt aber wissen, also ich habe das dann dadurch einfach behoben,
indem ich einfach die Feder rausgebaut habe aus diesem Federmechanismus.
Es hüpft einem jetzt nicht mehr entgegen, sondern man muss es einfach nur ganz
entspannt rausziehen, aber sorgt dafür, dass es hinten die Sache dicht ist und
plötzlich trocknet sie auch wieder.
So, ich habe das Ganze mit viel Aufwand auch irgendwie alles gereinigt und diese
ganzen Fussel an völlig verqueren Stellen alles irgendwie rausgeholt.
Und dann gab es aber eben dann dieses Abluftrohr, wo ich wissen wollte,
so habe ich das jetzt eigentlich wirklich sauber bekommen.
Und dort habe ich jetzt also meine Endoskopkamera, die auch vorne ein Licht
schalten kann, wo man also Licht an- und ausmachen kann.
Ansonsten siehst du in diesem dusteren Rohr ja mal einfach gar nichts.
Aber dann schiebt man jetzt also diese Endoskopkamera in dieses Abluftrohr rein
und kann also genau gucken, was da Phase ist.
Und habe dann gesehen, bis zu dem finalen Sieb war also alles schön sauber.
So und wenn man dann anfängt ein bisschen nachzudenken, merkt man so,
es gibt viele Orte, wo man mal hingucken würde.
Jetzt wird es interessant. Also ich meine, Waschdruckner, okay.
Du hast mir jetzt ein bisschen Angst gemacht, dass meine Miele mir auch nochmal
Sorgen bereitet. Aber ich bin ehrlich gesagt noch der Auffassung,
dass man bei Miele irgendwie safe ist.
Bisher finde ich das Ding, ehrlich gesagt, unglaublich wartungsarm.
Also man hat diesen Trocknungsmodus und dann kommt die Wäsche da trocken raus
und dann sind es noch so ein paar Restflusen in der Maschine.
Und dann gibt es ein spezielles Spülprogramm dafür, was nochmal 10 Minuten nachspült
und dann ist auch wieder alles weg.
Das war sozusagen bisher alles, was ich damit gemacht habe. Ich habe jetzt noch
nicht solche Mengen gemacht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie in den Verstopfmodus komme,
aber vielleicht passiert das ja gar nicht.
Jetzt überlege ich gerade, wo ich dieses Endoskop reinmachen kann.
Also es muss man auch nicht rein, sondern es kann auch einfach dahinter sein.
Beispielsweise, wie sind denn die Anschlüsse an meinem Desktop-Rechner oder am Mixer?
Ja, ja.
Kann das Ding auch streamen? Das kann streamen und das kann auf SD-Karte aufzeichnen.
Sowohl Fotos als auch Videos.
Und wie streamt das wohin?
Indem du ein USB-Kabel anschließt.
USB-C. Dann ist es ein Videoeingang.
Dann ist es ein Videoeingang. Ach, guck an. Für 29,99 Euro. Für 29,99 Euro.
Bei Aldi Nord.
Wow.
So, ich habe zum Beispiel einen riesen Fernseher bei mir an der Wand.
Da ist die Halterung macht irgendwie gerade ein Problem so und dann schiebst
du jetzt halt einfach diese Kamera da durch und guckst so, was ist denn da eigentlich
Phase, ohne den also irgendwie abmontieren zu müssen oder ähnliches.
Und ein totales Killer-Feature, das habe ich jetzt noch nicht gebraucht,
ist, dass damit zusammen auch
noch so ein paar Instrumente mitverkauft werden. Ich packe die mal aus.
Nämlich, ihr werdet dann gleich sehen, wofür die wohl gut sind.
Also ihr an den Empfangsgeräten werdet es sich nicht haben.
Musik-Instrumente?
So, guck mal hier, Da sind nämlich noch solche Widerhaken-Schnupsis hier dabei.
Ein Magnet war da auch, oder?
Ein Magnet ist da auch noch. Das heißt also, wenn einem irgendwas Magnetisches
mal irgendwo hinfällt und man kommt nicht dran,
dann klippt man diesen Aufsatz vorne dran und hat ein Magnet mit Licht und kann
irgendwo hinter der Couch oder sonst wo den Ehering, den man vorher abgezogen hat.
Warum auch immer. Wenn er magnetisch ist.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen.
Sind Ehringe eher selten, oder?
Hier hast du noch einen Minispiegel. Guck mal, das ist auch cool.
Für den Zahnarzt unter uns.
Dann kannst du auch nochmal um die Ecke gucken, wenn du also die letzte Biegung
irgendwie nicht klar genug hast.
Das ist ja noch so ein Minispiegel und zwei verschiedene Haken,
um auch irgendwelche Sachen, die wo reingefallen sind, dann wieder rauszuageln.
Ja, nee, das wollen wir eher so.
Also, habt ihr das Bild von Munkel gesehen? Slack dazu, es ist hilarious.
Man sieht einen Schwanenralf. Einen Schwanenralf mit Schwanenhals.
Was hat AI für uns getan?
Deine Einsortierung ins Marvel-Universum. Endo, man.
Ja, gar Gadgetto-Ralf.
Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, ja, das gibt es alles in viel besser und qualitativ
und länger gibt es das mit Sicherheit auch.
Also Meter ist vielleicht manchmal schon ein bisschen zu kurz.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass man das noch gerne in zwei Meter auch hätte.
Glaube ich aber fast, dass es standardisiert ist, diese Schwanhälse,
dass man die wahrscheinlich auch austauschen könnte.
Aber jetzt, um überhaupt erstmal so ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen,
ist das nützlich oder nicht.
Ich finde das irgendwie saukool und mir fallen im Tagestakt neue Orte ein,
wo ich jetzt endlich mal gucken kann, was denn da eigentlich los ist.
Sag mal ein paar.
Also hinterschränken. Lohnt es sich, diesen Schrank vorzuschieben,
weil da irgendwelche Dinge hintergefallen sind oder nicht?
Insbesondere auch bei mir hinterm Bett gibt es irgendwie so Orte,
wo also regelmäßig irgendwie aufgrund einem nicht ganz abschließenden Regalbrettes Dinge runterfallen.
Und bevor ich dann immer den ganzen Hässel mache und das irgendwie durch die
Gegend schiebe, guckt man jetzt einfach mal nach. Lohnt es sich überhaupt?
Oder kann das dann noch ein Vierteljahr länger liegen bleiben?
Da ist noch gar nicht genug dahinter, das lohnt nicht.
Was du hier gerade eben hattest, Verkabelung prüfen. Irgendwie meine Stereoanlage.
Ich habe ja noch eine relativ alte analoge Stereoanlage und die ist halt so
reingebaut in so eine Kiste und die rauszuziehen ist ein Riesenakt,
weil natürlich alle Kabel irgendwie dann nicht lang genug sind,
dass man das Ganze irgendwie elegant rausholen kann und wenn man den Eindruck
hat, ist da jetzt ein Wackelkontakt oder nicht, schiebt man einfach so die Kamera dahinter.
Also das ist schon was...
Was ganz was Feines.
Hat jemand ein USB-C-Kabel? Ich habe hier gerade keins. Es kann nicht sein,
dass ich hier kein USB-C-Kabel habe.
Den wohl sortierten.
Ich bin beruhigt, dass wir das auch nicht.
Die Steckschubladen sollten doch USB-C-Kabel sein.
Ja, ja. Ah, habe ich.
Ralf, ich wollte dich nicht derailen, aber jetzt sagt Tim gerade USB-C-Kabel
und das ist ein kleines Seitenthema, was perfekt dort anschließen würde.
Warte mal, ich muss erstmal hier die Streaming-Funktion ausprobieren hier.
live, wie man jetzt gerade sieht.
Wie man gerade schön sieht.
So.
Und. Ah.
Wie Sie sehen.
Entschuldigung, jetzt bin ich hier gleich mit dem Endoskop aufs Mischpult gekommen.
Und hast irgendjemand gemültet.
Jetzt sagt er aber Mass Storage. Jetzt kann ich hier sozusagen nur drauf,
auf die Dateien zugreifen.
Ja, nee, es müsste eigentlich auch der Video-Feed gehen. habe ich noch nicht
ausprobiert, stand dabei eine Anleitung drin.
Das ist vielleicht wie beim Zoom H6.
Das ist so ein anderer Modus.
Ja, ja, da muss man sich vielleicht erstmal durchs Menü noch irgendwo klicken.
Muss ich das vorher machen.
Für Endos.
Das hätte ich ja jetzt ganz cool gefunden. Na gut, also,
hinter den Schrank gucken und so weiter, das würde mir ja noch nicht ausreichen.
Gut, du hast ja die Ausrede gehabt mit dem Waschtrockner, das ist okay, das kann ich verstehen.
Der sagt goodbye, wenn man das Kabel abzieht.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn man so einen Campingwagen hat oder einen
Wohnwagen, da ist dann nicht alles super kompakt hinter irgendwelchen Wänden verbaut.
Und dann, wenn man dann die Elektrik sowieso täglich neu bastelt oder so,
könnte doch Ausrede genug sein für 29,95.
Wink, wink, nudge, nudge.
War das so toll.
Äh äh äh äh.
Ja, ich muss gerade daran denken, dass unser Bassist Jens, der baut ja unser
Rack zusammen, also das ist so ein 12-HA-Rack, glaube ich, und das ist von beiden
Seiten, also so ein offener,
rechteckiger Schrank und von beiden Seiten sind da Geräte absolut kompakt reingebaut
und dazwischen, zwischen den Geräten auf der Innenseite sind etwa,
ich weiß nicht, 150 Kabel oder so gesteckt und das ist so kompakt auf jeden
Stecker berechnet, wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass da innen drin irgendwas nicht
geht, baust du halt einfach dieses ganze Ding auseinander.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, wie man den Millennium Falcon aus Lego hat und dann
feststellt, dass innen drin irgendwas anders muss.
Und das sind so Momente, wo ich mir gerade so denke, okay, vielleicht möchte
man dann auch so ein Ding haben.
Ja, aber ich meine mit diesen Geräten, das ist ja so, ich meine,
ich weiß ja nicht, wie ihr es so mit eurer Ordnung so haltet in der Wohnung,
aber ich habe mir dann irgendwann mal so die Regel auferlegt,
wenn ich mir ein Gerät kaufe, wenn ich mir irgendetwas kaufe, ein Möbel,
egal was, dekorativer Kram, Dinge betreten die Wohnung und wollen dort bleiben,
dann müssen sie einen Ort haben.
Und mit diesen ganzen Geräten, mit denen man so Single-Use hat,
dann hat man also irgendwann so einen ganzen Keller voll mit so Single-Use-Geräten
für, naja, das könnte ich ja irgendwann mal gebrauchen und dann nutzt man sie nicht.
Also ich sag nur Ozongenerator, das brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht. immer in seinem Leben.
Habe ich aber jetzt zumindest gerade mal erfolgreich verliehen bekommen.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Ich finde, das ist wie mit einem Pool.
Man muss nicht selber einen haben, man muss Freunde haben, die einen haben.
Oder im Haus, ja. Dafür finde ich, gilt in der Tat auch noch,
neben an.de und sowas, es fehlt noch eine gemeinnützige Infrastruktur,
wo man innerhalb von einem Mehrparteienhaus einen gemeinsamen Pool an sinnvoll
ausleihbaren Dingen irgendwie verwalten kann.
Da gibt es ja jetzt diese ganzen Nachbarschaft, Social Networks,
wo sowas organisiert wird.
Oder der WhatsApp-Chap des Hauses.
Ja, aber du musst halt erstmal ja eigentlich so deinen Shopping-Bereich haben.
Also mir fehlt da so die Datenbank-Anbindung, dass man einfach mal sehen kann,
so was gibt es denn alles?
Also teilweise kommst du ja auch erst auf Ideen, wenn du erstmal siehst, so oh ich könnte.
Naja, aber manche Sachen, die so im Werkzeugbereich sind, die will man schon haben.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich will das ja auch haben.
Ich habe neulich eine Heißluftpistole gekauft, so ein Heißluftföhn-Dingsi,
der so in 10 Grad Schritten irgendwie zu regeln ist.
Wofür?
Eigentlich um Schrumpfschläuche zu schrumpfen.
Ja, da geht aber auch ein Föhn.
Da geht im Prinzip auch ein Föhn, aber ich habe auch keinen ordentlichen Föhn.
Also insofern, aber ich habe jetzt neulich eine andere...
Daher die Frisur.
Du hast mein Geheimnis ausgeplaudert.
Wie Sie gerade sehen.
Wie Sie schön sehen können, ja. Nee, und mir hat irgendwie diese komische Folie,
die der Hersteller meines Autos an Selbiges angebracht hat, nicht mehr gefallen.
Und die habe ich jetzt mithilfe des Heifluftföhns entfernt.
Statt da was drauf?
Nee, das war einfach nur Silber und hatte sechseckige Löcher.
Ja, ich kenne das Problem.
Und die habe ich entfernt und jetzt sieht das Auto meiner Meinung nach viel besser aus.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich finde so Werkzeuge, naja gut, jetzt habe ich,
meine Mutter hat mir irgendwie zwei,
ein Bohrhammer und eine Bohrmaschine übergeholfen, hatte sie noch über.
Jetzt habe ich glaube ich drei Bohrmaschinen und zwei Bohrhämmer zu Hause,
das ist jetzt ein bisschen viel. Also das ist so, braucht man eigentlich.
Zwei Bohrmaschinen und zwei Bohrhemmer.
Drei Bohrmaschinen, ich glaube es sind drei Bohrmaschinen.
Hast du auch einen Impact Driver?
Impact Driver?
Ja.
Nee, habe ich glaube ich nicht.
Aber du hast einen Akkuschrauber.
Ich habe einen Akkuschrauber, aber der schraubt so ein bisschen auf dem letzten
Loch. Ich überlege einen neuen Akkuschrauber anzubeschaffen.
Ja, da musst du aber echt mal drüber nachdenken, ob du vielleicht schon immer
einen Impact Driver gebraucht hast.
Aber man braucht erstmal einen Akkuschrauber in seinem Leben.
Aber es gibt glaube ich Momente...
Ja, ich habe einen. Es ist nur so, dass er eventuell nicht mehr allzu lange lebt.
Wir müssen das auch nicht weiter vertiefen.
Also Bosch Grün ist halt einfach eine dumme Idee.
So, wolltest du gerade noch irgendwie, hast du auch noch irgendein Gadget mal
legt oder hattest du, glaube ich, kurz Ja.
Gadget ist, ne, wir sind noch nicht ganz, es war nur das Thema USB-C-Kabel,
denn bei mir ist die Transition in Richtung USB-C, dadurch, dass ich mir letztens
einen M4 MacStudio auch gegönnt habe.
Jetzt weitgehend abgeschlossen.
Das heißt aber, jetzt plötzlich habe ich noch zu viele Kabel,
die USB-A auf USB-C haben und der hier sendungsbekannte Abdel Kader hat mir
auch letztens als Hörer geschenkt, netterweise auch einen 5 Volt Auto Adapter,
geschenkt, der auch ein USB-A und ein USB-C hat.
Das wäre jetzt im Auto das erste Mal, dass USB-C bei mir so ans Leben kommt,
weil mein alter Adapter war irgendwie kaputt und jetzt saß ich da im Auto und
ich kann ja den USB-A Stecker von diesem Doppelstecker auch benutzen, aber wir leben 2025 und
Ja, und dann stellte ich fest, okay, ich habe noch mindestens fünf Kabel USB-A
auf USB-C, sogar neue, die ich irgendwie noch in den letzten Zügen gekauft habe
für die Transition, aber ich habe auch sehr wenige USB-C auf USB-C.
Und dann ist man ja sofort bei dem Problem, was kann denn dieses Kabel?
Und das eine ist so dieses Datenübertragungsproblem, was man ab und zu vielleicht hat.
Man will die externe SSD anschließen und hat da so ein Kabel und will wissen, was geht da durch.
Aber auch was Strom angeht, da habe ich noch viel weniger Ahnung als von allem,
ist so, welches USB-C auf C-Kabel möchte man denn haben, damit man kein Problem
hat, so ein iPhone da dran zu stecken und dass da nicht nur 5 Watt,
sondern 15 kommen oder so.
Und woran erkennt man es und welches will man? Und ich dachte vielleicht,
ihr werft sofort, ihr seid Nerds, ihr wisst was von Technik.
Ihr werft sofort den Link rüber, mein Problem ist gelöst.
Also in Freakshow 276 mit dem schönen Titel Remember we are in the 80s, so dress accordingly.
Das ist eines meiner besten Episodenbilder ever.
Zum Thema AI. Habe ich tatsächlich meine USB-C Kabeltester vorgestellt,
aber das handelte sich dabei um reine Funktionstester, also Pinout-Tester.
Das ist die billigere Variante. Das heißt, da kannst du dann überhaupt erstmal
sehen, ob du nur so ein USB 3, 3.1, 3.2 hast, also die Kategorie,
also wie schnell kannst du da Daten mit übertragen.
Es sagt aber meiner Meinung nach nichts über Leistungsfähigkeit in Bezug auf Strom aus.
Da brauchst du dann einen USB-C-Tester, der diese digitale Information ausliest,
weil ja diese ganzen USB-C-Geräte oder die...
Also wenn spezielle Funktionen vorliegen, dann melden die sich sozusagen auch
mit Protokoll und geben darüber Auskunft, was sie quasi können.
Und da brauchst du dann eben schon einen more sophisticated USB-C-Kabeltester.
So einen habe ich nicht, deswegen kann ich da jetzt auch keine Empfehlungen
geben. Ich weiß nur, dass es diese Geräte gibt, die sind aber dann teurer.
Man möchte natürlich auch getestet haben, bevor man kauft. Also gibt es nicht
irgendeine Bezeichnung?
Also wo man sagt, okay, such bei Amazon nach dem Begriff XY und dann hast du
auf jeden Fall ein Kabel, was das kann.
Hier kommen schon links natürlich. Natürlich von ab der Kader und Q.
Aber das ist der Tester, okay.
Ich meine, der Primärunterschied bei den Kabeln ist, also du willst halt alle
Datenleitungen connected haben, damit du eben USB 3.2 machen kannst.
Das ist quasi das schnellste USB mit 5 Gigabit.
Oder? Ja.
Aber für das Auto wäre es halt egal.
Es ist egal, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, die Kategorie von Kabeln,
die man so als normale USB-C Kabel kauft.
Dann gibt es halt noch die Thunderbolt Fegen, also quasi USB 4,
ist ja dann quasi mit Thunderbolt 4.
Und das sind aber dann eben auch schon die etwas teureren, etwas dickeren Kabel.
Das heißt, klar, man kann sagen, man sollte nur die kaufen, weil dann hat man
immer maximale Datenübertragung.
Andererseits, aus eigener Erfahrung, selten habe ich so, also ich habe jetzt
wirklich nicht so viele Thunderbolt-Devices, die miteinander verbunden werden müssen.
Das ist halt so der Rechner und der Bildschirm und wenn du eine externe SSD anschließt,
dann willst du natürlich definitiv da ins Gold reingreifen aber das allermeiste
was du anschließt, also Ladekabel sowieso erstmal,
also zum Laden ist es halt wirklich egal und eben die typische Device Connectivity
ist halt nach wie vor einfach normales USB 3 oder USB eben 3.1 und wie sie alle
heißen und deswegen kann man sich schon mal die günstigen USB 3.2 Kabel kaufen,
die dann eben auch nicht so dick sind und die man dann vielleicht auch in der
größeren Länge dabei hat.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel so ein illustres, ich habe jetzt so gemerkt,
dass so zwei Meter Kabel extrem praktisch sein können im Leben.
Und sehe jetzt zu, das zu machen. Was diese A auf C Kabel betrifft,
die würde ich jetzt nur noch verwenden in so Festinstallationen, also wo ich weiß,
da ist jetzt ein USB-A dran an diesem Gerät und auf der anderen Seite muss C
rauskommen, was weiß ich, so ein Nintendo Switch zum Beispiel.
Da sind diese Kabel ganz gut aufgehoben. Ansonsten habe ich jetzt radikal ausgemistet
und habe mir einfach eine größere Teilmenge von so kleinen USB-A auf C Adaptern
in beide Richtungen gekauft und habe eigentlich nur noch USB-C Kabel dabei.
Das heißt, wenn du ein USB-C Kabel hast und dann hast du diese A auf C oder
C auf A, also einfach nur so kleine Mini-Plugs,
dann kannst du halt sowohl an Netz teilen, wo noch ein A dran ist und du dich
fragst, warum, kannst du halt mal schnell noch ein C-Port draus machen und du
hast sofort das richtige Kabel und genau wie sie hier sehen,
also du zeigst es hier gerade bei uns in die Kamera, wobei der ist relativ groß noch,
und genauso halt dann eben auch in die andere Richtung, dass du eben jederzeit
auch irgendwie halt von C nach A wieder zurück kannst und all so eine Geschichte.
Zu dem Punkt, ich habe jetzt, weil es mir tierisch auf den Sack ging,
USB-Sticks mit USB-A und so eine Adapter-Dongle ständig adaptieren zu müssen,
habe ich mir jetzt einen Schwung USB-Sticks gekauft von Sundisk.
Die heißen irgendwie Dual Drive oder so ähnlich.
Die haben tatsächlich ein A-Ende und ein C-Ende.
Und dann kann man sie in die entsprechenden Geräte mal so rum reinstecken und
mal so rum reinstecken und bin da jetzt ganz glücklich mit, wenn man sowas wie
USB-Sticks überhaupt verwenden möchte.
Aber als Besitzer eines 3D-Druckers habe ich da irgendwie jetzt wieder den Fall
für, dass ich da gerne mal, das ist irgendwie immer noch am einfachsten,
als diesen Drucker irgendwie ins Netzwerk zu bringen. Das ist so.
Was ich nochmal in den Chat geworfen habe, löst jetzt dein Problem nicht,
Malik, aber das ist ein Kabel, an dem ich gerade täglich Freude habe.
Das ist in dem Fall jetzt Lightning-Ladekabel, wo ein Mini-Display drin verbaut
ist, was den aktuellen Ladestrom anzeigt. Und das löst für mich zwei Probleme.
Zum einen sehe ich, wenn ich da jetzt also ein iPhone anschließe,
zu welchem Ladestand wird eigentlich wie viel dann gezogen?
Am Anfang ganz viel und nach hinten raus dann immer weniger. Das ist Smart Loading.
Wie Akkus das so machen.
Und zum anderen kann ich damit dann eben jetzt auch mal verschiedene Netzteile
durchprüfen. In dem Fall jetzt USB-C am anderen Ende.
Wie viel kommt denn da eigentlich raus und reicht das dann auch irgendwie,
um mein iPad zu laden? und das schafft so eine Ebene von Transparenz irgendwie, die ich
die ich sehr schätze, weil ich sehe sofort, da ist auch kein Wackelkontakt,
sondern da fließt jetzt was und alles hat seine Richtigkeit.
Klar, die ziehen selber halt dann auch Strom, das heißt also,
das muss man nicht einplanen, aber das hält sich in Grenzen.
Habe ich mir jetzt auch welche gekauft, auch dann eben in dieser 2-Meter-Variante
und vor allem das Gute an diesen Dinger mit diesem Display ist,
die verwende ich halt für reine Ladekabel.
Also wenn so ein Ding, ich erkenne sozusagen schon am Display so,
ah, dieses Kabel liegt hier zum Laden.
Das ist nicht mit einem Computer verbunden, sondern nur mit einem Netzteil.
Also in der Tat ist es ganz gut. Es ist vor allem auch sehr gut,
um herauszufinden, was sind denn eigentlich die Spannungsbedarfe dieses Gerätes,
weil die ja dann auch alle sehr unterschiedlich ziehen.
Da geht es gar nicht mehr so sehr um die Leistung, sondern das Netzteil muss
eben auch die entsprechende Spannung machen. Und bis vor kurzem zumindest gab
es immer mal wieder noch Netzteile, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht
alle von USB-C unterstützten Spannungen unterstützen.
Und es gibt auch Geräte, die sind ein bisschen picky. Also zum Beispiel hier
dieser Rode-Caster, mit dem hier gerade die Sendung ja aufgenommen wird.
Der mag auch nicht jedes Netzteil. Da habe ich noch nicht so ganz rausgefunden, woran es liegt.
Also nur die Spannung allein scheint es auch nicht zu sein. Also es gibt auf
jeden Fall einen gehobenen Bedarf für einen guten USB-C-Tester.
Falls jemand, weil wir jetzt echt keinen Tipp haben, aber falls jetzt jemand
in die Kommentare vielleicht reinwerfen möchte, weil ihr habt schon das ultimative
Teil getestet, dann bitte sagt es uns doch.
Also so ein Gerät, was einem nicht nur sagt, was kann das Kabel,
sondern im Idealfall auch, was kann es nicht oder was für Stromstärken unterstützt ist etc.
Ich habe noch einen abgefahrenen Use Case für ein Kabel, das wirklich auch ordentlich
Strom kann. nämlich ein USB-Lötkolben.
Da will man auch nicht mit dem falschen Kabel agieren.
Was denn?
Wie viel Part braucht der?
Ich glaube 30 oder so, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also es geht schon, die sind jetzt auch nicht so, dass du ja,
das ist ja kein Bügeleisen oder so.
Aber du willst schon das richtige Netzteil und das richtige Kabel verwenden,
sonst lötet er nicht. Das ist schon so.
Abdel Kader rettet natürlich die Podcast-Landschaft mit folgender Aussage.
Fürs Laden reichen die einfachsten Kabel. Alle USB-C-Kabel in meinem Fundus
können mindestens 60 Watt.
Das iPhone, ich habe ein 15 Pro, die können sowieso nur 30 Watt.
Deswegen reicht das aus. Aus Auto, denke ich, kommt sowieso nicht so viel raus. Also aus diesem,
Zigarettenanzünder. Was kommt da raus?
Das hängt sehr von dem...
100 Watt maximals.
Ja, also sowas gibt es.
Aber man könnte ein Laptop damit fett laden und so.
Ja, das geht schon. Das geht schon. Also es gibt so 12 Volt Adapter,
habe ich auch teilweise schon im Einsatz.
Also auf jeden Fall 60 Watt reicht in der Regel für die Laptops aus.
Für manche, die eben aus welchen Gründen auch immer noch sehr viel mehr Strom
brauchen, kann man halt bis zu 100 Watt machen.
Also da tut sich schon was, aber man darf nie vergessen, gerade wenn das jetzt
so eine Installation im Wohnwagen, Wohnmobil, Auto oder so weiter ist,
gibt da auch immer noch eine Seite dahinter, da müssen auch die Kabel dann entsprechend
dick genug sein, wenn man solche Ströme anbaut.
Nee, aber so üblicherweise 100, manchmal auch 120 Watt hängt so ein bisschen
davon ab, aber sollte ja auch eine Sicherung dabei sein, wenn man es übertrieben hat.
Ja klar, aber man will ja nicht nur, dass die Sicherung knallt,
sondern man will ja, dass der
Strom dann auch ankommt, aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht so viel Bedarf,
aber wir leben auf jeden Fall in zunehmendem Maße den USB-C Ladestyle und mehr
und mehr Geräte wird man darüber laden können und das ist durchaus ein guter Trend.
Apropos USB-C, ich habe zwei EcoFlows, eine ganz kleine River 2 Mini oder so
ähnlich heißt die, die lässt sich über USB-C laden und die große,
deshalb habe ich es noch nicht ausprobiert, ob ich die über USB-C laden kann.
Also mit EcoFlow, du meinst so eine Batterie?
So eine größere Batterie, genau.
Wie viel größer ist diese Batterie?
Also die eine hat 250 Milliampere Stunden.
Milliampere Stunden?
250 Wattstunden. und die andere hat eine Kilowattstunde.
Könnte bitte die Welt aufhören, Akkukapazitäten in Ampere-Stunden anzugeben?
Es ist einfach eine Krankheit.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn die Volt nicht dazu gesagt werden.
Oder man sie gar nicht wissen kann.
Die eine hat 250 Wattstunden und die andere hat eine Kilowattstunde.
Wow, das ist ja schon richtig...
Und die kann mit USB-C geladen werden?
Die kleine auf jeden Fall schon. Die große habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also ich habe die jetzt angeschafft, weil ich will in ein paar Wochen nach Slowenien
zu einem Punkrock-Festival fahren. Und da muss dann auch der Kühlschrank mit.
Und da will man dann auch unterbrechungsfrei Strom haben.
Tim, scroll mal nach unten in den Chat. Der Abdelkader hatte ein Gerät gepostet.
Das sieht vielversprechend aus.
Letzter Link in dem Thread.
Das hier?
Genau.
Achso, ja, das. Der Tridix.
Der sieht aber aufgeräumt aus.
Ist das ein Vorteil oder ein Nachteil?
Das könnte ein Vorteil sein. Die meisten Teile, die ich bisher gesehen habe,
waren furchtbar in Layout und es war einfach so China-Junk.
Das könnte hier auch China-Junk sein, aber er sieht zumindest aufgeräumt aus.
Das mal als erster Eindruck. Jetzt gucken wir mal, was es kann.
Also, Tridix USB-Kabeltester. 2,4 Zoll Farbdisplay.
Unterstützt Widerstandstest. Type C E-Marker. Genau, das war das,
was ich vorhin gesucht habe. E-Marker.
Aha. Okay. Ja.
43 Euro hier gerade auf der Webseite.
Das macht schon mal...
Das sieht ja ordentlich aus. Sogar mit Lightning Support.
Und Mikro. Da kann man ja alles anschließen.
Gute britische Hardware, wird hier behauptet.
Okay. Britische Hardware?
Britische Hardware.
Okay, das könnt ihr das mit dem User Interface erklären. Hm.
Hm.
Der sieht tatsächlich teure Sendung heute. Ja, teure Sendung.
Teure Sendung.
Spendet jetzt für dieses Podcast.
Ja, wo ist der Ort, wo das zu liegen kommen wird bei dir, Tim?
Bitte was? Wo was?
Wo ist der Ort in deiner Wohnung, wo das zu liegen kommen wird?
Das musst du ja zuerst beantworten.
Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, es kommt gar nicht in die Wohnung.
Es kommt hier ins Studio und zwar da unten gibt es eine Schublade,
die könntest du sogar sehen.
Siehst du die? Da steht USB-HDMI.
Wie sie sehen?
Wie sie sehen.
Steht da USB-HDMI drin, das ist eine Schublade voll mit Meshbacks,
wo alles drin ist, was in irgendeiner Form mit HDMI oder USB zu tun hat.
Und ich kann dir sagen, da ist einiges, einiges ist da drin.
Darüber habe ich übrigens noch sehr spezifisch eine weitere Schublade,
da drauf steht diverse Devices.
Also so für den besonderen Fall.
Diverse Devices. MISC.
MISC, MISC Devices, genau. MISC, die hätte ich auch schreiben können.
Zum Beispiel, soll ich mal vorlesen? Also externe SSDs habe ich hier drin.
Okay.
Internet Switches, Präsenter,
Äh, Mäuse.
Mäuse?
Ja, Tastaturen, also einfach so assorted. Und vor allem, ganz wichtig bei den
Tastaturen, eine größere apokalyptische Vorrat A1242-Tastaturen.
Mhm.
Ah.
Ja, so.
Oder, Malik? A1242. Yes, der Mann weiß, was gut ist.
Das ist die Königsklasse.
Das ist einfach Tastatur CM.
Das sind aber die ohne den 10er-Block.
Und?
Nee, nee, nee. Bei mir ist das nur mit 10er-Block.
Mit 10er-Block ist keine A12-42.
Er meint die kleinen mit Kabel ohne 10er-Block. Die sind wirklich Goldstaub inzwischen.
Ja, das ist einfach die beste Tastatur. Leute, falls ihr A12-42 bei euch im
Keller habt und ihr findet die scheiße, schickt sie mir. A12-42.
Die 43 habe ich ja Roddy abgekauft und anderen Leuten. Also eine meiner Tastatur ist Roddy.
Guck an.
Wenn du brauchst eine, habe ich noch.
Okay, soll ich noch weiter vorlesen, welche diversen Devices ich in meiner Schublade habe?
Nein, lass gut sein.
Okay, wir haben die Schublade gefunden, du darfst kaufen.
Das Interessante ist, ich habe eine Tüte Bluetooth-Remotes, dann habe ich noch
ein Bluetooth-Pulsmesser.
Und das ist sehr lustig, weil dieses Gerät wurde tatsächlich von der Steuerprüfung mal hinterfragt.
Das könnte ja wohl unmöglich sein, dass das hier gewerblichen Ursprungs war, dieser Kauf.
Wo ich hier sage, ich benutze sowas nicht. Ich habe das hier nur im Podcast
reviewt. Mussten sie dann leider eingestehen, dass ich recht hatte.
Ich dachte, Blinkenlights damit gesteuert.
Als Hacker hast du jede Ausrede auf jeden Fall diverse Devices du siehst schon,
das funktioniert hier und jetzt weiß ich auch, wo mein USB-C-Tester hinkommt,
der kriegt eine eigene USB-C-Tester Tridix, guter Tipp vielen Dank.
Abdelkara er korrigiert sich selber, es ist doch nicht UK, sondern doch China-Ware ja.
Das macht ja nix wenn die jetzt langsam auch Englisch können,
okay, dann bleibe ich doch mal kurz im Devices-Land. Da habe ich nämlich auch noch was.
Ich habe ein neues Gerät gekauft und ich kann kaum was dazu sagen,
außer warum ich es gekauft habe.
Ich kann deshalb nichts dazu sagen, weil es eine Stunde bevor diese Sendung
begann, hier vom DAL-Boten abgegeben wurde.
Von daher, aber ich habe eine gute Ausrede.
Gekauft habe ich mir eine Insta 360 X5. Wer weiß, was das ist?
360-Grad-Kamera, neuestes Modell.
Ja, sieht aus, genau. Es gibt ja derzeit im Wesentlichen zwei Contender auf
dem Markt, nämlich GoPro und Insta360.
GoPro traue ich nicht mehr über den Weg.
Ja, das haben ja auch ganz viele Leute gesagt.
Weil dieses Überhitzungsproblem von GoPro hatte ich auch diverse Male, also no more GoPro.
Ja, auch Software nicht so geil. Und also ich habe relativ wenig Gutes über
GoPro gehört in diesem Segment und relativ viel Gutes über Insta360.
Ob ich das dann auch sagen werde, nach diesem Sommer, weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann euch aber sagen, warum ich es mir gekauft habe. Ich hatte ja schon
mal eine 360-Grad-Kammer, diese allererste von GoPro, die war scheiße.
Und natürlich läuft auch die Software nicht mehr und ich kann die alten Aufnahmen
nicht in irgendwas Ordentliches konvertieren.
Und der Grund, warum ich mir die jetzt geholt habe, ist natürlich die Tatsache,
dass Vision OS 26 Native Support hat für das Dateiformat von dieser Insta360.
Schwer ist das.
Das ist, ja. ist.
Ja mit Akku.
Der Akku allein ist es nicht das ist schon robust und,
naja, halt so für Traveller gedacht die mal ganz schnell ihren Scheiß auf Instagram
posten müssen, von daher ist der Name,
Insta360 auch ganz passend nicht in Betrieb nehmen, ich hab das Ding ja noch
nicht in Betrieb genommen ich muss ja meine First Mover Experience noch machen
wie gesagt, ich hatte noch genau null Zeit damit irgendwas zu machen,
Aber ich habe mir natürlich das ein oder andere Review angeschaut und habe mich
mit Leuten unterhalten, die das mir dann empfohlen haben.
Und dann gucke ich mal, was dabei rauskommt. Aber die Hoffnung ist natürlich,
dass ich damit interessantes Zeug dokumentieren kann und es mir danach in der
Vision Pro direkt 360 Grad anschauen kann.
Und das ist natürlich auch echt interessant, wenn man das hinten so auf dem
Motorrad drauf macht und damit
dann durch die Gegend gurkt. Darf man wahrscheinlich wieder alles nicht.
Aber sagen wir mal, man würde sowas machen.
Das ist Instapuke 360.
Instapuke?
Warum? Naja, in der Vision, auf dem Motorrad. Na gut, wir werden sehen.
Also ich bin schon mit Tim gefahren. Ich finde den Einwand korrekt.
Die Aussage war man hat eine Strecke durch Berlin das Navi zeigt eine gewisse
Zeit an und es ist halt nicht die Frage ob sondern um wie viel man diese Zeit
unterbietet das können auch mal 20 Minuten sein.
Ich weiß von nichts.
Auf jeden Fall geht.
Es darum dass man es gibt ja jetzt schon diese schöne Funktion,
du nimmst alles auf 360 Grad aus und danach wählst du den Bildausschnitt.
Also du musst deine Kamera ja gar nicht mehr irgendwo hinhalten,
sondern dadurch, dass du sowieso alles filmst, kannst du dir danach,
sozusagen deinen Kameraschwenk aussuchen. Aber ich fand es vor allem interessant
als so Dokumentation, wenn man mal irgendwo ist und irgendwas begutachtet,
was weiß ich, eine neue Location,
irgendwo einen Ort oder so und man macht eh Fotos, um danach eben einen Eindruck zu haben.
dann ist natürlich so ein 360-Grad-Ding irgendwie naheliegend.
Nur wie guckst du es dir denn eben an?
Aber wenn man es sich dann eben auch wirklich in 360 Grad anschauen kann,
dann ist es halt wirklich ein zweites Mal durchlaufen und jedes Mal kannst du
auf ein anderes Detail schauen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was ich mir erhoffe.
Aber es ist 2D und nicht 3D.
Klar, es ist 2D, nicht 3D, aber es ist halt 360 Grad.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeine 360 Grad 3D Kamera? Das dürfte schwierig sein
von der Konstruktion her.
Weil das wäre natürlich echt dann der total, also da hast du immer noch die
ganzen Probleme mit, worauf wird scharf gestellt, hast es jetzt irgendwie hinten
scharf, vorne scharf oder so eine kleine Blende, dass es keine Rolle spielt.
Da brauchst du ja wieder viel Licht. Also da potenzieren sich natürlich so die
Probleme, aber das wäre natürlich echt nochmal.
Also es gibt natürlich 180 Grad 3D-Kameras jetzt schon noch und nöcher,
weil das ist ja genau das, was Apple da die ganze Zeit zeigt, da in ihren Immersive,
Videos und hier von wie heißt die Bude noch gleich?
Blackmagic hat ja eine spezielle Kamera rausgebracht jetzt im Nachgang der Vision Pro, die,
genau dafür gedacht ist, quasi Content für die Vision Pro also natürlich nicht
nur für die Vision Pro, sondern generell so 3D 180 Grad Content zu machen.
Die ist glaube ich relativ teuer. Ich weiß auch gerade nicht,
wie die heißt, aber die gibt es auf jeden Fall und wahrscheinlich gibt es demnächst
auch noch andere Anbieter.
Naja, mal gucken. Also ich werde damit mal ein bisschen rumspielen in den nächsten Wochen.
Ich habe eh gerade so ein bisschen was zu dokumentieren und dann werde ich damit
halt dokumentieren und bin gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich kann noch ein bisschen was hinzufügen, was ich auch gerade erst gelernt habe.
Nämlich das Thema Videoschnitt. Ich mache ja auch so ein bisschen Videoproduktion
und manche mögen sich erinnern, wir hatten mal diesen Elektro-Weltrekord-Flug
und ich bin immer noch so mit einem Bein ein bisschen in dieser Electric Aviation-Welt.
Und da ist es so, dass dann ab und zu aus der Richtung auch so Videoprojektanfragen
kommen. Und jetzt gerade habe ich eins auf dem Tisch.
Da hat Morell, der damals mit uns geflogen ist, der hat dieses Elektroflugzeug geflogen.
Und dann hat er, ich frage mich nicht woher, in der Schweiz kennt er irgendwelche
F-18-Piloten. F-18 Hornet, so ein Kampfflugzeug.
Und dann haben die so einen sogenannten Intercept gemacht. Also sprich,
das Elektroflugzeug ist so ein wackeliger Zweisitzer, tuckert da so durch die,
also nicht mal tuckern, surrt da so durch die Luft und dann kommt von hinten
halt, wie soll ich das sagen, so ein...
Panzer der Lüfte in Lichtgeschwindigkeit an und die stellen sich dann so schräg,
so halbschräg in die Luft,
damit die quasi so viel Auftrieb und Vortrieb, aber auch Bremsung durch die
Luft von vorne haben, dass die halt langsam werden, also die fliegen quasi mit
angezogener Handbremse und das halt so kurz ein paar Sekunden neben dem Elektroflieger her,
der eine 360 Grad Kamera unterm Flügel montiert hatte, an der einen Tragfläche.
Und dieses Video hat man mir geschickt und sagt, kannst du das irgendwie schneiden, so für YouTube?
Und dann habe ich gedacht, wie schneidet man das eigentlich?
Weil ich weiß, diese ganzen Hersteller, GoPro und Insta und so,
die haben so eine eigene Software dabei, wo man auch ein bisschen schnibbeln
kann und auch ein bisschen das so konvertieren kann,
dass du für verschiedene 360-Grad-Anguck-Formate da eine Datei rausbekommst.
Aber erstmal ist es das proprietäre .360-File-Format.
Und ja, konvertieren war ganz einfach, geht mit zwei Klicks in deren Software
und dann dachte ich, okay, aber wie editiere ich das und stellt sich raus, wusste ich nicht,
Final Cut Pro, was ich sowieso benutze, kann problemlos 360 Grad Video schneiden
und auch so etwas tun wie Blickwinkel festlegen und dann die entsprechenden
Bewegungen, die man da so macht und so, wusste ich noch nicht.
Also für den Fall, dass du dann die 20 Minuten quer durch Berlin auf 4 Minuten
kürzen möchtest für YouTube, könntest du es auch mit Final Cut machen.
Ja, ich bin ja überhaupt nicht auf YouTube. Also wenn, dann eher mit 360 Grad
Content, das wäre dann interessanter, weil man kann ja bei YouTube auch 360
Grad draufladen, nur dass halt Google noch die Vision OS,
also die Vision Pro boykottiert und weder ein YouTube Client,
geschweige denn ein YouTube 360
Grad Client anbietet, was natürlich eine gehässige Aktion ist im Sinne von,
Und Platform Wars, also nichts, was nicht Apple genauso tun würde,
um das gleich mal klarzustellen,
aber es ist halt ein bisschen schade, weil es gibt halt schon eine ganze Menge
360-Grad-Content auf YouTube und überhaupt eine Menge Content,
der sich mal dann doch ganz gut machen würde in der Vision Pro.
und ich frage mich, wie die das politisch nochmal ausgecast bekommen werden.
Zumal halt ich das noch nicht so richtig sehe, dass die anderen jetzt so ohne
weiteres anschließen werden an das, was Apple da macht.
Also diese anderen Brillen und so spielen ja in einer anderen Liga als die Vision
Pro. Also ich verstehe das nicht.
Was siehst du denn, weil ich auf der MetaQuest habe ich mir eine Menge YouTube
360-Grad-Zeug angeguckt.
Was ist denn, wenn du im Browser in der Vision Pro auf YouTube gehst und solche Videos klickst?
Ja, dann siehst du die halt irgendwie verzerrt, aber das wird nicht irgendwie entzerrt.
Okay.
Du meinst, weil eigentlich müsste das ja übers Web auch gehen?
Wenn es in der Quest geht, warum soll es nicht auf der Vision Pro gehen?
Also klar, man will es lieber in der dedizierten App dafür haben, das ist klar.
Ja, aber das ist eine gute Frage, auf die ich keine gute Antwort habe.
Das werde ich mir auch nochmal anschauen. Ich glaube aber nicht,
dass ich da jetzt irgendwas,
übersehen hätte, weil es gibt halt eine ganze Menge schlecht gemachter Vision-Apps,
die versuchen das irgendwie alles zu umgehen, aber es ist eine grauenhafte Hackerei,
also das ist wirklich ein Schlachtfeld und ist nicht schön.
Ich hoffe, das wird sich bald ändern. Kann ich echt nicht anders sagen.
Also mal gucken. Also dieser Move jetzt hier zumindest schon mal Insta360 und
GoPro-Formate zu unterstützen ist auf jeden Fall gut.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich noch nicht die finale Lösung, aber es geht zumindest mal voran.
Aber es ist halt einfach immer noch alles Experimentier-Feld.
Ich habe halt jetzt mal eine Anwendung.
Entschuldige, Simon hatte gerade gepostet, die fette Variante von der Insta
kann das und er meinte, das stereoskopische, hat hier einen Link reingeworfen,
Insta 360 Pro 2, die kann man irgendwie so ausklappen und dann macht die stereoskopisch,
aber dann wahrscheinlich nur 180 Grad.
Ich werfe es nochmal hier in die Big Show.
Das ist ja die klassische alte 360-Grad-Kamera.
Die kann man wohl aufklappen und dann macht die zumindest stereoskopisch.
Da steht 8K 3D vor.
Die hat vier Linsen. Du hast immer zwei Linsen, die einen Abstand zueinander haben.
Dann berechnen sie vielleicht irgendwelche.
Ja, stimmt. Jetzt, wo du es sagst, sie hatten das Feature schon immer.
Die Kamera gibt es ja schon ganz lange.
Die gibt es ja schon seit 4, 5, 6 Jahren. Also nicht jetzt vielleicht nicht genau dieses Modell.
Das ist jetzt die Pro 2. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann die rausgekommen ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die kostet.
Einfach mal in den Bestellenbacken klicken.
Ich klicke mal auf den Bestellenbacken.
Teure Sendung.
Diese Seite ist in Ihrem Land oder Region nicht verfügbar. Aha, Insta360 Pro.
Nee, ich kriege einen anderen Requester. Wo in Ihrer Wohnung würden Sie dieses Gadget ablegen?
Was?
Also diese Pro 2.
Kann es sein, dass man die noch gar nicht kaufen kann?
Da steht es, vier Jahre alt.
Oder nicht mehr kaufen kann?
Ah, Insta360 Pro 2 kostet irgendwie was über,
5600 Euro.
Das ist doch super. Einfach an die Drohne schnallen und los geht's.
Also ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, nicht so ganz mein, also da da muss ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt sofort zuschlagen.
Reicht ja auch erstmal. Erstmal 360 Grad und dann mal schauen.
Und weil 3D ist halt auch so,
ich taue langsam ein bisschen auf, weil man merkt, auf der Vision ist es deutlich
konsumierbarer, als ich das bisher wahrgenommen habe.
Aber es braucht auch nicht unbedingt immer 3D. Hier zum Beispiel diese Talkshow
von John Gruber, Daring Fireball.
Der macht ja dann immer zu dieser WWDC dieses langweilige Gespräch.
Das war auch dieses Jahr genauso langweilig wie die Jahre davor auch.
Und seit dem letzten Jahr hat dann irgendeine Bude, die halt auch so eine App
hat auf der Vision, das eben in 3D gestreamt.
Kannst du dir die Sendung vom letzten Jahr anschauen. Für das aktuelle wollen
sie irgendwie nochmal Geld haben.
Und es war so überhaupt nicht toll.
Also es war halt so, ja okay, du siehst so ein bisschen, dass sie da so auf
der Bühne sitzen und es ist so ein bisschen dreidimensional,
aber es hat keinerlei Informationen transportiert, die du nicht in einem 2D-Video auch gehabt hättest.
Also muss man auch klar sagen, also 3D nur um das 3D-Willen ist Quatsch und
da muss man sich schon Mühe geben und deswegen ist das glaube ich auch so ein schwieriger Prozess.
Man sieht das jetzt bei diesen ganzen Immersive-Videos, also Apple schmeißt
halt so alle zwei, drei Wochen neuen Content raus. Sie haben so drei,
vier, fünf verschiedene Kanäle, über die sie dann immer mal wieder eine neue Episode rausdrücken.
Und das ist teilweise ist es so, ja, ganz nett und teilweise ist es auch ganz
beeindruckend, aber auch nicht so, dass das Leben das unbedingt gebraucht hat.
tatsächlich am besten nach wie vor finde ich dieses Musikvideo was sie mal veröffentlicht
haben also von The Weekend weil da macht es dann wieder Sinn,
weil es auf einmal ein künstlerisches Element wird.
Da kannst du einfach mit dem dreidimensionalen Effekt in deinem Musikvideo was
erreichen was eben sonst so nicht gegangen wäre, was du aber so aus einer normalen
Realität heraus so nicht so beeindruckend bekommen kannst ich glaube, dass es für eigene.
Memories, für eigene.
Erlebnisse, so fotografieren um des Erinnerns willen.
Da ist es schon auch interessant.
Aber da ist vielleicht 360 Grad noch interessanter, weil ich genieße auch die
Panoramas zum Beispiel, die ich jetzt gemacht habe, sehr.
Ich mache aber jetzt auch immer mal wieder 3D-Filme mit der Kamera,
um zu gucken, okay, gib mir das jetzt irgendwas, ist das jetzt irgendwie besser als ohne?
und ja, das muss ich alles noch entscheiden, weiß ich vielleicht nach dem Sommer.
Gut, 360 Grad Content. Warum nicht?
Haben wir.
Haben wir auch. Check. So. Warte mal noch.
Also ich habe Anliegen, wenn ihr nie wisst, was ihr sagen sollt.
Entschuldigung. Ein Nachtrag noch, dann bin ich auch gleich ruhig.
Und zwar hatte ich ja letzte Sendung berichtet, dass ich hatte ja schon davon
berichtet, dass diese Insta360 und Fusion-Format,
unterstützt wird. Und das ist ja auch interessant, sich das dann anzugucken,
weil auf einmal aus einer Weitwinkel-Aufnahme so ein gebogenes Bild wird.
Das ist ja der Sinn von Weitwinkel, dass du eben mehr als nur so ein Flatscreen
hast, aber normalerweise ist es halt immer so zusammengestaucht.
Das sieht dann ganz interessant aus.
Aus Gründen, die nur Apple kennt, funktioniert es aber nicht für die Weitwinkel-Fotos vom iPhone.
Also man kann ja hier auf Weitwinkel schalten. Da dachte ich so,
ja, ich hab doch ganz viel Weitwinkel-Content, immer wenn ich auf 0,5 schalte.
Ja, nee, machen sie irgendwie nicht. Also keine Ahnung. Vielleicht holen sie
das noch nach. Okay, jetzt bin ich aber ruhig.
Ich hoffe, du hast viel zu sagen zu einem Anliegen, was ich habe.
Ich hab gedacht, hey, da sitzt du doch mit so Nerds zusammen.
Das wird noch häufiger kommen, dass ich das heute so einleite.
Denn es gibt so Dinge, zu denen muss ich wirklich mehr wissen als vorher,
nämlich ich habe jetzt gerade, sprechen wir über eine Glasfaserleitung von NetCologne
slash NetAachen miteinander und diese.
Glasfaserleitung schimpft sich zwar Glasfaser, aber der Upload sind 55 Mbit.
Ich habe ja eben gesagt, ich mache viel mit Video, das wird auch gerne mal 4K
und das wird auch gerne mal ProRes und so weiter, da musst du auf einmal einen
Terabyte irgendwo hinschicken.
Da sind auch 55 Mbit Upstream, einfach ein absoluter Witz.
Und deswegen Mehr kann ich da aber nicht kaufen für sinnvolles Geld.
Ich zahle jetzt so 40 Euro im Monat, habe 500 Down, aber die Down sind ja nicht das Nadelöhr.
Also habe ich dann mal wieder und wieder und wieder gebettelt und so weiter.
Ich habe jetzt aber gehört, dass die Telekom in meinem Gebiet nicht mehr nur
noch bis zur nächsten Straßenecke ausbaut, wie seit Jahren,
sondern auch wirklich, wirklich dieses Jahr meine Straße, mein Haus an Telekomglas anschließen möchte.
Und da gibt es einen sehr guten Umstand, die AudiodumphörerInnen wissen das schon,
ich habe ja den unten rechts Telekom-Vertrag, den Deluxe XXL,
irgendwas, den es da geben kann und der ist auch irgendwie teuer und so weiter,
da kann man Freunde mit reinnehmen, das ist alles total praktisch.
Wenn man den hat und Telekom Glas dazu nimmt, wird der preislich runtergestuft von XL auf S.
Sodass man in der gesamten Kombi, wenn ich jetzt schnellstes Telekom Glas nehme
und diesen Handyvertrag behalte, spare ich 15 Euro zuvorher.
Das heißt, auf einmal kostet es nicht mehr mindestens 80 Euro im Monat schnelles
Internet zu Hause zu haben, sondern es ist, sage ich mal, es bleibt ungefähr verträglich.
Und das war ein ausschlaggebender Punkt zu sagen, okay, was kann ich bei euch
kaufen und was man da kaufen können wird, hoffe ich, ist 1000 slash 500.
Damit würde sich mein Upload, also 8-fachen oder 10-fachen, je nachdem.
Und da wäre ich sehr glücklich.
Also die 1000 Down, wie gesagt, geschenkt, so oft lade ich die Linux-Distributionen
halt nicht runter, ist mir eigentlich egal, aber der Upstream,
ich brauche alles, was es gibt.
Und leider, symmetrisch geht trotzdem nicht, aber man kann 500 abhaben.
Jetzt ist es aber so, die alte Fritzbox, was habe ich hier, 75,
92 oder irgendwas, weiß ich nicht, die ich hier habe, wird da wahrscheinlich nichts mit tun können.
Und meine Frage an die Nerds ist, welches Gerät und gibt es irgendwelche Erfahrungen,
wenn man wirklich Fiber to the Home bekäme,
das ist noch nicht ganz sicher, denn es muss erst eine Begehung geben und dann
werden die rauskriegen, können sie es nur in den Keller legen und schicken es
mir irgendwie anders hoch oder legen sie mir wirklich Glas bis in die Wohnung.
Ich hoffe das, aber wenn dem so wäre, welches Gerät möchte man,
weil man wahrscheinlich nicht einfach das Telekom-Gerät mieten will.
Habt ihr da irgendwie Erfahrungen, werft ihr mir jetzt einen Link zu...
Was will ich vermeiden?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was du mit Gerät meinst. Gerät wofür, weil welches Gerät? Router.
Also ich habe jetzt hier so eine Fritzbox und die muss auch nicht viel machen.
Ja.
Ich hole kurz noch zwei Sätze aus. Meine Fritzbox versorgt per Ethernet-Kabel
den Mac, ein, zwei iPhones, wenn sie in der Wohnung sind und eine Handvoll IoT-Geräte.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt keinen Clemens-artigen Gerätepark an Switches für
irgendwas oder so, sondern das ist so ein normales Fritzbox-Haus-Verhalten.
Es muss aber den Durchsatz schaffen. Und Glas anschließen können.
Ja, also es gibt ja von Fritz auch Glasfaser- Fritzbox-Varianten.
Ja, genau. Es gibt da welche und dann fing ich an, da so reinzulesen und dann
wurden da Voraussetzungen abgefragt, die ich nicht mal beantworten konnte.
Aber das wird sich wahrscheinlich schnell klären lassen, sobald ich weiß,
ob ich eine echte Glasdose, was kriegt man da eigentlich?
Man kriegt dann Glas bis in die Wand und ab dann Ethernet?
Oder ist das so Tosslink-mäßig?
Du kriegst auf jeden Fall ein Abschlussgerät. Sowas wie ein Modem.
Also das kriegst du, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall dazu. Weil, also ich glaube,
es gibt jetzt eine Fritzbox, da kannst du eine Glasfaser reinstecken.
Ja, gibt es.
Aber, also, Also ich hatte ja schon mal Glasfaser und da war das halt so,
da gab es halt diesen einen Schrank im Flur, also so eine Klappe,
so wie Sicherungskasten, nur halt so ein Datenkasten.
und da kamen halt irgendwie vier Glasfasern, glaube ich, raus,
und dann hat man die Glasfaser, die hatte vorne so einen Stecker dran,
hast du da in die Box gesteckt und dann hat es funktioniert,
bis dann die Box irgendwann abgeraucht ist und wir eine neue gekriegt haben.
Was war das für ein Stecker?
Naja, so ein Glasfaser-Stecker, keine Ahnung. Ich erinnere mich nur dunkel,
ehrlich gesagt, weil ich das nie ausgesteckt habe.
Was ist denn genau dein Vorbehalt quasi gegenüber der Telekom-Standardlösung?
Also da sind ja jetzt auch nicht nur Idioten unterwegs, die werden dann ja so
ihre eigenen Specs und Kabel ganz gut kennen.
Inklusive Fernwartung und sowas, was sie da drüber laufen lassen.
Das ist eigentlich genau meine Frage. Also ist es nur die alte Sorge von damals,
dass diese Plasterouter, die die einem da so geschickt haben,
die konnten halt nix. Ich bin auch nicht so ein Freund von Mieten.
Ich würde mir das Ding einfach mal kaufen, statt unendlich 8 Euro im Monat zu bezahlen oder so.
und es ist so, dieses bei einer Fritzbox weiß ich halt, wenn ich da eine Benutzeroberfläche
öffne, weiß ich halt, wo ich bin.
Das ist dann eher so, das ist mein gewohntes Terrain.
Während ich bei den Telekom Dingern oder ähnlichen, von Vodafone kenne ich jetzt
eher, das sind dann halt sehr, sehr hübsche Oberflächen, die vier Knöpfe haben
und wenn du dann irgendwie wissen willst, woran es gerade hakt im Internet,
dann hast du keine Analysemöglichkeiten und sowas.
Ja, totale Katastrophe. Also ich würde auf gar keinen Fall auf so ein Gerät gehen.
Allein schon, weil wenn du eine Fritzbox hast, mit AVM halt noch einen unabhängigen
Hersteller, dann ist das einfach mal, die holen sozusagen aus dem Anschluss raus, was sie können.
Und nicht, was gerade in die Produktpolitik der Telekom passt und was sie dir
gerade verscherbeln wollen.
Das ist ja auch bei Vodafone und so weiter das Problem, dass diese Abschlussgeräte
sind halt immer so verlängerte Marketingmaßnahmen und das ist einfach nie gut.
Von daher würde ich auf gar keinen Fall auf irgendeinen Telekom Router setzen.
Es sei denn, der macht jetzt irgendwas ganz Irres, Tolles.
Ja, ob du jetzt das eine oder andere Fiber bekommst, also die eigentliche Frage
ist ja Fiber to the Home oder Fiber to the Curb.
Das hängt ja ein bisschen von deinem, du wohnst ja im Mietshaus, nehme ich mal an.
Das hängt ja dann sozusagen von den Hausbesitzern oder der Eigentümergesellschaft
ab und wie die sich dann eben mit der Telekom auf die Anschlusskosten einigen,
weil ich, soweit ich weiß,
wobei ich weiß da nicht viel drüber, ganz ehrlich, ich hab mir das vor ein paar
Jahren mal angeschaut, wie die Realität ist, keine Ahnung, ob sich das mittlerweile
geändert hat, aber das ist ja immer noch dieser Battle, die Telekom möchte halt gerne,
ja, wenn alle hier Glasfaser haben wollen, dann legen wir das auch ins Haus,
aber dann machen wir das auch selber und dann ist immer die Frage,
wer trägt die Kosten dafür,
wird das dann sozusagen von der Eigentümergemeinschaft übernommen oder nicht
und wie wird das dann umgelegt und da habe ich überhaupt keine Antwort drauf,
was da die normale Realität ist.
Wenn du dann diesen Anschluss hast, dann sieht es für mich derzeit so aus,
dass man wohl tatsächlich eine Glasfaser als Abschluss hat,
wo man dann eben sein Gerät ransteckt, auch wenn ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig verstehe.
Man könnte da einfach so ein tumbes Device machen, wo einfach ein Ethernet rauskommt und fertig ist.
Also ich habe ja von der deutschen Glasfaser ein Angebot bekommen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal nachgeguckt. Die sind immer noch in Prüfung.
Also ich glaube, die werden auch bei Schneckenrennen Mario immer letzter.
Also das Das ist so. Aber bei denen ist es halt so, dass sie tatsächlich die
Glasfaser bis ins Haus führen.
Und wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hast du dann die Glasfaser im Keller.
Und was dann vom Keller aus passiert, ist dann dein Problem, mehr oder weniger.
Beziehungsweise es kann sein, dass sie es noch ins Erdgeschoss ziehen.
Aber im Prinzip gehen die durch den Garten, bohren dann irgendwie die Hauswand
an und ziehen es in den Keller und fertig.
Ja, auf dieser Telekom-Seite, Sie haben tatsächlich so eine Homepage,
wo der Verlauf dieses Bestellvorgangs, der Monate dauern kann,
so aufgelistet ist und wo man auch ein bisschen interagieren kann.
Also da ist so, schließen Sie den Vertrag ab und dann da und da Begehung und
dann suchen Sie sich jetzt schon mal ein Gerät aus, aber genau diese Frage konnte
ich nicht beantworten und genau, man muss diese Begehung abwarten,
dann wird das wahrscheinlich gehen und dann möchten Sie mieten, möchten Sie kaufen,
möchten Sie dies, möchten Sie das und dann gibt es eine Wahl, die man machen kann.
dann entweder belegen es im Prinzip hinter die Tür, Klammer auf,
drei Meter Umkreis gilt auch noch als hinter die Tür.
Und das wäre bei mir schon am Rechner durch eine Wand durch.
Oder sie suchen sich selber aus, wo sie den Endpunkt haben wollen,
müssen dafür aber dann selber auch die entsprechenden Vorbereitungen treffen.
Und da spezifizieren sie dann sowas wie, wenn man durch eine Wand durch muss,
dann sollten sie einen Zwölferbohrer nehmen und dann brauchen wir so und so viel Platz.
und die Kurve und darf nicht der Radius von Untersohn so haben und dann darf
da auch kein Schrank davor stehen.
Also sowas in der Art, man müsste sich dann selber kümmern, das kann man und
wollen doch, dass man vorher anklickt und auch sagt, damit wenn der Techniker
an dem Tag kommt, wahrscheinlich nicht viele aufgehalten wird.
Ja, aber drei Meter um die Tür, da wäre ich schon glücklich.
Naja, wie ist denn das mit der Kiste, die du da leihen müsstest?
Hast du da eine Mindestlaufzeit Laufzeit über die Live-Rest?
Ich glaube ein oder zwei Jahre oder sowas. Weiß ich gar nicht.
Die Frage ist halt, nimmt man die halt für ein paar Monate und guckt,
ob das Teil taucht oder und kündigt dann das Leihgerät und kauft sich was Vernünftiges
oder wenn es halt funktioniert, dann funktioniert es halt.
Vielleicht.
Also da würde ich nochmal nachgucken, ob es da die Möglichkeit gibt.
Guter Gedanke.
Ich werfe sogar mal diese Seite, die ich gerade erwähnt habe,
auch mal hier in die Links.
Vielleicht kann man das sogar da direkt nachvollziehen.
Ja, okay. Danke für den Input. Also abschließend kann man das natürlich nicht
beantworten, aber ich dachte, ihr sagt vielleicht, ja, ich habe das und das
zu Hause und aus dem Grund habe ich das andere nicht gekauft oder so.
Dann lieber vorher fragen.
Ja, ich wünsche dir Erfolg, aber du hast jetzt noch nicht gesagt,
was dir die Telekom ein Upload dann anbieten möchte. Haben die da was?
500.
Doch, doch. 500.
500 Megabit bei welchem Download?
Tausend.
Okay.
Symmetrisch, ja.
Ja, einfach symmetrisches Netz. Einfach Gigabit fertig aus.
Ja.
Ja, aber das wollen die Leute doch gar nicht. Das brauchen die Leute doch gar nicht.
Das ist einfach so.
Hast du Business, musst du Business bezahlen. Ach, so ist das.
Na gut, ich wünsche auf jeden Fall viel Glück damit. Wir können dir jetzt nur
begrenzt helfen, aber wenn es da akut wird, dann hören wir nochmal nach.
Könnte Oktober werden, ja.
Am Ende ist es ja wie immer, die Antwort kommt dann von Abdelkader.
Kam auch schon eben. Ich versuche ihn jetzt unten zu halten.
Aber das fällt mir immer schwerer.
Da steigt mein Blutdruck, um mal eine goldene Brücke zu bauen.
Ja, dann hau rein.
Na gut. So, womit machen wir weiter? Sind wir schon in Tierlist-Country?
Nee, ich war hier bei meinem goldenen Brücke. Ralf, der Blutdruck steigt bei diesem Thema.
Das weiß ich ja gerade nicht. Also meine Hausärztin hat mir aufgetragen,
mal systematisch und über einen längeren Zeitraum meinen Blutdruck zu messen und zu erfassen.
Und jetzt bin ich so halb motiviert auf der Suche nach irgendetwas in Sachen
Blutdruckmessgerät. Ich habe von meiner Mutter einen geerbt,
der so, glaube ich, einfach tut, was die halt so tun.
Ja, mit Batterien drin irgendwie, Akkus, aber halt nichts jetzt irgendwie mit
WLAN und streamt irgendwie aufs iPhone irgendwelche Daten.
Wir reden jetzt von so einer Armbinde.
Genau, genau.
Das würdest du gerne mit USB-P.
Mit Pumpe.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich habe auch so einen Teil mit Pumpe.
Also mein ist schon vollautomatisch. Das heißt, da ist nichts,
wo man selber irgendwas macht. Genau, okay.
Aber letztlich tut sie genau das Gleiche.
Sie tut das, was man irgendwie seit Jahrzehnten irgendwie so kennt.
Und jetzt hatte ich so die vage Idee,
okay, will man irgendwas haben, was jetzt über Bluetooth sich gleich mit der
Health-App irgendwie koppelt und da gleich die richtigen Daten reinschreibt,
wo man hinterher feierlich ein PDF hochprofessionell überreichen kann?
Oder muss man das alles doch händisch eintragen und lohnt sich gar nicht?
Die Frage ist halt, wenn du so eine Messung machst, wie viel Aufwand empfindest
du, ist das, zwei Zahlen abzutippen?
Eigentlich hält es sich in Grenzen. Also diese Health-App ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so, die...
Lass dir sagen, das hat auch eine gewisse Schwelle.
Ja, dass man eine Einstiegsschwelle.
Ja, dass man dann irgendwie doch keinen Bock hat.
Man muss sich doch erstmal so ein bisschen durchklicken in der Health-App,
bis man da so in dieser Eingabemaske drin ist.
Nö, das geht. Man kann das ja als Favorit auf die erste Seite tun und dann sagt
man Plus und dann drückst du die beiden.
Dann fragt er immer, bist du sicher? Ist das nicht vielleicht ein bisschen hoch?
Und dann so, ja, ja, nee, passt schon. Ich weiß, was ich tue.
So, aber Malek, wird uns jetzt sagen, was ich vielleicht kaufen sollte.
Ich komme ja nur hierher, weil ich die Antworten suche. Es war so gewesen,
meine Mutter hat tatsächlich,
gerade geäußert, dass sie gerne ein neues Blutdruckmessgerät hätte aus irgendwelchen
Gründen und sie hat noch ein paar mehr Anforderungen, aber ihre erste Frage,
ich bin sehr stolz auf sie, war,
Bluetooth-Anschluss und App, ja oder nein, ob ich das wohl brauche,
dann könnte ich mir die Eintragung sparen, geht das auch mit Voice?
auf jeden Fall große Ziffern und muss beleuchtet sein.
Das, was sie jetzt hat, hat tatsächlich so fingergroße Ziffern in so einem Display,
was so LC-Display, was hinterleuchtet ist.
Was ist bei dir fingergroß? Fingergroß heißt so groß wie ein Fingerabdruck oder was?
Nein, nein, nein, fingerlang. Also wir reden von 5, 6 Zentimetern.
Sind die Ziffern groß? Achso, aber das ist die Größe, die sie haben will.
Das ist sie ja nicht zu klein.
Nein.
Das ist das, was sie jetzt hat. Also die Hauptwerte sind auf einem wirklich
großen, also ich sag mal, mindestens Handteller großen Display,
ja, sind sehr große Zahlen drauf zu sehen und ein paar kleinere natürlich irgendwie auch.
Aber dieses, man wacht nachts auf, fühlt sich nicht so wohl,
muss da jetzt irgendwie halb verwirrt dieses Ding seine Arbeit tun lassen und
will dann einfach nur wissen, systolischer Wert, Dankeschön.
Und scheinbar ist das aber die Anforderung und tatsächlich sie trägt genau wie
Medikamentensachen und so immer alles in irgendeine App ein und ich habe ihr
natürlich nur die installiert oder direkt bei Health,
die mit Health reden, weil man das gerne natürlich zentralisiert in so einem
iOS und macOS haben möchte.
Und das wäre aber auch dann direkt meine Frage an Community und oder euch.
Wo gibt es die passenden Geräte? Und hier gibt es schon Empfehlungen.
Wollen wir mit Abdelkader anfangen oder heben wir uns den zum Abschluss auf?
Weil J. Tim sagt nämlich, es gibt hier von der Hochdruckliga Blutdruckmessgeräte
mit Prüfsiegeln und am besten nehme man Omron.
Krude App, die mit Health synchronisieren kann, aber genaue Geräte.
Kann ich nur sagen.
Also hier, was Abdelkader empfiehlt, ist von Withings.
Da habe ich in der Tat eine Personenwaage. Und mit der bin ich nur sehr mäßig
zufrieden. Ich glaube, das eigentliche Wiegen ist super.
Aber die vergisst irgendwie alle zwei, drei Tage, was sie eigentlich ist.
Und schaltet wieder von Kilosystem auf US um.
Und syncht sich nicht vernünftig durch. Und vergisst ihr WLAN.
Also vom Softwarestand her ist die echt wackelig.
Die ist allerdings auch, weiß ich nicht, acht Jahre alt oder sowas.
Also ich habe auch eine Withings Waage, die habe ich lange bevor Withings von Nokia gekauft wurde.
Und sie funktioniert aber eigentlich immer noch sehr gut. Also klar,
wenn die Batterien leer laufen, dann muss man manchmal neu koppeln.
Eigentlich immer, aber ansonsten tut die ganz gut.
Also meine macht nicht, vergisst keine Daten.
Aber das Koppeln ist mittlerweile besser geworden, nachdem sie wohl bei der
App dann doch nochmal ein paar Updates nachgeschickt haben.
Ich habe das jetzt gerade nochmal
durchgeführt. Das war deutlich unkomplizierter, als es vorher noch war.
Aber mit dem Wiegen finde ich das ein bisschen problematisch.
Manchmal steht man da drauf und das Ding kann sich irgendwie ewig nicht entscheiden,
wie schwer ich jetzt wiege.
Wie viel ich jetzt wirklich wiege. Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass ich mir nochmal eine Chance geben möchte, runterzugehen,
damit ich nicht sehen muss, was da steht.
Aber naja, dafür habe ich es ja nicht gekauft. Ich will, dass du mir die Wahrheit sagst.
Also ich finde diese Withings Waage, äh Waage, sag ich schon,
diesen Blutdruckmesser hier sehr stylisch, Apple-mäßig, aber so mit geil Zahlen
ablesen und so bin ich jetzt gerade nicht so sicher.
Das sind so Pünktchen Display direkt am Arm.
Da riecht für mich stark nach Lesebrillen-Problematik.
Aber es gibt eine App. Ja, ist ein bisschen die Frage, wie gut ist es am Ende?
Aber Abdelkader sagt, ist bei ihm seit Jahren im Einsatz.
Nachteil, die drücken einem einen Account aufs Auge.
Ja, das will man nicht. Also ich versuche gerade die zu finden,
die ich irgendwann mal gekauft habe, das Ding.
Aber es gelingt.
Ja, Tim sagt, hat bei ihm nicht lange gehalten und ist nicht mutterkompatibel.
Bei meiner Wildingswaage war der Akku komplett tot, ging in den Schrott.
Hakuda sagt, ich empfehle das vorher mit diversen Geräten zu testen. Ja, dieses Testen.
Das Withings Ding behauptet bei einem meiner Kumpels, er habe keinen Puls.
Hast du diesen Kumpel schon mal im Spiegel gesehen?
Ich frage nur für einen Freund.
Okay, sind wir durch mit dem Thema?
Ah, hier ist das, was ich habe, aber es gibt es schon lange nicht mehr. Okay, gut.
Ich versuche es jetzt vielleicht einfach erstmal ein paar Tage mit manuell eintragen.
Mal gucken, wie sehr es mich nervt.
Ja.
Wenn es wirklich wichtig ist, macht man das.
Okay. Also wenn ihr weitere Tipps habt, schickt es mir gerne,
egal wo. Auch Mastodon oder wo immer. Im Slack.
So.
Ja.
Jetzt kommen wir zum einsamen Höhepunkt der Sendung.
Jetzt schon?
Oder?
Nee.
Oder Malek erzählt noch was über Liquid Glass.
Ich muss leider Er hat sich auch ein Macintosh gekauft. Ich meine,
wenn man sich ein Macintosh kauft, dann muss man natürlich auch berichten.
Das ist ja schon länger her. Aber nee, wichtiger ist tatsächlich Klingelverstärker.
Gleiche Mutter, ähnliches Problem.
Was?
Man hört nicht mehr.
Mutter, ähnliches Problem.
Natürlich das Problem der technischen. Okay, ich sehe schon Sendungstitel.
Also Grüße gehen raus Mama. Also das Problem ist, das Älterwerden und die technische Anbindung.
Und zwar ist es dieses, du hast irgendwo so eine Wohnung und die Klingel ist
am einen Ende und du bist oft am anderen Ende und dann hörst du die Klingel
nicht mehr so unbedingt.
Und gibt es, also es gibt so Klingelverstärker.
Habe ich, ich habe wirklich gar keine Ahnung. Ich dachte, ich werfe es hier
einfach mal blind rein. Also taub rein sozusagen. Ihr versteht schon.
Klingelverstärker. Und ich glaube, es ist halt nicht nur dieses,
es macht die Klingel lauter, damit man alle Nachbarn noch direkt mitwecken kann,
sondern wahrscheinlich gibt es auch irgendwas, was dann auf der Apple Watch mitbimmelt und so.
Und ich habe schon versucht, die akustische Erkennung, die iOS und so ja mit anbieten,
laufendes Wasser dir zu melden oder eine Klingel dir zu melden und so,
das ist leider nicht so richtig zielführend, denn man hat das Telefon nicht
immer an der Frau oder andere Sachen, das erkennt auch nicht immer die Klingel,
also diese Art Klingel, diesen Klingelton, der wird quasi nicht erkannt.
und deswegen ist das nicht die Lösung, falls jetzt jemand mit Hausmitteln kommen
möchte, sondern es gibt irgendwie so Klingelverstärker und deswegen,
sollte jemand einen Tipp haben, muss auch kein langes Thema draus machen,
auch da wäre ich sehr dankbar,
bitte her zu mir,
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die so heißen.
Es nimmt es akustisch auf, erkennt, dass das der Klingelton ist,
überträgt den dann woanders hin? Vielleicht.
Oder irgendwas Elektrisches passiert und eine App macht ein Pop-up auf irgendwas
und die Homepods klingeln und das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, ich hatte irgendwann mal die Hoffnung auch hier irgendwie mal an meine Klingel
einfach eine Telefonanlage anzuschließen oder irgendwie sowas.
Also irgendwas, mit dem ich das dann digitalisiert und virtualisiert bekomme,
bin ich aber auch ein bisschen dran gescheitert.
Habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt lange nicht mehr probiert, weil so eine normale
Klingel findet man ja jetzt auch nicht mehr überall, aber wir reden jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich über eine reine klassische elektrische Klingel,
da wird dann einfach die Verbindung geschlossen und dann klingelt das Ding.
Also so eine richtige Rasse.
Genau, Klingelrad.
Ist sie mit Gegensprechanlage und Gedöns?
Ja, Gegensprechanlage, keine Kamera.
Achso, das heißt, es ist schon eine Klingel im Rahmen einer Anlage.
Ja, aber es gibt dieses Telefon als ein eigenes Gerät und es gibt einen Meter
da drüber die separate Klingel.
Deswegen gehe ich davon aus.
Und geht das Telefon immer, wenn man abnimmt, hat man sofort Kontakt mit unten
oder ist das so eine, die nur geht, wenn kurz vorher geklingelt wurde?
Das geht immer.
Okay, dann ist wahrscheinlich die Klingel tatsächlich separat und könnte einfach
eine ganz normale physikalische Rutschlussklingel sein.
Also man stellt einfach Strom her und dann klingelt das Ding und dann ist das einfach so eine Rassel.
Ist das so eine Kring-Klingel oder ist das so eine Tüdelü-Klingel?
Ne, so eine Möp.
Okay, keine Melodie.
Keine Tüdelü. Ne.
Ja, okay, gut. Das ist eine klassische, einfache Klingel.
Das ist ja quasi einfach nur so, braucht man ja nur so einen Kurzschluss-Konnektor.
Das ist so quasi das...
Genau und es gibt ja auch diverse Geräte, also auch irgendwelche Reichweiten-Extender
und optische Signale und alles, aber es gibt da so viel irgendwas angebot,
dass ich wieder auf Erfahrungswerte hoffen würde, sowas wie, guck mal,
du kriegst hier ein Gerätchen, was an die Klingel drankommt und dann kriegst
du hier zwei Gerätchen, die kannst du in der Wohnung verteilen und damit,
wenn es klingelt, kriegst du es auf jeden Fall überall in der Wohnung mit,
ohne dass du die eigentliche Klingel zehnmal so laut machen musst.
Okay, ich weiß nicht genau, was dir die Hoffnung gibt, dass ausgerechnet wir
darüber Auskunft geben können, aber ich habe da jetzt ehrlich gesagt keinerlei Erfahrung.
Also ich finde den Anwendungsbereich jetzt interessant und kann jetzt auch nur
kurz ins Internet schauen und feststellen, es gibt da eine Million Sachen,
wovon klar ist, was jetzt wofür gedacht ist.
Aber es scheint wirklich auch so Systeme zu geben,
die man tatsächlich einfach anstatt einer Klingel anschließt und die dann in
irgendeiner Form Funk macht und dann hast du dann nochmal über diesen Funk aktivierte
Klingeln, die du im ganzen Haus verteilen kannst.
Welche jetzt für deine Mutter da relevant ist?
Ja, ich hoffte natürlich auf dieses Weiße, dass das irgendwie im Apple Home
Universum auch noch sinnvoll stattfinden kann oder so.
Aber das Home-Universum selber findet ja nicht sinnvoll statt.
Ja, in ein paar Disziplinen, aber in viel zu wenigen.
Ich habe ja das Problem, dass die Jungs, die bei mir die Wärmepumpe installiert
haben, das Klingelkabel getötet haben.
Also bei mir klingelt jetzt gerade mal gar nichts.
Da hilft dann auch kein Klingelverstärker, wenn es überhaupt gar nicht erst klingelt.
Und ich würde ja auch so eine moderne Irgendwas-Klingel da draußen dran machen,
nur die gibt es halt nur mit Kamera.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es die nicht ohne Kamera gibt.
Irgendeine Funk-Klingel, die nicht einfach nur ein Stück Scheiß-Plastik ist,
sondern halt auch vielleicht ein bisschen irgendwie Daten kann und weiß nicht was. Aber na gut, egal.
Deine Mutter soll einfach eine App programmieren auf dem iPhone mit Machine
Learning das dann automatisch das ergibt Ich meine tatsächlich hat das iPhone
so eine Funktion mit Töne erkennen Ja.
Darüber sprach ich eben von Das klappt nicht mit dem Klingelton Das Apple Machine Learning.
Das lernt ungern dazu Ja.
Das Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt.
Ja. Wollt ihr irgendwas über den M4 wissen? Weil Tim, du hast doch das gleiche
Ding, oder nicht? Nee, wahrscheinlich noch was dickeres.
Hast du einen M2 oder so?
Ich habe einen Mac Studio M2 und du hast jetzt einen M4 Max gekauft.
Genau.
Der ist alles scheiße an dem Teil, oder? Du hast da nur Ärger mit.
Leider, leider nein. Nein, also ja,
der Audiodump berichtete über immensen Ärger, den ich beim Umstieg hatte vom
Hacky auf den Rechner, was einfach nur,
mir wurde gesagt, neu aufsetzen sei ja mal alle zehn Jahre eine gute Idee und
dann habe ich das gemacht und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass macOS wirklich
gar nicht gerne einen User-Ordner auf einer externen SSD untergebracht haben will,
weil dann esoterischste Probleme auftreten,
die völlig unzusammenhängend sind.
Also sowas wie Menü-Items tauchen dann nicht auf, obwohl die Programme korrekt
installiert sind. Und du kriegst nicht raus, warum.
Und dann irgendwann, ich glaube sogar mithilfe von Perplexity oder so,
kam man dann irgendwann drauf.
Das liegt tatsächlich einfach nur an dem Fakt, dass es auf der externen Platte liegt.
Und dann habe ich Möglichkeiten gefunden, auf meiner internen SSD den User-Ordner
wieder dorthin zu verschieben.
Und damit lösten sich alle Probleme plötzlich in Luft auf. Das war sehr lehrreich
und hat mich irgendwie zwei Tage Frickel gekostet.
Aber nö, der Rechner ist tipptopp und ich habe ihn auch noch nie gehört und er hat,
kleine Dinge, vielleicht so Beobachtungen, die ich nicht so erwartet habe und
auch ein bisschen schade finde.
Als erstes zum Beispiel das kleine Licht, was vorne an dem Mac dran ist.
Ich bin ja wie bei Tim, ich hatte ja den gleichen oder sehr ähnlichen Mac Pro.
Auch sehr, sehr lange, den du auch lange hattest. Ich hab das Ding geliebt, den Cheese Grater.
Der hatte vorne so ein kleines weißes Licht, was einfach das perfekte Licht,
so muss eine LED aussehen.
Und wenn der schlafen gelegt war, dann hat das so geatmet. Und genau so muss
ein Atmen einer LED aussehen.
Und das war ja früher bei den MacBooks auch so, wo sie noch,
ihr erinnert euch, wo sie mit winzigen Lasern durch das Alu kleine unsichtbare
Löcher gebohrt haben, damit die LED unter dem Alu zu sehen war.
Aber wenn die LED aus war, hast du keine Löcher gesehen.
So schön, also diese Sache. Genau, und seitdem haben wir uns leider zurückentwickelt
in der Menschheitsgeschichte und dieser M4 Max hat jetzt tatsächlich ein Licht,
was ich etwas zu gelb finde. Da kann man jetzt sagen, Grafikerproblem.
Das wurde zuerst mir auch vorgeworfen, bis dann jemand anders gesagt hat,
du, ich war mal gerade in einem Apple Store und hab auf so ein Ding geguckt,
das Licht ist ja einfach viel zu gelb.
Also auch normale Menschen finden das Licht da, es ist nicht mehr das Schöne
weiß und, und das finde ich richtig kacke, es atmet nicht mehr,
wenn der Rechner schläft.
Und das ist ein Problem, wenn du den Rechner ansonsten ja wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr hörst.
Du weißt halt nicht, was macht der gerade? Und das ist ja schön,
wir wollen ja, dass die Rechner ruhig sind, aber wenn du jetzt den einen Indikator,
den du dafür haben könntest, wenn sie den sozusagen dann funktionslos geschaltet
haben, denke ich also, was ist Apple? Ihr habt das erfunden.
Das ist die Eleganz, für die euer Name steht.
Was ist Steve tot oder was ist passiert? Keine Ahnung.
Schon länger.
Was? Hat mir keiner gesagt. Ja, also auf jeden Fall, das ist eine Beobachtung.
Dann ein Problem, was ich hoffte zu lösen durch Ausgabe von 3000 Euro. ist, ähm,
Das ist bei Studiolink, was ich fürs Podcasten ja noch verwende,
gibt es immer Knacksprobleme, wenn sehr viel I.O.
passiert, also wenn Time Machine anspringt oder wenn Backblaze als Remote,
wie nennt man das, Backup-Tool ins Netz backupt.
In dem Moment, wo die beiden Tools und auch nur diese beiden Tools irgendwie
angehen, hörst du auf einmal, hast du Bit-Verluste.
Und das ist sicherlich ein Studiolink-typisches
Problem, also in Zoom passiert das zum Beispiel nicht.
Aber ich habe halt gedacht, okay, der Hacky, den ich vorher hatte, der war acht Jahre alt.
Wie viel I.O. kann der schon können? Da sind fünf Festplatten drin und SSDs
und Zeug. Da passiert sehr viel gleichzeitig auf dem Motherboard.
Kann ja sein, dass da irgendwie Probleme passieren. Jetzt habe ich halt diesen
neuen Rechner, stecke den ganzen Gerätepark an und habe gehofft,
vielleicht ist das Problem Geschichte. Kurze Antwort, nein, ist es nicht.
Also, ich deute Sebastian, ich grüße in deine Richtung, er weiß es auch schon,
ich beschwere mich seit 10 Jahren darüber, aber ja gut, also das heißt,
wenn ihr hofft, das Problem damit zu erschlagen, geht nicht.
Über Ethernet oder über WLAN?
Ethernet.
Echt, bei Ethernet hast du das Problem?
Ethernet, ja. Ich habe ein Premium-Ethernet-Kabel zwischen Mac und Router.
Vermute ja wirklich ein Bug im Studio-Link.
Kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Ja, ich denke auch. Also Sebastian hat auch gesagt.
Da ist was braun.
Genau, weil ich habe zu Twitch, das ist eine andere Beobachtung von der positiven Seite.
Ich habe mit meiner Band damit auch so eine Twitch-Show gestartet und da hat
der liebe Lindworm auch geholfen, OBS und die ganzen Sachen,
die man dafür braucht, zu installieren und das war wirklich, das war wirklich schön.
Also, stellt euch folgendes vor, Twitch-Stream mit einer Band heißt,
du hast vier Leute vor Kameras sitzen und meinen zweiten Monitor,
auf dem vielleicht ein YouTube-Video gezeigt wird.
Das heißt, du hast schon vier Video-Streams, die sowieso bei mir ankommen,
meine eigene Kamera inklusive und dann noch eins, der aufgezeichnet wird.
Das Ganze muss natürlich umgerechnet werden und als Stream zu Twitch geschickt
werden und es muss ja noch Video zu den anderen Leuten jeweils geschickt werden.
Das heißt, da geht eine ganze Menge über die GPU.
Also hier muss auf jeden Fall sehr viel berechnet werden. Beim Hacky war es
so, wir haben das auf 30 Frames pro Sekunde in Full HD gestellt und haben in dem Moment Wieso.
Muss da viel über die GPU laufen?
Video-Codierung Das ist die CPU bestimmt auch, aber Video-Codierung passiert da sehr viel.
Was für ein Video codierst du denn da?
Ja, alle Kamera-Feeds rein.
Und raus Hartz-264 Ja Das macht ja überhaupt nicht die GPU.
Die von NVIDIA können das.
Reden wir jetzt von PCs oder von dem Mac?
Er redet von Hacky.
Achso, du redest von Hacky?
Ja, genau, wir sind gerade beim... Aber da wäre auch kein NVIDIA,
Roddy, weil geht ja nicht mehr.
Achso, ja, okay.
Da ist so eine Engine drauf.
Dein Mac Studio macht Videoencoding in einem eigenen Videoencoder,
der nicht Teil der GPU ist.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, gut, das ist das Rumschieben von Silikon. Also das ist jetzt nicht das Ding.
Ja, aber es ist nicht... Das hat nichts mit der GPU erstmal an sich zu tun.
Die GPU macht kein Video-Encoding.
Also sagen wir mal, in der GPU-CPU-Kombi und der Engine, die in der Grafikkarte
ist für H.264-Encoding, kann ich halt nur beobachten,
dass wenn ich das versucht habe in Full-HD mit 30 Frames, war der Rechner ausgelastet
und in dem Moment, wo ich versucht habe, ein YouTube-Video abzuspielen,
waren wir runter auf 10 Frames pro Sekunde und alles ruckelte.
Ja, das war der Hacky mit einer dezidierten Grafikkarte.
Dann habe ich den M4 angeschlossen.
Wir haben das ganze Setup gemacht in 60 Frames, doppelte Framemenge,
hatten noch eine Person mehr dabei.
Und ich habe halt die ganze Zeit schön vom zweiten Bildschirm gestreamt und
alle Bilder werden durch die Gegend geschoben, was man so macht beim Umschalten
zwischen Personen, so wie bei der Tagesschau auch oder so.
und dann gucke ich unten auf die Prozessoranzeige oder auf die Auslastungsanzeige
von OBS und sie sagt, 2,5 Prozent.
Und dafür, dass irgendwie der alte Rechner vorher so gar nichts konnte,
war ich halt so flabbergasted.
Das war so, okay, ich habe erwartet, dass er das kann, aber nicht, dass er nichts tut.
Es war so, okay.
In acht Jahren ist was passiert.
Also dein alter Rechner hat das, wie gesagt, die GPU spielt überhaupt gar keine
Rolle, sondern das hat die CPU gemacht. Deswegen geht die Kiste auch in die Knie.
Weil wenn du keinen Hardware-Encoder hast, dann machst du das in Software und
das macht die CPU. Es gibt in der GPU keinen H264-Encoder.
Ich habe irgendeine H64-Encoder-Engine.
Es kann mal Grafikkarten geben, die sowas haben.
Ja, eigentlich alle. Alle externen Grafikkarten haben Encoder inzwischen.
Die vom macOS unterstützt sind.
Ja, ich habe das in Final Cut gesehen. Nicht unbedingt.
Doch, du siehst in Final Cut dann. Es gibt so Testprogramme,
die dir das sagen. Also ich habe da natürlich extra drauf geachtet.
Ich habe ja so Videoschnitt gemacht.
Deswegen war ich auch erstattet. Ob jetzt genau OBS das dann vielleicht nicht
benutzt hat oder so und deswegen Probleme kamen, das kann gut sein.
Der Unterschied war auf jeden Fall eklatant. Jetzt kommt die Pointe der Story.
Dann habe ich natürlich Final Cut aufgemacht, 4K, Riesen-Video-Dinge und habe
halt gedacht, so, jetzt exportiere ich mal irgend so ein Video.
Zwei Stunden 4K-Video schön exportieren. Und habe gedacht, das muss ja jetzt
da durch, wie durch Butter. Der Ralf hat immer gesagt, M-Prozessoren in Ultraschall,
jetzt geht alles hundertmal so schnell.
Und tatsächlich war es zehn Prozent schneller als der Hacky.
Und ich war dann so, hä?
In H264?
Ja. Und ich dachte dann auch, aber ich hab doch so und so viele GPU-Kerne.
Und da war ich falsch, denn es macht nicht die GPU, sondern es machen die beiden,
die nur zwei Engines, die es gibt in diesem Rechner, für genau H264-Encoding.
Und das war halt, also ich meine, es war zügig und so weiter.
Also arbeiten mit Video ist eine Freude. Gar keine Frage.
Aber dieses reine Video-Exportieren, da hab ich echt gedacht,
ist irgendwas kaputt? Hab ich irgendwas nicht eingeschaltet?
Aber Final Cut nutzt natürlich alles, was geht und ist eigentlich auch sehr schnell.
Da war ich dann so, okay, das hatte ich jetzt geiler erwartet.
Das ist ja überhaupt nicht richtig zusammen, weil im Prinzip ist der Export
in Final Cut und das, was OBS macht, ja eigentlich genau das gleiche.
Deswegen gucke ich auch wie so ein Auto. Ja, verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht.
Aber wie findest du denn so generell den Rechner an sich so als Rechner?
Naja, wie interagiere ich damit schon, außer über das macOS,
ne? Also was meinst du, Hardware-mäßig, Anschlüsse, Speed?
Na so das Gesamtpaket, so ist der Rechner für dich in der Summe what you want,
ist das irgendwie so das Device oder willst du doch lieber ein Mac Pro haben?
Ne, ich finde den schon ganz fantastisch. Ich würde sagen, der eine Hinke-Fuß,
der mich wirklich stört, ist die SSD-Preispolitik und so.
Ich habe den allerkleinsten mit 512 gekauft, weil ich davon ausging,
dass diese französischen und chinesischen Buden das schon hinkriegen werden,
da interne Plattenersatz zu bauen.
Bis heute habe ich aber noch nichts davon gehört.
Gibt es nur für den Mac Mini.
Für den Mac Mini gibt es die, ja.
Aber auch nur für das normale, nicht das Pro-Modell, glaube ich. Oder?
Ich bin gerade nicht so sicher. Es kann sein, dass sich das auch schon geändert
hat. Auf jeden Fall habe ich für ein Mac Studio auch noch nichts gehört.
Das Ding ist wohl, dass der SSD-Controller auch mit in dem M4 drin ist.
Weswegen du keine normalen SSDs da rein tust, weil der halt auch gleich die
gesamte Verschlüsselung im Chip macht und diesen ganzen Krempel.
Genau. Zum Thema M4 habe ich auch noch eine Kleinigkeit und zwar wurde ja bei
der WWDC angekündigt, dass man jetzt sowas wie Speech-to-Text auch lokal machen kann, oder macOS.
Und da hat jemand, hier, Link im Chat, hat jemand ein kleines Tool geschrieben,
mit dem man das also machen kann. JEP heißt es.
Das funktioniert nur auf macOS 26 bis jetzt. Also wird auch nie auf einer älteren
Version funktionieren.
Und ich habe es halt einfach mal probiert.
Und Englisch.
Wie Englisch. Nein, Speech-to-Text. Ich habe es ausprobiert mit der letzten Sendung.
Ich habe die komplette Sendung so wie sie ist, in das Tool reingeworfen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr mal raten, wie lange er gebraucht hat, um die gesamte Sendung zu transkribieren.
Also der kann Deutsch sozusagen.
Also Whisper macht es bei mir auf dem M2 Pro in 20-facher Real-Time.
Heißt, wie lange braucht er dann?
Wie lange war die Sendung? Fünf Stunden.
Ja, also er hat 106 Sekunden gebraucht.
Oh. Das ist sehr schnell.
Für eine 5-Stunden-Sendung.
Ach so, aber warte.
On-Device.
On-Device, ja. Auf dem M4. Also es ist kein Pro oder so.
Und das war das Geilste. Er hat, der Prozessorlast war so konstant bei 5 bis 10 Prozent.
Ja, weil auch hier kommt halt der andere, wieder ein anderer Teil des M4 zum
Einsatz. nämlich, also der ist die NPU kommt jetzt im Einzelnen.
Der ist nicht so richtig in die Puste gekommen.
Hat der am Anfang irgendwie das Modell erstmal geladen?
Ich erinnere mich nicht.
Also das ist häufig bei Stable Diffusion so, dass du quasi zum ersten Renderdurchlauf
erstmal so 60 Sekunden wartest und bis die ganzen Modelle erstmal hochgefahren sind.
Und danach geht es dann super zackig.
Ja, weil es keine MLX Modelle sind.
Warte mal, ich mach mal folgendes und mach den.
Wie viel RAM hast du?
Nur die 16. Ich hab wirklich das kleinste Basismodell von dem M4 Mac Mini gekauft,
weil ich hatte auf diese Preisleiterpolitik überhaupt keinen Bock und dachte,
du benutzt den jetzt mal so, wie der ist und dann wird er schon passen.
So, ich kann das jetzt mal hier reinschmeißen.
Das ist die Ausgabe auf der Kommandozeile. Also es ist halt jetzt ein Kommandozeilen-Tool.
Und da steht halt Audio Transcribed, 106 Sekunden, Success.
Transcription, Written to, Blah, Text und so weiter. Ich habe so ein bisschen durchgeguckt.
Da sind natürlich Worte dabei, die ihr nicht kennt, aber im Großen und Ganzen
war die auch ganz brauchbar.
Also keine zwei Minuten, wo Whisper 15 Minuten gebraucht hätte,
wenn ich das richtig gerechnet habe jetzt.
5 Stunden, 300 Minuten mal 20.
Und die Erkennungsqualität?
Sei wohl ganz gut.
Also ich habe jetzt klar sehen, also ich habe halt das Pfeil aufgemacht und
habe mir dann angeguckt, wie viele rote Würmchen sind denn da drin.
Aber fand jetzt auch nicht, dass das so unglaublich viele waren, ehrlich gesagt.
Schreibt er die auch mit rein, die Würmchen?
Nein, aber wenn du das in Textedit aufmachst, Und dann, die Würmchen schreibt er nicht mit dran.
Nein, habe ich das Fall schon weg. Egal.
Achso, nee, habe ich nicht auf dem Rechner.
Genau, also das wollte ich nur mal erwähnt haben, weil ich war doch sehr erstaunt,
wie schnell das ging und wie wenig CPU-Last er dafür gebraucht hat.
Ja, aber Apple kann kein KI, von wegen.
Ich habe Fragen.
Ja.
Ich habe eine ganze Weile bei Audiodump durfte ich ein System mit Beta testen
von einem Amerikaner Andrew.
Die haben auf Servern so Transkriptionssachen angeboten, hatten überlegt,
Podcasting mäßig was damit zu machen und haben das auch eine ganze Weile entwickelt.
Und er hat auf meinen Drängen hin quasi etwas gebaut, was auch,
falls die aus Ultraschall kommen, entsprechend irgendwie sinnvoll aufnimmt und
falls die zu Potluff gehen, sinnvoll ausspuckt.
Und zwar, was ich halt gemacht habe, war eine.
Also ich habe ausgespielt eine Spur pro Sprecher und zwar in,
das habe ich über die Zeit dann festgestellt,
in so maximal kleinster MP3-Qualität, die schnell zu rechnen und gerade noch
gut genug verständlich ist, weil das hat die Erkennungsqualität nicht gedrückt,
aber Upload und Berechnung massiv beschleunigt.
einfach, wenn die Dateien kleiner waren, witzigerweise.
Das heißt, ich habe ihm vielleicht fünf Spuren geschickt und auf diesen Server
abgeloadet und die Kapitelmarken, das Chapter-File und habe zurückbekommen, ein Transkript,
wo eben die Sprecherinnen und Sprecher entsprechend markiert waren mit den Zeitmarken
und die Kapitel auch schon drin waren.
Also etwas, was im Podlove-Player direkt perfekt gut aussah.
Und das ist etwas, was leider der Jordi Boyne, der Mac Whisper macht,
nie wirklich zu Ende gebaut hat. Bei dem hatte ich das nämlich vorher versucht, von ihm zu bekommen.
Und hier steht bei Podcast Transcription immer noch Beta dran.
Und das, was da rauskommt, konnte ich nie wirklich in Podlove werfen.
Und was bringt es mir dann?
Deswegen meine Frage ist jetzt, die Zeiten, die du da gerade genannt hast,
die gehen von einem Mono MP3 aus, wo alle Sprecher, Sprecherinnen kreuz und quer drin sind.
Ja, es war eine M4A. Und ob die jetzt Stereo war, weiß ich nicht.
aber einfach das, was ich jetzt mal eben von Freakshow FM runterladen konnte,
Ich habe da jetzt keinen größeren Aufwand reingesteckt.
Aber es gibt keine Sprecherunterscheidung?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, weil es ist auch nur eine Datei und du merkst auch so ein
bisschen, dass er da natürlich jetzt auch nichts zu tun kann.
Ich habe auch nur die ganz normale, also dieses Tool, JEP, ist jetzt im Prinzip
auch nur eine Fingerübung von irgendjemand gewesen, mal zu gucken,
wie gut funktioniert denn die Erkennung. Das kann nicht so richtig viel.
Man kann da irgendwie noch so eine YouTube-Untertiteldatei kann man da irgendwie erzeugen.
Aber das war es dann auch. Also wenn man jetzt ein sinnvolles Tool haben will,
müsste man nochmal den Compiler anwerfen.
Aber ich fand das halt einfach auch als Test dafür, wie gut funktioniert diese
Speech-to-Text-Übertragung überhaupt, die Apple da anbietet.
Und ich muss sagen, ich war schon beeindruckt.
Ja, das kommt jetzt.
Das, was ich da damals hatte, also was ich da mitnutzen durfte for free,
das haben sie dann leider eingestellt nach einem Jahr, weil sie dann andere
Tools entwickelt haben, aber das hat halt eine ganze Sendung,
Audio Dumps auch so wie hier, drei, vier Stunden mit, sagen wir mal,
fünf Spuren in zwei Minuten transkribiert und mir das File geschickt.
Ich habe das halt damals noch lokal auf dem Hackie probiert,
das hat es ja vollkommen vergessen.
Also mal ehrlich, überrascht euch das jetzt wirklich? Also man kann sich jetzt
schon seit einiger Zeit mit diesen AI-Chatbots irgendwie live unterhalten,
die transkribieren alles quasi in Realtime.
Das Ding ist durch. Also wir haben jetzt mit den neuen Modellen wirklich sehr,
sehr gute Transkriptionen und natürlich auch eine sehr gute Text-to-Speech-Generierung.
Sprache in jeder Hinsicht ist glaube ich jetzt so gut wie durch das Thema.
Ich habe mich gewundert, dass es funktioniert, sondern nur, wie gut es funktioniert,
wenn du die Randbedingungen bedenkst.
Also da ist jetzt nicht ein riesiges Data Center im Hintergrund,
das weiß ich nicht, wie viele AI-Ressourcen draufwirft, sondern halt auch einfach
der normale M4, der hat ja auch nur vier Performance-Kerne.
Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass der jetzt aus dem Vollen schöpfen könnte
oder so, sondern das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Schmalspurprozessor an sich.
Und dafür fand ich das jetzt einfach mal mit quasi Hausmitteln,
die Apple jetzt dann ausrollen wird, das mal eben drüber gerechnet,
fand ich das schon beeindruckend. Eindruckend ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich das jetzt irgendwie auf Stuhl gehe.
Du hast natürlich, wir reden ja von Faktor 150, also nicht Realtime,
sondern 150 mal so schnell wie Realtime.
Und das Ganze eben auf so einer, weil das würde wahrscheinlich auf dem iPhone
genauso schnell laufen.
Naja, iPhone-Prozessoren sind deutlich niedriger getaktet.
als die Mac-Prozessoren und du hast ja auch kein M4 im iPhone,
also du müsstest wenn, dann schon ein iPad nehmen.
Du hast aber auch die NPU, also die ist ja jetzt nicht so schlecht.
Also 150 wirst du wahrscheinlich auf dem iPhone nicht hinkriegen,
sondern wahrscheinlich nur 50 oder 40 oder so, aber ja, also solche Zahlen sind realistisch.
Aber auf dem iPad hast du ja auch ein M4 drin.
Also Ja, wie gesagt, der ist halt niedriger getaktet, weil der muss ja in der
Batterie irgendwie, ne, und so.
Aber jetzt, wie gesagt, also ich fand das zumindest so, hey,
das ist jetzt im Allerweltsding angekommen.
Und vor allem wird es bedeuten, dass alle Podcast-Clients, die was auf sich halten,
werden jetzt Ende dieses Jahres mit einem Update rauskommen und wenn du die
auf dem neuesten iOS 26 laufen lässt oder iPadOS, dann können die quasi alle Podcasts,
lokal transkribieren und durchsuchbar machen.
Sie haben halt nicht die Sprecherunterscheidung, die gibt es halt nur in der Metaebene.
Weil das ja ein Premium-Podcast ist und nicht so ein Vergangenheits-Podcast. Aber immerhin.
Aber du machst ja Auphonic, ne?
So gesehen, ja.
Ich mache Auphonic, weil Auphonic macht das halt schon ganz lange ganz richtig
und das ist ja auch einer der Hauptgründe, warum ich das benutze,
ist, dass ich da einfach Multitrack arbeiten kann und dass ich da Multitrack-Transkriptionen
habe, weil das mir schon immer wichtig war, dass man ein ordentliches Transkript hat.
und das, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange mache ich das jetzt eigentlich schon?
Schon ein paar Jahre auf jeden Fall.
Mit dem Transkript?
Ja, und ich als Ultraschall Ultra frage natürlich Ralf, der auffällig schweigt gerade.
Ich muss das gerade installieren.
Ja, ich wollte, weil ich kenne halt nur die Lösung, seit meine Lösung jetzt
nicht mehr geht, mache ich einfach keine Transkription mehr.
Das hat sich übrigens nie jemand beschwert.
Aber ich finde es halt auch schön, das zu haben, auch wegen Durchsuchbarkeit und so.
Und jetzt ist aber meine Sache, okay, wenn ich aber nicht auf Phonic machen
möchte, weil ich bräuchte es für nichts anderes als genau nur für das Transkriptionsthema
und dann würde ich das gerne lieber anders erschlagen.
Wann, wie kriegen wir die Multisprecher-Transkription in Ultraschall 6?
Also wir, ja ich habe es gerade up and running hier, die Geschwindigkeit ist
in der Tat beeindruckend.
Ich werde jetzt mal ein paar A-B-Tests erfahren, wie sich das von der Qualität
her zu MacWhisper verhält.
So zu deiner Frage, also wir haben das auf dem Schirm jetzt für die Ultraschall
6, dass wir eigentlich das in Ultraschall selber transparent laufen haben.
Also ich habe das Framework ja schon mal vor anderthalb Jahren zusammengehackt,
wie man dann den Text in die Timeline reinbekommt, sodass man also auch quasi
auf den Text schneiden kann und schön suchen kann,
wo ist jetzt die Audio-Stelle, wo XY gesagt worden ist. So, das haben wir eigentlich alles schon gelöst.
Und die Frage ist halt nur so, wie und mit was für einem Verfahren macht man halt die...
Die Texterkennung. Und so ein Gedanken, den ich noch nicht ganz aufgegeben habe,
ist das einfach über einen VST-Plugin zur Laufzeit zu machen.
Das heißt also, während man den Podcast einspricht, im Hintergrund schon die
Texterkennung drin zu haben.
Sodass du also quasi schon mitlesen kannst, während du sprichst.
Also sobald Aufnahme gestoppt ist, kannst du sofort loslegen mit dem Schnitt
und musst dann eben nicht nochmal irgendwie wie lange warten.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das jetzt hier, was ich jetzt gerade sehe,
natürlich dermaßen schnell.
Da kommt es dann darauf dann auch nicht mehr so wirklich drauf an.
Aber so das ist noch up to discussion.
Und es soll ja auch alles auf alten Rechnern laufen und mal gucken,
was uns da noch so einfällt. Aber das wird kommen auf jeden Fall.
Aber auf dem Mac könnt ihr das sozusagen richtig schnell machen dann?
Naja, schon.
Auf Linux gibt es das dann auch in zehn Jahren.
Die Erkennungsquels sieht doch echt nicht schlecht aus, was ich jetzt hier sehe.
Also wir experimentieren bei uns auf der Arbeit jetzt auch gerade mit Protokollwesen,
dass man das also so als Zwischenstufe für das dann immer noch von Menschen
produzierte Protokoll, aber zumindest schon mal ein ziemlich gutes Wortprotokoll
hat, um nochmal Dinge irgendwie nachschlagen zu können.
Und da muss ich mal gucken, wie sich das hier so schlägt. Ja,
danke für den Tipp, Rodi. Super, das gucke ich mir mal genauer an.
Ja, dachte ich mir doch, dass das spannend ist.
Darf ich nochmal ein bisschen rumposen?
Nein.
Doch. wenn du so fragst,
erster Multisprecher erste Multisprecher Transkription auf der Meta-Ebene mehr als 10 Jahre her.
Automatisch oder per Hand?
Noch per Hand. Aber im Web anklickbar, im Player sichtbar, runterladbar.
Stimmt, du hast da mal Forschergeist war das, ne?
Ja, genau. Da war das noch irgendwie
mit Geld und das hat aber dann auch nicht mehr so lange gedauert.
Dann habe ich das auch, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau,
wann auch Fonix das Feature eingeführt hat.
Müssen ich nochmal nachschlagen. Das haben die ja sicherlich in ihrem Blog irgendwie bekannt gegeben.
Aber seitdem ist da geht, mache ich das auch. Sorge noch angegeben.
Muss ja mal gesagt werden. 20 Jahre Meta-Ebene, 10 Jahre Transkription.
Sauber.
Es bleibt spannend. Also in der Tat ein Nahziel von mir mit der ganzen Technologie
ist automatische Kapitelmarkengenerierung.
Weil also ich kann das Gejammer der Leute nicht mehr hören, die dann irgendwie
immer sagen, so viel Aufwand, da bin ich doch froh, dass die Sendung gerade
durch ist. und dann eben sagen, so, guck mal hier, hast du schon mal,
wie viele Kapitel möchtest du gerne haben?
5 oder eher 10 oder willst du das ganz detailliert haben? 20?
Dabei ist das so einfach. Nicht wie Kapitelbilder, das ist richtig Arbeit.
Naja, naja. Also da geht, glaube ich, einiges.
Ja, sehr schön, wunderbar. Wieder was geblendet.
Gut, nächstes Thema. Wo sind wir jetzt?
Die goldene, der Peak-Sendung. Ist es soweit?
Ja, ich würde mal sagen, wir sollten mal einbiegen langsam, weil das dauert ja auch.
Das geht total schnell jetzt.
Genau, Tierlists. Die ganze Welt berichtet davon und wir fangen erstmal an mit
dem Feedback zur letzten Sendung und,
los geht's mit Matthias und Matthias sagt, mit den Tierlists kam der bei mir
gerade rechtzeitig, sodass ich bei meinen jüngeren Kollegin nicht doof dastand,
als sie zu etwas meinten, das ist doch voll F-Tier.
Sehr gut, gern geschehen.
Bei Beta-Ebene hören heißt zukunftskompatibel sein. Das ist doch einfach,
ja, und auch gegenwärtskompatibel.
Wobei ich das Gefühl habe, dass wir mit den Tierlists jetzt nicht unbedingt Speerspitze sind.
Schön ausgedrückt. Ich wusste aber auch nicht, was es ist. Noch nie gehört.
Ohne Tierlist bist du auf gar keinen Fall Speerspitze, weißt du,
das ist sozusagen eher so ein exklusives Ding.
Man muss die Leute patchen, one by one.
Heute Tierlist, morgen lösen wir wieder ein anderes mentales Problem,
so wird man einfach die ganze Zeit up to date gehalten.
Nicht jedes Update muss sofort kommen, aber Hauptsache es kommt.
Gut.
So, ansonsten haben sich die Leute natürlich das Maul zerrissen über unsere Meinung.
Ja, wie sollte es auch anders sein? Dafür machen wir es doch.
Im Wesentlichen hat sich das auf VGA und SD-Karten konzentriert und dann hatten wir noch….
ISA-Karten auch noch. Es gab noch einen ISA-Karten-Hart.
Also das kann man, glaube ich, einfach ignorieren. Aber schauen wir mal,
was zu VGA geschrieben wird. Also analog Bob meint, was habt ihr denn gegen VGA?
Das ist mein S-Tier. Funktioniert einfach immer und auch heute noch.
Da wackelt auch nichts und der Stecker ist sogar noch anschraubbar.
Diesen Kommentar schreibe ich quasi über VGA.
Die absolute Pest und ein klares F- ist DisplayPort mit seinen Widerhaken.
Der übelste Anschluss seit Jahrzehnten, was den Stecker angeht.
DisplayPort hatten wir ja leider vergessen. Also haben wir uns gar nicht drüber unterhalten.
und ich weiß nicht, ob er F gelandet wäre, aber naja gut, Leute haben Meinung,
wir geben das jetzt hier nur wieder.
Gustav K. schreibt, ich schließe mich dem mal an, VGA ist ein guter Stecker
und auch sinnvoll belegt.
Außerdem hat es alle relevanten Signale und kann sogar noch,
wenn Monitor und Rechner das unterstützen, so eine Art Autoerkennung über diese ID-Pins machen.
So eine Art ist genau der Punkt.
Es ist eine deutliche Verbesserung im Vergleich zu den wilden Varianten,
die es vorher gab, um einen Monitor anzuschließen, das haben wir auch, glaube ich, gewürdigt.
Etwa 9 Pol Sub-D oder 15 Pol bei Mac oder 13 W3 oder nur dreimal Mini-Coax bei Deck etwa.
Oh ja, oh, aua.
Ja, wobei, ich meine, die Sub-D waren ja VGA. Dazu noch lustige Anschlüsse,
wie die für die hochauflösenden Monitore, etwa am Atari ST oder die beliebige
Vielfalt an jeder erdenklichen Steckerform bei den 8-Bit-Rechnern.
Ich denke, wir haben das auch gewürdigt, dass VGA das schon alles so ein bisschen vereinheitlicht hat.
Aber wir hatten VGA doch auf A getan, oder?
Oder war der weiter unten?
Schauen wir nochmal kurz nach. Das ist ja jetzt, nachdem ich das so gut vergessen hatte.
Der ist auf D.
Er ist auf D.
War das irgendwie Absicht.
Dass es kein E gibt?
Ich glaube, wir haben ihn einfach, er ist auf D, ja es ist Absicht,
damit F sozusagen nochmal schlechter ist, als nur Rieger ist da drunter.
Also ich nehme das an, ich denke, D war zu wenig. Egal.
Ja, aber es ist auch zu viel.
Flolle sagt, VGA war wirklich lange sehr gut.
DP, also Displayport gibt es übrigens auch noch ohne die Haken mit Hakenkabel,
aber wie bei verschraubten VGA-Kabeln den Rechner dran aufhängen.
Da muss man sagen, der erste Poster, der die Widerhaken nicht mag,
aber dann VGA mit dem, ich schraub immer den Stecker an.
Also ich finde ja, anschraubbare Stecker generell eine gute Idee,
auch wenn sie eine ganze Menge Platz wegnehmen.
Und dann schraubst du ihn ab und dann hast du die Mutter mit am Stecker?
Also doch die, also... Ja, na gut, das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema.
Wir haben ja das Interface als solches gemacht.
Big Brother schließt das VGA-Thema ab mit VGA, moderner Schnickschnack.
Steinplatten und Hammer und Meißel ist die wahre Form der Darstellung.
Überdauert Jahrtausende, braucht keinen Strom, ist mit allem kompatibel, auch ohne Adapter.
Maximale Auflösung, besser wie Retina, muss nirgendwo angeschraubt werden.
Okay, gut, das war ein guter Joke.
Der liest zu viel Asterix.
Genau.
Dann ging es zu SD-Karten.
Helmut sagt, zu eurer SD-Karteneinstufung, die ist BS, vor allem im Vergleich mit CF.
Da weiß aber einer Bescheid hier über die Abkürzung.
Ja, aber CF war doch so Nischenstandard.
CompactFlash. Hatten wir das überhaupt?
Das hatten wir nicht, nee. Aus Gründen.
Aber wir hatten doch PCMCIA. War CompactFlash nochmal was anderes?
Ja, das war so ein kleineres Format.
sehr, sehr viel größer als SD mit Pins und alles, wo Pins dran sind,
finde ich schon mal nicht gut.
Hat halt den riesen Vorteil, dass der Controller da halt mit drauf saß.
Und das, was SD jetzt immer vorgeworfen wird, jetzt hier auch in den Postings.
Die SD-Karten sind mechanisch der letzte D. Allein die Stege zwischen den Kontakten
brechen gerne ab und bleiben dann im Slot stecken, was dann das Gerät zwischen
teurer Reparatur und Totalschaden schwanken lässt.
Okay, das habe ich noch nicht erlebt.
Ich habe in meinem Leben noch keine kaputte SD-Karte gesehen.
Ich auch nicht.
Also nicht mechanisch kaputt, elektrisch kaputt, ja, kommt vor.
Dann noch die verschiedenen Standards, SD, HC, XC und das noch in verschiedenen Geschwindigkeiten.
Das alles, weil SD selbst dumm ist und der Controller im Lesegerät sitzen muss.
Deswegen kann man dann mit einem Gerät für SD-Karten keine SD,
HC oder gar XC-Karten lesen. Ich meine, das ist technischer Fortschritt.
Immerhin wird es immer besser und das haben wir ja eigentlich auch gewürdigt
durch den SD, weil es halt einfach auch immer besser wird. Kann man so oder so sehen.
Bla bla bla, das ist alles bei CompactFlash kein Thema. Robust,
da kann sogar ein Auto drüber fahren und der Controller liegt auf der Karte.
Da braucht es keinen neuen Standard für größere Größen oder Geschwindigkeiten.
CF gehört mindestens nach A, wenn nicht S.
SD maximale C, E, A, D. Na gut, also ich weiß nicht, CompactFlash hat mich nicht
so überzeugt, aber meinetwegen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen CompactFlash, also ich hab's immer als Nischenstandard empfunden.
Also die Nische kannst du nicht in S tun einfach. Und es war relativ teuer auch
und es hat sich halt auch einfach nicht durchgesetzt.
Und da kann man halt auch mal drüber sprechen, warum hat es sich eigentlich nicht durchgesetzt?
War halt auch zu klobig und zu teuer und so, weiß ich nicht.
Naja, gut. Also ich sag mal so, SD meinetwegen, ich würde es auch noch in A,
werfen, VGA, okay, meinetwegen vielleicht auf C.
Da würde ich grad noch mit mir reden lassen, aber wesentlich.
Ansonsten hatten wir bei allem recht.
Genau.
Nee, also mich.
Was, was, was?
Ach, jetzt kommst du. Häckler.
So was. Mich haben zwei Entscheidungen geschmerzt.
Ja, komm mal los.
Geschmerzt, ja. Und zwar das auf B sind meine Lieblingsstecker gelandet,
nämlich Lightning und Firewire.
Und aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Ich bin gerade nicht mehr sicher,
ob ihr das bei Lightning gesagt hattet. Vielleicht schon.
Dass die Kontakte so schnell korrodieren, hat für mich halt das Problem,
ich habe fast nur kaputte Lightning-Stecker.
Weil die halt, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht keine Ahnung.
Goldlitzenkabel. Meine Meinung.
Leckt die nicht an, aber trotzdem korrodieren die halt einfach.
Okay, also ich hatte das Problem tatsächlich nicht, aber ich finde,
es gab noch nie einen überzeugenderen, reinen Steckkontakt für mich als Lightning.
Ich bin ja jetzt auch im USB-C-Game, auch mit dem iPhone und so und immer noch,
jetzt zwei Jahre später fast, vermisse ich den Lightning-Stecker.
Ja, das stimmt. Der Lightning-Stecker hat eine ganz andere Robustheit als so
ein USB-C. Bei USB-C hat man immer so das Gefühl, ein bisschen vorsichtig mit Umgehen.
Man kratzt da auch immer so am iPhone rum und so Und hier dieses Pimmelchen-in-Loch-Konzept
vom Lightning ist halt auch einfach von der Natur über Jahrtausende schon ausgemendelt worden.
Und das haben die halt einfach für sich sinnvoll genutzt.
Während du halt beim USB-C nimmst du ja quasi einen Kreis und schiebst ihn über
einen nicht zu sehenden, ein Loch muss in ein Loch und so. Das ist irgendwie schwierig.
Und bei Lightning muss ich einfach sagen, es gab keinen geileren Steckkontakt
bei allen Steckern, die ich je kannte.
Also fand ich immer super. Und Firewire hat halt, wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen
mit Video zu tun hatte, ihr erinnert euch an Steve Jobs und den Digital Hub,
den der iMac damals darstellte und so dieses, wenn du mit einer DV-Kamera unterwegs
warst und einem Mac, dann hat Firewire digitales Video ermöglicht.
Das war ein absoluter Enabler für dieses gesamte Videothema und da kam nie irgendeine
andere Lösung am PC oder sonst wo ran.
Deswegen für diesen Bereich war Firewire so an sich, also natürlich nicht nur
der Stecker, auch das Protokoll und so.
Ja, Firewire war zu einem Zeitpunkt halt ein Hochgeschwindigkeitsstandard,
wo es wenig Alternativen gab, als der rauskam.
Also dem gebe ich recht. Trotzdem hat Firewire auch ein Nischenprodukt geblieben.
Leider, also meiner Meinung nach hätte Firewire eigentlich mehr gekonnt,
aber dann hat Apple irgendwie die Lizenzzahlungen angezogen.
und dann ist der emergierende Standard auch gleich wieder gestorben.
Das ist die Frage, was man da höher gewichtet. Ich wollte nur sagen,
diese beiden Entscheidungen schmerzten mich.
Wir haben ihn ja auch nicht so niedrig gerankt, weil er jetzt ein schlechter Standard wäre oder so.
Ist er ja nicht, sondern einfach, weil er es nicht geschafft hat,
sich aus der Nische heraus zu bewegen.
Oder zwei Macs verbinden mit Firewire. Es war Magie.
Ja, auch der Firewire Target Disc Mode. Den vermisse ich eigentlich auch immer noch.
Ich vermisse ihn auch immer noch. Warum geht das nicht? Jetzt kann ich mal meinen
User-Folder auf eine externe Platte tun, das ist alles traurig.
Okay, aber das war nur mein Feedback dazu.
Schöne Diskussion, aber...
Ja, wollen wir jetzt sozusagen noch mal anpassen?
Nee, nö.
Es gilt das gesprochene Wort.
Echt?
Ja.
Wir haben ja gesprochen noch mal quasi angepasst, aber du musst jetzt nicht
die Liste noch mal umräumen.
Okay, gut. Ich wäre dazu bereit gewesen, aber wenn ihr so zerstörerisch drauf seid.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite Hörer der letzten Sendung, die diese noch nicht
gehört haben und dann sehen, dass die Liste nicht passt zu dem, was sie da...
Teil of Konfusion kommt auch.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Alright, na gut.
So, jetzt haben wir uns aber ein Tierthema ausgesucht, mit dem wir super schnell
durchkommen werden, weil...
Was?
Da kann es zu keinem Eintrag zwei Meinungen geben.
Zugegebenermaßen habe ich da ein paar Vorschläge reingetan, die eher als Trollung gedacht sind.
Aber wir werden sehen.
Aber wir werden sehen, wir werden das diskutieren.
So und wir feiern in der Tat den ersten Hörerinnenvorschlag dazu,
nämlich von Senme, Senme, wie auch immer, der hat das am 27. Mai vorgeschlagen.
Und zwar Single-Purpose-Küchengeräte.
Und wir haben uns schon zwei Stunden die Köpfe eingeschlagen,
wie man denn diese Definition eigentlich genau fassen soll und das ist nicht einfach.
Es ist wirklich schwierig.
Ja, weil die Frage ist, also was genau ist ein Single-Purpose-Küchengerät?
Ist ein Messerwetzer ein Single-Purpose-Küchengerät oder ist es ein Küchen-Kitchen-Essential?
Oder ein Messer?
Ein Messer ist nicht Single-Purpose. Also gut, du schneidest nur damit,
aber du kannst sehr viele Dinge damit schneiden.
Ja, aber ich glaube, Single-Purpose ist schon nochmal ein etwas eng gefasster Begriff.
Also so ein Ananasschneider zum Beispiel, das ist schon definitiv sehr Single-Purpose
und auch so ein Sandwich-Maker ist irgendwie Single-Purpose,
während so ein Sparschäler halt alles mögliche schält.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob wir da überhaupt auf einen grünen Zweig kommen
oder ob wir das einfach jetzt mal als Differenz im Raum stehen lassen und dann
warten wir mal ab, was das Kommentargewitter zu dem Thema sagt.
Ich glaube, da wird es darauf hinauslaufen.
Ich fürchte.
Die Frage ist nur, welchen Titel geben wir jetzt sozusagen unserer Tierliste tatsächlich?
Ist egal, die ist jetzt so, wie sie ist und wie sie heißt, ist doch egal,
oder? Single Purpose finde ich schon ganz gut.
Selbstverständlich ist das nicht egal. Titel sind überhaupt generell das Allerwichtigste.
Wir machen hier einen Podcast.
Was bitteschön hat mehr Titelkultur als Podcast?
Mal ehrlich, sag mir mal eine Sache, außer vielleicht Spiegelartikel.
Wir schweifen ab.
Wir sind in der Rigshow. Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, das ist jetzt mal wichtig.
Ich habe früher immer Spiegel gelesen und ich fand immer gut,
wie der Spiegel seine Artikel benannt hat. Früher.
Ich kann das jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz so nachvollziehen.
Inzwischen ist alles Clickbait.
Dieser Clickbait hat alles vernichtet. Früher waren die Titel beim Spiegel richtig geil.
Ich habe das geliebt. Ich habe sogar geschafft, in meiner Abi-Zeitung irgendwie
diesen Spiegel Titel-Style als Titel-Style durchzusetzen.
Weil er gut war. Also es war einfach, da steckte Humor drin,
man war schon irgendwie beim Thema, man liest schon ein bisschen was offen und
vor allem war er dann wieder erkennbar. Und das ist wichtig.
Und deswegen liebe ich Podcasts und sag mal ganz ehrlich, gibt es überhaupt
irgendeine andere Medienform im Internet, die mal jetzt jenseits vom Clickbait
in irgendeiner Form Titelkultur hat.
Blog-Beiträge, früher eigentlich auch, oder? Also das spielt jetzt auch schon echt eine Rolle.
Ja, würde ich mitgehen. Zumal das ja auch die Podcast-Reise sehr mitgeprägt hat.
Die gehen ja ein bisschen Hand und Hand in den Sonnenuntergang. Okay.
Ja, gut zugegebenermaßen. Also auch YouTube-Videos vielleicht nicht unbedingt.
Mir finde ich, hilft nicht.
Die haben eher so eine Vorschau-Bild-Kultur.
Um nicht noch weiter abunschuldigen. Ich schaue ein wenig auf die Uhr.
Ich hoffe, dass wir diesmal unter anderthalb Stunden Besprechung hinkommen.
Du wolltest kurzfristig diesen Dienstagstermin, obwohl ich Donnerstagstermin
hätte, hätten wir auch früher anfangen können.
Ich habe mir im Vorfeld ein paar Gedanken gemacht, was sind da jetzt eigentlich
die Kriterien und wo lang diskutiert man und was darf drauf auf die Liste und was nicht.
Und ich habe mal so einen Vorschlag für eine Formel, an der man sich vielleicht entlanghangeln kann.
Weil man kann sich darauf vermutlich doch erstmal einigen, jedes Küchen,
in Klammern Spezialgerät, wird irgendwelche großen Fans haben und es wird Leute
geben, die ohne überhaupt gar nicht irgendwie leben können.
Das heißt also, und das den Leuten abzusprechen, finde ich auch irgendwie komisch.
Aber es muss halt in Relation stehen zu anderen Faktoren.
Und die Formel, die ich jetzt vorschlagen würde, ist folgendes.
Erstens, was in jeder Küche fehlt, ist Platz.
Jede Küche ist zu klein. Egal wie groß sie ist, egal wie clever sie gebaut ist,
es ist immer zu wenig Platz.
Und das gilt insbesondere für so Stellflächen oder Geräte, die dann halt richtig
Stellfläche für sich beanspruchen und die nicht nur in irgendeinem Regal oder
in einer Schublade verschwinden.
Das heißt also, so ein Wasserkocher, der beansprucht dann halt auch einfach mal Platz.
Das heißt also, das Erste, was man irgendwie gegeneinander abwägen muss,
ist Platzbedarf versus Platzbedarf.
Nutzen oder Nützlichkeit. Und der dritte Faktor, den ich vorschlagen würde,
ist sowas wie Verbreitung oder Akzeptanz.
Warte mal, was war der erste?
Der erste ist sowas wie Nützlichkeit. Das heißt also… Okay.
Nützlichkeit, zweite?
Zweite ist Platzbedarf und das dritte ist sowas wie Verbreitung,
also wie mainstreamig ist das eigentlich.
Dann ist die Formel Verbreitung mal Nützlichkeit durch Platz. Ist die Formel.
Kannst du die dann immer ausrechnen?
Verbreitung, okay, also die Popularität ist jetzt einmal...
Aber warum ist das ein Pro-Argument mit der Popularität? Ich als Vertreter des
Underdogs frage, warum ist das ein Pro?
So tausend fliegen können nicht, Millionen fliegen können nicht irren...
Guter Punkt von Herrn Assis hier.
Achso, Malik, ja. Also was ich versuche mit Popularität so ein bisschen auszuhebeln,
ist auch so eine gewisse Trivialitätsschwelle.
Also ja, man braucht jetzt irgendwie eine Bratpfanne, Punkt.
Da finde ich jetzt gar nicht so bedeutsam, jetzt da lange drüber zu diskutieren.
Es ist wichtig, sonst reden wir noch länger über die Sachen,
wenn wir nicht klar haben, was unsere Kriterien sind.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich finde, das ist ein wesentliches Merkmal von Tierlist-Diskussion,
ist korrekte Definition, worüber man einfach...
beurteilt.
Ich finde zu jedem Kriterium eine Ausnahme.
Das ist ja noch ein anderes Thema.
Nein, aber ich meine.
Man muss ja erstmal wissen, wovon man eine Ausnahme macht.
So, also das ist so das eine, worüber ich nachgedacht habe.
Und das zweite ist, ist, dass wir glaube ich aufpassen müssen,
dass wir bei etlichen unserer Kandidatenobjekten hier nicht in eine tiefe Debatte
reingehen, welche Form davon jetzt eigentlich die beste ist.
Das ist jetzt nicht Job dieser Tierlist in dieser Sendung. Also Beispiel Messerschärfer.
Ich werde also gleich ein flammendes Plädoyer dafür halten, warum man einen
wirklich guten Messerschärfer braucht in der Küche.
Aber ob das jetzt ein Haul ist oder ob das jetzt ein Leder ist oder ob das irgendwie
ein elektrisches Gerät ist, das würde den Umfang oder ein Wasserstein, ja.
Das würde den Umfang dieser Sendung, den Rahmen dieser Sendung sprengen.
Nichts sprengt das ab dieser Sendung. Hier hat alles Platz.
Die Debatte haben wir nämlich bei fast jedem Eintrag.
Ich plädiere aber sehr dafür, dass wir eine Messer-Messer-Schärfer-Tierlist-Sendung nochmal machen.
Da können wir auch gerne Huckel nochmal einladen. Der ist ja nämlich auch Experte.
Und dann können wir auch hier live in der Sendung mal eine Schärfestrecke aufbauen,
da habe ich total Bock drauf.
Aber das vielleicht nicht heute.
Eine Messers-Govel-Skala.
Was übrigens auch ganz gut wäre für eine Tierlist, ist Eiswürfelherstellung.
Also allein schon die Formen, das hatten wir auch mal in der Sendung,
wie heißt es, Eiswürfel, also keine Maschinen, sondern wo man einfach Wasser
reinkippt und das in die Kühlkultur tut.
Ja, und da gibt es auch, also allein das wäre auch schon eine Tierlist wert.
Aber wir schweifen ab.
Wir schweifen ab.
Wirklich?
Das überrascht ja jetzt sehr.
So, haben wir die Diskussion jetzt geschafft?
So, und die Frage ist, ob jetzt aus dieser eher theoretischen Betrachtung sich
jetzt noch ein präziserer Titel ableitet oder ob wir jetzt mit dem arbeiten, was jetzt hier steht.
Drüber steht Single-Purpose-Küchengeräte.
Also wegen dir können wir da jetzt auch einfach beibleiben.
Genau, ich habe den Link jetzt auch schon mal der wilden Meute vorgeworfen.
Ist das auch der richtige, den du da hättest?
Der ist der View-Only-Mode, ich habe den gecheckt. Sehr gut,
sonst hätten wir auch schon ein Problem.
Sehr gut.
Okay, na gut.
Bist du denn zufrieden mit dem Interface, wo du es das erste Mal selber benutzt hast?
Also ich hatte in der Tat von der UX her das Problem, dass ich immer versucht
habe, in die schon bestehende Liste noch Sachen hinzuzufügen.
Ich glaube, da muss auch noch eine zuerstere Dropzone rein.
Das kann man nochmal vereinheitlichen mit dieser, ja, ja, das stimmt.
Dass die Dropzone einfach größer ist, ist es auch keine gute Idee,
dass dieses Add New Objects ganz unten ist Und dazwischen die Sachen,
die man viel seltener braucht, die Links, die dann dazwischen zu haben und so.
Also da ist hier und da noch ein bisschen Spielraum.
Ich brauche unbedingt eine Zoom-Funktion für die Bilder, damit man nämlich auch
wirklich sehen kann, was wird
da eigentlich gerade gezeigt, weil der Titel ist ja auch abgeschnitten.
Das ist ein Problem.
Das heißt, ich habe weder den Titel, den ich ganz lesen kann,
noch kann ich teilweise bei den Bildern entziffern, was es ist.
Also so ein paar Nicklichkeiten sind da noch.
Und wenn ich das in die Farbhintergründe verschiebe, ist die Lesbarkeit der,
Texte, geht gar nicht, Tim.
Also Barrierefreiheit hin oder her, aber das geht gar nicht.
Weil es weiß aufhell ist.
Genau, das ist so.
Schwarzes Licht leuchtet auf von einer schwarzen Konsole in einem schwarzen
Raumschiff, ihr kennt das.
Also da musst du auch nochmal ran. Aber ansonsten grundsätzlich tut es, was es soll.
Genau, meine ganzen Beta-Kriterien habe ich dir ja schon mal in den Chat geworfen.
Ich hätte da auch noch drei bis sieben Ideen.
So, wollen wir einfach mal loslegen mit einer Geschichte, die wahrscheinlich schon kontrovers ist.
Ja, leg los.
Reiskocher.
Erste Frage, wer hat einen?
Ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht, aber viele Leute haben einen und ich habe auch schon mal einen im Einsatz gesehen.
Ich habe einen.
Interessant, dass du gleich mit einem Klassiker startest.
Ich habe einen, ich habe nämlich seitdem einen, seit ich im Asialaden einen
gesehen habe, der sehr klein und putzig ist.
Da standen irgendwie 0,6 Liter drauf oder so. Das ist tatsächlich ein Ein-Personen-Reiskocher.
Den kann man einfach anwerfen und dann hat man Mittagsreis.
Das ist einfach super.
Da kommt einfach ein Strom dran, also Stromeinschluss.
Ja.
Mit irgendwie auf dem Herd oder so.
Dann machst du Wasser und Reis rein, schaltest ihn an. So Prinzip Eierkocher,
nur dass er nicht mörbt, sondern halt dann den Reis warm hält.
Und was ist jetzt aber das prinzipielle Konstruktionsvorteil Ding Sie gegenüber,
ich nehme einen Topf und tue Wasser rein und mache das.
Das gleiche wie bei einer Kaffeemaschine.
Also ich, es gibt sehr viele Leute, die trinken Filterkaffee,
zu denen gehöre ich nicht,
aber die wenigsten brühen ihren Kaffee tatsächlich mit einem Wasserkocher und
einem Filterhalter auf, sondern die haben alle eine Kaffeemaschine. Warum?
Schmeckt der besser, der Kaffee? Nein, er schmeckt schlechter.
Man könnte, wenn man einfach nur einen Filterhalter und einen Wasserkocher hätte,
könnte man besseren Kaffee machen. Macht aber keiner.
Weil man faul ist. Ja, aber viele Leute.
Die machen das so.
Beziehungsweise so Kaffeemaschinen kann man halt irgendwie, du füllst sie an
und kannst sie später anschalten und hast dann...
Bei Kaffeemaschinen oder bei Reiskochern?
Nein, die Frage von ihm war ja, warum hat man einen Reiskocher und kocht den Reis nicht im Topf?
Aber ist da nicht die Menge an Handbewegungen einfach mal exakt dieselbe?
Ich habe ein Gefäß, da kommt Wasser rein, dann kommt da Reis rein und ich schalte etwas an.
Der Reiskocher hat einen ganz entscheidenden Vorteil über, ich mache das auf dem Herd.
Der Reis kann nicht anbrennen, weil der Reiskocher merkt, wann das Wasser verkocht
ist und schaltet dann auf den Warmhaltemodus um.
Und macht nicht Kohle draus.
Also in Asien, wo der Reiskocher ja herkommt, ist sozusagen der Reiskocher eine
permanente Quelle von Essen.
Man hat immer Reis. Das ist die Aufgabe des Reiskochers.
Es ist nicht ein Einzelschritt mit jetzt mache ich den Reis für mein Essen,
sondern Reis gibt es einfach immer.
Und der ist einfach da und der ist immer warm und der wird vorgehalten.
Und der Reiskocher kocht nicht nur den Reis, der ist mehr ein Reisdarbieter.
Also Reis ist immer da, es gibt immer Reis.
Du bestellst irgendwie Essen und so weiter, aber du bestellst kein Reis,
sondern du hast dann irgendwelche Dinge, die man halt mit Reis zusammen isst
und dann nimmst du dir Reis, weil Reis ist immer da. Das ist die Aufgabe des Reiskochers.
Er ist mehr oder weniger ein Reisebegleiter sozusagen.
Ein Reisbegleiter? Ein Reisbegleiter.
Wie so ein Samovar in den Zügen in Russland, Roddy.
Genau. Im Prinzip ist das sozusagen das Äquivalent zum Samovar.
So eine permanente Darreichung.
Ja, aber du musst ja nachfüllen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt ein Automatismus ist.
Ja, einmal am Tag.
Na gut, ich habe nur einen kleinen Reiskocher, der ist für ein bis maximal zwei
Personen gut zu verwenden.
Und ich mag meinen Reiskocher, ich möchte ihn nicht missen.
Wer das für überflüssig hält, darf das aber auch gerne für überflüssig halten.
Ich muss kurz mal die Meta-Ebene aufmachen, denn es wird sich zu Recht darüber
beschwert, dass die Liste kaputt ist.
Bei mir ist sie auch, die Links gehen nicht mehr und bei mir ist sie jetzt auch weg.
Welche Links gehen nicht mehr?
Der rankt sie über unsere Küchensachen.
Schade, dass der Abend zu Ende musste.
Okay, also unser Edit geht ja noch.
Nee, bei mir nicht.
Wenn ich Reload mache, ist es bei mir in der Tat auch weg jetzt.
Ja, bei mir auch.
Bei mir nicht, komischerweise.
Gededosed.
Aber ich habe hier tatsächlich ein, hm, okay.
Kann es echt ein Problem von Zugriffsmenge sein?
Ja, kann es sein. Lass mich kurz, ich mache mal mehr CPU. Ah, ich habe auch.
Wo läuft das Ding?
Auf Fly.
Ich lasse das Ding mal kurz auf.
Hauptsache, die Datenbank ist dann safe, oder?
Die Datenbank ist eh safe.
Bleibt und safe müsste da was kommen.
Also Roddy, du würdest sagen, dass auch diesen Aspekt Platzbedarf,
den ich ja sehr zentral gemacht habe, dir ist es für deinen Reiskonsum diesen
Platzwert, den der einnimmt.
Ja, weil ich habe, der ist tatsächlich sehr klein. Also der ist kleiner als der Wasserkocher.
Wie viele Portionen gehen da so rein?
Also kriegt man eine vierköpfige Familie und mit verreist?
Nein, ich habe ja auch klar gesagt, das ist eher ein Ein-Personen-Reiskocher.
Du kannst jetzt im Prinzip auch für zwei Personen Reis kochen, würde ich sagen.
Aber mehr schafft er nicht, weil es ist tatsächlich ein sehr kleines Gerät.
Ich hätte aber auch nicht Bedarf für eine vierköpfige Familie Reiskocher.
Also hier Daniela schreibt im Chat, wir Inder kochen Reis im Topf, 2 zu 1 und gut.
Das ist exakt das, was ich halt auch mache. Also ich denke da eben auch nicht
groß nach, sondern ich nehme halt irgendein Behältnis und ein Teil Reis und
zwei Teile Wasser. und dann, wenn das Wasser weg ist, ist Reis fertig.
Ja, richtig, aber dann musst du halt zugegen sein, wenn das der Fall ist.
Also wenn dieser Moment ist. Wenn ich koche, bin ich in der Regel zugegen.
Du hast doch auch dann nicht nur trockenen Reis, oder? Sondern du machst nur
noch irgendwas zum Reis dazu.
Und dafür bist du ja in der Küche anwesend.
Ja, es sei denn, ich grille. Und der Reiskocher kocht Reis, damit ich zum Grillen Reis habe.
Nun gut.
Also ein Reiskocher ist auf jeden
Fall ein geiles Teil und ein wichtiges Single-Purpose-Gerät in der Küche.
Das kann eine Menge viele Leute, also Verbreitung, hast du ja als Kriterium
gemacht, ist extrem groß.
Der Platzbedarf okay ist da.
Irgendwas in der asiatischen Küche ist ja ohne Reis sowieso nichts los.
Also ohne Reis nichts los.
Und von daher würde ich sagen, ist das auf jeden Fall mindestens A-Tier.
Ja, man kann, aber dann bricht so ein bisschen Single Purpose,
man kann auch rote Linsen da drin machen, das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Also wofür man die noch zwecks entfremden kann, da werde ich jetzt mal ganz tolerant.
Okay, Art hier.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade viel dagegen argumentiert, aber in der Tat,
ich kenne niemanden, der einen Reiskocher hat und nicht gleichzeitig liebt.
Das heißt also, es scheint ein Objekt zu sein.
Lieben ist jetzt übertrieben, aber.
Also das dann sehr, sehr schätzt. Es scheint also ein Objekt zu sein,
dass wenn man es dann mal hat, man merkt.
was einem gefehlt hat vorher. Von daher.
Also ich bin da sehr leidenschaftslos. Also ich bin der beste Gast,
den ihr euch heute aussuchen konntet, damit Ralf früh ins Bett kommt, weil ich koche nicht.
Ich esse gerne, aber ich koche nicht. Und deswegen werde ich bei vielen von
den Dingen wahrscheinlich...
Du kochst nicht. Was heißt das, du kochst nicht? Wie ernährst du dich denn?
Das frage ich mich und meine Mutter und viele andere Menschen auch.
Ach, du bist einer von diesen Lichtwesen.
Nein, Tim Pridloff hat mir mal eine Brotmaschine aufoktroyiert seitdem esse
ich Brot Es ist nur noch Brot,
Ich kann ja nicht schlafen und wecken dich wieder.
Wenn wir über die Brotpackmaschine.
Reden Naja, also ich sag mal, ich hab bestimmt Meinungen zu Sachen,
aber ich bin nicht besonders leidenschaftlich bei vielen von denen,
das erleichtert die Tierlist Haben wir denn eine Tierlist?
Wir haben immer noch keine Ich bin dran.
Aber Ich trage mal einen Wir können uns ja jetzt merken, was wir da mitnehmen. Ich sage jetzt mal A.
Ich gehe mit, was auch immer ihr sagt. Okay, ich habe es hingeschrieben.
Du musst auch eine Meinung haben. Die muss ja nicht informiert sein.
Viele Leute haben eine Meinung, die nicht informiert ist.
Je weniger informiert, desto mehr Meinung.
Ja, geh einfach nach deinem Bauch. Ja, genau.
Ich habe im Internet gehört, bei Leuten, denen ich vertraue,
es sei A. Deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung.
Okay.
Jetzt kommen wir doch langsam irgendwo hin.
Gib mal ein weiteres Gerät vor.
Okay, ich habe mal ein paar Sachen noch mitgebracht.
Was war es mitgebracht? Wie Sie hier sehen können.
Ich habe was mitgebracht. Aber Tim, du meinst, wir kriegen es noch hin?
Ich bin dran.
Weil ansonsten können wir es auch gerne in die nächste Sendung verschieben.
Erklär doch einfach mal, was du da jetzt hast.
Also, was habe ich jetzt hier? Ich habe ein Gerät, das habe ich noch gar nicht
so lange, ungefähr vier, fünf Jahre oder sowas. Und das ist im Prinzip...
Und eine runde Silikonform, die man noch etwas kompaktieren kann,
sodass es eher die Form eines Tellers hat.
Und dann kann man da so reindutschen. Ihr kennt das auch von Tupac Wear vielleicht.
Und dann hat man so ein Bowl letztendlich aus Silikon.
Eine Faltschüssel.
Eine Faltschüssel. Danke, Roddy. Genau, eine Faltschüssel aus Silikon.
Und das zweite Utensil, was dazu gehört, ist ein Silikondeckel,
der so lose in diese Falschüssel reinpasst und die oben abschließt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin auf der falschen Top-Aware-Party.
Ja, ich auch.
Aber gut.
Ihr wisst aber, was man hiermit zubereitet, wofür das gut ist.
Popcorn. Hier drin macht man Popcorn. Das heißt, es gibt hier so zwei kleine Messlinien.
Man füllt Popcorn-Mais rein und zwar eben jetzt nicht so den aus den irgendwie
Fertigpackungen, sondern den, den man wirklich so pur als Popcorn-Reis kaufen kann.
Mais, nicht Reis, aber ja.
Mais, ja genau, danke. Dann im Verhältnis ungefähr drei Esslöffel Wasser,
ein Esslöffel Zucker verrührt das Ganze mit dem Mais.
Zucker? Süßes Popcorn.
Boah.
Also gut, darüber diskutieren wir heute nicht. So, dann verrührst du das Ganze
ordentlich, dann packst du diesen Deckel oben drauf und stellst das Ganze in die Mikrowelle.
Und 600 Watt, vier Minuten, 20 Sekunden.
Und danach hast du fantastisches, frisch gepopptes Popcorn.
Da komme jetzt ich und sage, ich mache mein Popcorn immer im Topf.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Es gibt natürlich diverse andere Varianten,
wie man Popcorn machen kann.
Die professionellste Variante ist natürlich mit einer dezidierten Popcornmaschine.
In Klammern haben wir sogar auch eine im Keller.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch eine, die ich mal irgendwann erwischt.
habe bei so einem Schrottwichteln.
Das Popcorn, das schmeckt so ein bisschen nach Verpackungsmaterial,
wenn es rauskommt. Nämlich nach gar nichts.
Deswegen habe ich das Ding drei, vier Mal benutzt und seitdem wird es halt nicht mehr benutzt.
Ja, aber es ist ja ein bisschen eine Frage.
Naja, es ist halt so ein Heißluft-Dingsi. Da dreht sich das Popcorn.
Es sieht furchtbar witzig aus, aber es schmeckt hinterher nach genau gar nichts.
Aber es ist ein bisschen eine Frage der Würzung, oder? Also das könnte man ja...
Ja, selbst dann. Also normalerweise machst du ja Popcorn in irgendeiner Art von Öl oder Fett.
Und dadurch kriegt es ja dann eigentlich den Geschmack.
Kommt hier nicht rein. Das ist komplett fett- und ölfrei. Kommt vorbei,
probier es aus. Meine Kinder lieben es.
Das heißt also, das löst einfach ein Problem, weil im Topf ist es richtig asig,
auch in der Pfanne Popcorn zu machen, weil es brennt an und geht kaputt.
Und du musst ständig rumrühren.
Hier machst du halt gar nichts.
Was? Rühren? Ich rühre nicht.
Echt, du machst Popcorn in einem Topf ohne Rühren?
Warum soll ich denn da rühren?
Okay.
Ich dachte, es poppt einfach.
Ja.
Und es kostet vor allem nur 10 Euro. Und jetzt verstehe ich,
warum Ralf reingebracht hat, wie viel Platz Dinge verbrauchen.
Denn ein Silikonding, was du noch platt drücken kannst.
Verbraucht praktisch keinen Platz.
Keinen Platz, das ist richtig schlau.
Genau.
Okay, also ein dedizierter Popcorn-Maker ähm,
Diese Bauform, die überzeugt mich nicht.
Warum?
Und die Popcorn-Maschine, die ich habe, die überzeugt mich gleich dreimal nicht.
Aber es hat ja einen Grund, warum ich die geschrottwichtelt habe.
Aber also beschreib doch mal, wie du es im Topf machst. Das würde mich jetzt
wirklich interessieren. Ich habe das ein paar Mal probiert und es war immer
eine totale Katastrophe.
Gut, brauche ich schon mal nicht. Das heißt, meins ist gesünder. Weiter.
Ich brauche weder Öl noch Butter. Aber mach weiter.
Popcorn? Deckel Herd anmachen.
Und Zucker oder Salz nachträglich dann dran?
Nachträglich, ja.
Also bei mir karamellisiert es halt auch während des Poppens.
Ich mag ja kein süßes Popcorn.
Na gut.
Deswegen ja, oder man hat halt dieses indische Fertig-Popcorn,
also fertig im Prinzip, also du hast,
in so einem kleinen Päckchen hast du halt die ungepoppten Maiskörner zusammen
mit auch so einer Fett-Dings und es ist alles schwer gewürzt und dann packst
du es so, wie es ist, in den Topf und lässt es poppen. Und das ist schon super lecker.
Verstehe. Na gut. Okay.
Mich überzeugt das und ich habe eine Meinung. Die Meinung ist ein A.
Also das hängt halt sicher natürlich erstmal, das werden wir bei etlichen Teilen
merken, ein bisschen damit zusammen,
so wie gerne isst man denn eigentlich das, was da zubereitet wird.
Aber der Aufwand, was du eben gerade beim Reiskocher gesagt hast,
einfach Dinge irgendwo reinwerfen und wegstellen und das macht Pling und das ist fertig.
Das ist so vom Convenience-Faktor her schon.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Kinder wollen Popcorn haben zum Kino und vier Minuten später haben sie Popcorn
zum Kino. Also Home-Kino.
So, was macht denn jetzt hier unsere Tierlist?
Ah ja, jetzt geht sie wieder.
Nee, bei mir geht nicht die, also es ist nicht der gleiche Link.
Der neue Link geht aber auf jeden Fall.
Zum Gucken ist der, ne?
Ja.
Der zum Gucken geht bei mir auch.
Es gibt einen neuen Link, okay.
Also um die Frage, ich würde das Ding wahrscheinlich in C, maximal B tun.
Okay.
Gut, aber ich habe auch keine Mikrowelle. Also ich habe eine Mikrowelle,
aber nicht in der Küche, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Wie ist denn bei dir der Anteil nicht gepoppter Körner bei deinem Verfahren?
Das hängt sehr stark von dem Mais ab, den man einsetzt. Also es gibt halt Mais,
der popt besser und es gibt Mais, der popt weniger gut.
Ein bisschen nicht gepoppte Körner hat man immer, aber das ist so.
Ah ja, hier gibt es die...
Dann kriegt gleich Hunger.
Also worauf habt ihr euch jetzt geeinigt? Noch nicht. Ich kann Popcorn noch
nicht so richtig viel sagen.
Ich finde, das Gerät ist jetzt nicht unpraktisch, nimmt halt wenig Platz ein,
wenn man generell so eine Schublade hat mit all so komischen Silikon-Gemumpel.
Es ist halt nur die Frage, wie oft macht man das? Ich denke,
wenn man viel Popcorn macht, dann mag das ja durchaus praktisch sein.
Also ich würde mal solche Geräte generell so irgendwie in B oder so reinwerfen.
Ja, B ist okay, B oder C.
B würde ich mich drauf einlassen. Übrigens noch ein Detail, wir haben zwei davon,
um in Serienproduktion Popcorn herzustellen.
Das heißt, ich bin in der Lage, jetzt nächstes Wochenende unsere Kita-Gruppe
von 15 Kindern binnen ungefähr 30 Minuten Produktionszeit mit einer riesigen
Menge Popcorn zu versorgen.
Kinder wollt ihr Popcorn? Wie viel Popcorn wollt ihr? Ja.
Genau. Es ist nämlich immer zu wenig Popcorn da.
Nicht so, wenn ich eingeladen bin, weil mit zwei von denen, ja,
einen bereitest du vor, der andere ist in der Mikrowelle.
Das heißt also, du kannst wirklich am Stück alle vier Minuten ernten.
Na gut, na gut.
Also ich muss auch sagen, Tim meinte gerade, wenn man viel Popcorn braucht und
so weiter, ich finde gerade, wenn man nicht oft Popcorn braucht,
ist das die beste Lösung, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Man kann natürlich sagen, Topf hat man sowieso, aber wenn es schon irgendein Detektivität gibt.
Oder du kaufst halt gleich Mikrowellen-Popcorn. Das kannst du natürlich auch
machen. Wenn du das eh in die Mikrowelle tust, dann ist es ja egal.
Aber dann hast du halt, die Menge ist fix, die kannst du nicht verändern.
Hierbei kannst du halt die Menge variieren, wie viel du haben willst.
Du kannst einfach mal doppelt so viel machen.
Klar, du kannst auch zwei Tüten Mikrowellen-Popcorn hinter dir machen.
Aber es ist relational natürlich viel teurer im Vergleich zu.
Also du hast bei dem Ding wahrscheinlich potenziell die Möglichkeit,
mehr zu machen, wenn du es im Topf machst. du kannst ja nie so viel Mais reinmachen,
dass maximal der Boden bedeckt ist.
Wenn sich die Körner stapeln, dann funktioniert es natürlich nicht mehr.
Die müssen alle unten jetzt kriegen.
Also ich esse nie Popcorn quasi, obwohl ich Popcorn mag, aber esse ich quasi
nie und bin trotzdem begeistert.
Ich hätte ein A vorgeschlagen, einigt ihr euch auf B?
Tim, kannst du denn jetzt auch schieben?
Du müsstest eigentlich auch schieben können.
Wo hast du denn den Admin-Link? Hast du den auch schon irgendwo getylt?
Den müsstest du mal irgendwo überwerfen in unseren internen Geheim-Chat.
Okay. Den Use-Link meinst du jetzt?
Genau.
Okay. Der Use-Link ist unterwegs. Da.
Da. Da kommt was.
Mein Rechner ist noch blau.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Webseitentitel muss man haben. So, wir hatten Reiskocher, aber auf A...
Popcorn auf B.
Okay, Popcorn auf B.
Hier bitte auch den News-Link. Nix gibt's. Es gibt nur den View-Link.
So, ich sehe noch keinen Maiskocher oben.
Maiskocher. Du sagst immer...
Ja, Mais und Reis ist es schwierig. Aber jetzt haben wir die beiden ja schon mal weg.
Wir erfinden jetzt eine neue Kategorie, den Maiskocher.
So, wer will denn das nächste sich mal picken?
Ich hätte gerne einen Wunsch zu haben, nämlich einen Eierkocher.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin seit den 70er Jahren verliebt in den Reiskocher,
ist es Siemens oder Grundig, er ist orange, wahrscheinlich hatte jede Familie
ihn, er ist einfach genial konstruiert.
Du hast gerade Reiskocher gedacht.
Eierkocher, Eierkocher.
Nicht noch Reis mit Mais und Ei verwixeln.
Nein, ein Eierkocher. Ich sehe nämlich hier auf unserem Tierlist-Bild,
es gibt so ein modernes Ding, das schreckt mich natürlich massiv ab.
Ich habe den aus den 70er Jahren, aus der Kindheit, der noch funktioniert wie
eine Eins, viel zu laut brummt und Eier immer perfekt macht,
ohne irgendeinen Aufwand.
Und das finde ich, vor allem dieses, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei den Modernen
auch so ist, wie im Deckel, wenn man den Deckel abhebt, dann ist der Griff des
Deckels schon der Eierpikser, den man braucht.
Und wenn man ihn umdreht, dann ist innen auf dem Deckel so eine Markierung,
wie viel Wasser man da rein zu tun hat, angemessen an die Menge Eier, die man kochen will.
Also hat man vier Eier und hätte die gerne mittelhart, dann kann man halt genau,
dann sieht man da so eine Rille eingezeichnet und genau so halbschräg kippt man,
also man hält den Deckel schräg und hat so eine, wie Wasser halt aussieht in
einem schrägen Deckel, das ist die Form, die da so angezeichnet ist,
füllt nur so viel Wasser ein, kippt das in den Eierkocher, macht ihn an und
wenn er brummt, sind die Eier genau vier Stück mittelperfekt.
Ich hasse Eierkocher. Also meine Eltern hatten einen, wahrscheinlich so ziemlich
das Modell, was du gerade beschreibst.
Wir hatten allerdings so einen Messbecher, den man so in der Hand drehen musste,
um dann auf so einer XY-Matrix sich quasi zu erschließen, wie viele Eier kommen
rein und wie hart soll es sein.
Das heißt also, je nachdem, wie man ihn gedreht hat, war die Anzahl an Eiern
und nach oben ging es dann halt wie, oder nach unten der Härtegrad.
Völlig bescheuert. Das heißt also, man musste erstmal anfangen rumzurechnen
irgendwie und dann schlimmer Sound.
Zusammenrechnen oder was?
Schlimmer Sound, den das Ganze hat und das ist für mich der Prototyp von verschwendet
Platz für eine Sache, die du echt genauso gut in jedem Kochtopf hinbekommst.
Und da ist es auch mal egal, wie viel Wasser drin ist.
Einfach nein. Also sowohl Zeit als auch wie die Eier werden,
als auch ich verstehe voll deinen Schmerz mit diesem Messbecher-Dings.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich, ich habe jetzt mal einen Link hier reingeworfen,
das ist der Siemens-Eierkocher, von dem ich spreche.
und der ist halt auf eine bestimmte Art gemacht.
Guckt euch mal das erste Bild an. Das hier ist auch ein altes Modell,
da fehlen jetzt, also da sieht man jetzt eine Sache nicht. Ihr seht den Eierkocher vor euch.
Geiles Industriedesign, muss ich leider sagen.
Absolut geil. Ich bin völlig biased.
Das ist ja schon fast, das ist ja schon braun mäßig.
Genau. Das ist der Style.
Total 70er Jahre Retro Look, allein diese Farben.
Wahnsinn.
Und deswegen nur über meine Leiche wird dieser Eierkocher jemals abgegeben.
Aber deswegen achtet man drauf, oben sieht man hier der Griff oben am Deckel.
Ja, sieht hier aus wie so eine Röhre, weil da fehlt etwas. Da oben muss ein
oranger Stöpsel rein und dieser orange Stöpsel ist der Piekser für,
dass man ins Ei reinpiksen kann.
Der ist da integriert. Außerdem wird das Ding natürlich super heiß,
aber wenn man oben am Griff das anhebt, hat man nie Probleme mit Hitze an den
Fingern. Das hat ja frisch Wasser gekocht.
Was ihr auch erkennen könnt, wenn ihr jetzt mal ranzoomt an den Deckel,
dann seht ihr, dass dieser braune Deckel so Rillen zu haben scheint.
Das sind keine Bruchkanten, sondern das sind diese Wassermengen-Markierungen, die ich meine.
Wenn ihr den Deckel abhebt, seht ihr auf dem zweiten Bild, da sieht man die
Rillen auch noch besser. Könnt ihr das erkennen?
Und da seht ihr auch, dass an den Rillen so Zahlen stehen. Und es gibt in dem
Deckel dreimal diese Rillen, nämlich einmal für weich, mittel und hart und dann die Menge der Eier.
Und das ist wirklich nur die Wassermenge, die man braucht, damit die entsprechende
Menge Eier genau perfekt werden.
Wie kriegst du das Wasser denn da jetzt rein? Du musst dann doch das Wasser,
weil du das Teil selber kannst du nicht irgendwie zum Wasserhahn bringen.
Das heißt, du brauchst schon wieder noch ein Gerät.
Um das Wasser dahin zu befördern. Der Deckel ist der Messbecher.
Du nimmst den Deckel ab, machst den Wassern an, machst so viel Wasser,
wie du brauchst und machst den Deckel sozusagen, kippst das Wasser rein, setzt den Deckel auf.
Es ist wirklich, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, sorry Apple, aber das ist Peak-Ingenieurs-Kunst.
Das ist besser als ein M-Prozessor, das ist unglaublich.
Ich liebe Geräte, die wirklich auch so eine eingebaute Automatik haben und die
man eigentlich fast gar nicht so richtig falsch bedienen kann.
Ganz toll. Dieses Gerät müsste eigentlich eine eigene Kategorie haben.
Oder ein eigenes Objekt sein sozusagen. Also es gibt Eierkocher und es gibt Malix Eierkocher.
Ich finde die Beschreibung dabei, Etsy, auch sehr schön.
Siemens Eierkocher, Vintage Orange, 1970er Space Age Design,
Mid-Sentry, modern, Tulpenfuß, Retro-Küchengerät.
Da ist alles drin. Da ist alles drin.
Was ich jetzt gerne wüsste.
Ein tumpenfuß Retro-Küchengerät.
Ich habe nie einen anderen Eierkocher gesehen oder benutzt als diesen.
Deswegen, es gibt wahrscheinlich auch Beschissene.
Aber wo diese Deckelrillen-Funktionalität so überhaupt nicht gegeben ist,
so wie Ralf gerade meinte.
Wahrscheinlich ist die ganze Welt draußen voll ein schlechter Eierkocher.
Das heißt, du bist auf der Suche nach diesem bescheuerten Messbecher irgendwie.
Ja, also ich muss da jetzt mal was...
Dieses Ding ist 40 Jahre im Familienbesitz, ist noch da.
Ich muss da jetzt mal was wenig Sachliniges zu sagen, ich koche Eier selten,
sondern ich mache meistens Rührei.
Ja, okay, also was sagen wir Eierkocher?
Also ich kann nachvollziehen, dass dieses spezielle Modell so seine Vorzüge
hat, aber in Bezug auf so, was man auf denselben Platz noch alles stellen könnte
oder muss in einer Küche.
Wir können das ja alles noch korrigieren, das sagen wir natürlich immer und
tun es dann nicht, weil du dann zu müde bist am Schluss und wir das dann nicht
mehr machen, obwohl das eigentlich zu jeder ordnungsgemäßen Tierlist-Prozedur
dazugehört, dass man am Schluss nochmal korrigiert.
Ja, dann verhindert man auch solche Kommentare, wie wir sie jetzt bekommen haben
nach der letzten Sendung.
Also ich würde hier keinesfalls über C gehen.
Ein Eierkocher? Ja. Also ich meine C.
Das ist ein Prototyp von überflüssig.
Also wenn der Eierkocher auf C landet, dann ist aber seine Popcornschüssel auch
auf C, weil dann ist das einfach so der Durchschnitt.
Ja, aber ich würde den Eierkocher ein Stück weiter oben einsortieren,
weil der Eierkocher einfach mal funktioniert.
Es ist genau so ein Klassiker wie Reiskocher.
Er ist auch eigentlich so ein Gerät wie ein Reiskocher. Du bereitest alles vor, schaltest ein.
Es ist ein zusätzliches Gerät.
Und hast Minuten später zusätzlich Strom.
Es braucht keinen zusätzlichen Strom. Wenn du Eier kochen willst,
brauchst du immer den gleichen Strom.
Strom ist immer zu wenig da in der Küche. Das heißt, wenn ihr so weitermacht.
Habt ihr hinterher.
Das Problem ist ein bisschen anderes. Ihr habt hinterher sechs Elektrogeräte
auf eurer Küchenfläche.
Kein Platz mehr für das viel wichtigere Schneidbrett, zu dem wir noch kommen
werden. Weil das schlussendlich alles voll mit euren Eierkochern.
Und ständig müsst ihr noch in den Steckdosen hin und her switchen.
Du bist aber informiert, dass die Mehrfachsteckdose durchaus schon erfunden ist.
In der Küche kritisch.
Ralf, wie viele Leute essen zum Frühstück gekochte,
Eier. Wie viel Prozent aller Menschen, die überhaupt Eier essen, essen sie gekocht?
Ich würde sagen, beide Zahlen sind ziemlich hoch.
Ich würde aber sagen, die Leute machen wirklich eher Rühreie nowadays.
Denk doch an die Leute, die nicht kochen.
Nur im Prenzler und Berg. Guck mal, er da, den Rühreiei, da ist er doch total
überfordert, dass er überhaupt Eier kocht, finde ich ja schon bemerkenswert.
Da muss ich dann nur noch mal ein Schülspinat machen und schon halt ein komplettes Abendessen.
Das muss man mal bedenken. Ein Eierkocher ist schon klassisch,
weil einfach Eierkochen an sich klassisch ist.
Also ich verlange ein A, wenn der Reiskocher auf A ist.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Ich kann von dem S hier nur deswegen absehen, weil es noch andere Eierkocher
gibt als meinen, aber gäbe es nur die.
Ihr werdet sehen, was ihr davon habt, weil nichts davon in eure Küche passt.
Und dann müsst ihr nämlich die harten Entscheidungen treffen.
Geil. Nicht kochen hat auch noch einen Vorteil. Ich habe Steckdosen frei in der Küche.
Aber ich habe gar keine.
Ja, daher schweigen. Okay.
Ja, ich habe auch Steckdosen frei in der Küche, aber der Vorbesitzer hat auch
sehr viele Steckdosen vorgesehen und ich bin ihm dankbar.
Gut.
Seidor.
Was haben wir noch?
Wir können ja mal wenig Kontroverse also ich hoffe, sie sind Wir können ja sowas
nehmen, wo alle direkt so, ja.
Famous last words.
Keine Ahnung. Okay, ja gut. Ich ziehe die Aussage zurück.
Ja, mach hin. Zieh was.
Ich mache mal was, was wahrscheinlich wenig Kontroverse relativ weit unten landet.
Und zwar das Spaghetti-Maß.
Ich wusste nicht, was es ist.
Genau, ich habe das gesehen und habe Fragen. Also wir können ja erstmal beschreiben,
weil es ist glaube ich nicht so landläufig. Es ist ein Stück Metall,
was eine etwas schmalere und eine etwas längere Seite hat.
Und in dieser Metallplatte sind Löcher gestanzt, die groß sind.
Und der Gedanke ist, dass man in diese Löcher jeweils die Spaghetti-Nudeln reinsteckt.
Und dann weiß man, wie viel eine Portion ist, zwei Portionen, drei Portionen.
Nimmt nicht viel Platz weg, das schon, aber ich habe Fragen.
Also erstens funktioniert das halt irgendwie nachweislich nur für Spaghetti-Nudeln.
Vielleicht noch Macaroni, wobei da wäre ich mir schon nicht so sicher,
ob das dann irgendwie noch so...
Macaroni eher nicht, aber so breitere Nudeln vielleicht.
Vielleicht noch so gerade eben. Dann okay, eine Portion für wen?
Wie viel Appetit haben die Leute?
Und vor allem das Hauptproblem bei Nudeln und Abmessen von Nudeln ist,
was machst du denn dann halt mit dem Rest?
Also ist das zum Beispiel jetzt so geeicht, dass du eine Standard 500 Gramm
Packung genau in einem Bruchteil davon quasi abgemessen bekommst oder hast du
am Ende immer nochmal 10 Prozent,
die nie irgendwo reinpassen und dann vergammeln sie im Schrank und alles ist schrecklich.
Lass mich erklären, ich habe das eigentlich nur da reingetan, damit wir was in F haben.
Oder kommt noch was?
Weil das meiner Meinung nach eins der sinnlosesten Dinge ist,
die man für die Küche anschaffen kann.
Besonders, weil man in der Küche normalerweise immer eine Waage hat und man
kann auch Spaghetti ganz normal einfach auswiegen und fertig.
Vor allem ist es ja nicht, man hat es ja dann nicht zur Hand,
wenn man es wirklich braucht und es funktioniert auch nur mit Spaghetti und
mit keiner anderen Nudeln.
Es gibt auch Spaghetti in verschiedenen dicken und wahrscheinlich auch in verschiedenen
Zutaten mit unterschiedlichen Durchmessern und also ich weiß nicht.
Weg damit.
Also wer das nicht hinkriegt, also braucht auch gar keine Spaghetti zu essen.
Da gibt es einfach nichts.
Vor allen Dingen kleiner Trick zum Spaghetti abmessen oder abwiegen.
Ein Glas auf die Waage stellen, nullen und dann die Spaghetti reinstellen.
Ja.
Eigentlich auch.
Womit wir vielleicht bei unserem nächsten...
Womit wir vor allem bei dem Problem sind, dass ja die meisten Rezepte keine
ordentlichen Maße angeben, an denen man überhaupt agieren kann.
Wenn man mal alles mal messen könnte, dann wäre ja schon eine Menge los.
Aber immer diese Rezepte mit ihren Esslöffeln...
Ja, oder etwas, das finde ich immer geil. Etwas Salz.
Wie soll ich als Nerd mit so einer Information klarkommen? Etwas Salz.
Deswegen koche ich nicht.
Genau. Siehst du mal, da werden Leute komplett abgehängt aus der Gesellschaft mit solchen Sachen.
Aber das führt ja vielleicht zu unserem nächsten Gerät, wo wir glaube ich wahrscheinlich
wirklich sehr schnell fertig und einig sind.
Ah, da träumst du ja von uns.
Die gute alte Küchenwaage.
Damit die da tatsächlich drin?
Mit Nüller-Funktion.
Ja.
So, ich bin halt Team Kochen. Meine Frau ist Team Backen. Ich brauche die sehr,
sehr viel signifikant weniger als Claudia.
Die hat die also ständig im Einsatz, weil Backen, da muss es ja schon mehr oder
weniger aufs Gramm stimmen.
Man sagt ja, Kochen ist Physik, Backen ist Chemie.
In der Chemie, da muss man die Mengen, die müssen halt passen, sonst passt es nicht.
Also ich glaube, Küchenwaage ist einfach ein in sich perfektes Objekt.
Und das Killer Feature ist halt diese Nuller-Funktion, die es ja auch schon
im vordigitalen Zeitalter gab.
Da hatten wir dann so Drehmaß.
Dreh so oder Dreh so oder ja, ja, null.
Man konnte das also dann eben auch trotzdem nullen und du kannst also egal in
einen einzigen Topf draufsetzen, nullen, erst Mehl rein, wieder nullen, Milch dazu, nullen.
Es ist also einfach ein in sich völlig perfektes Objekt und es braucht noch nichtmals viel Platz.
Das ist also für mich ein klarer Kandidat für S.
Ja, ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe auch eine Küchenwaage, also ich habe auch
eine Feinwaage irgendwann gekauft, die tatsächlich auf zwei Nachkommastellen
Gramm messen kann, weil mich dieses,
wie viel Salz ist ein Esslöffel oder ein Teelöffel oder wie auch immer.
Wahnsinnig gemacht hat.
Mich wahnsinnig gemacht hat. Und wenn man einfach mal 2,5 Gramm Salz abmessen will,
Dann braucht man eine Waage, die das kann. Und bei bestimmten Rezepten will
man das halt dann auch richtig haben.
Also gerade ein Hefeteig, wenn da der Salzgehalt nicht stimmt,
dann ist er entweder versalzen oder schmeckt halt wie, als würde man einen Pappedeckel reinbeißen.
Und wenn man, wie ich, Drogen an Schulkinder verkauft, da geht auch kein halbes Gramm Koks zu viel.
Also ganz klar, esst ja alles Geld. Ganz klar Esstier, eine Küchenwaage.
Also man kann eine Küche ohne eine Küchenwaage nicht betreiben,
auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt an dieser Stelle nochmal Protest einlegen muss
gegen den Titel dieser Tierlist, weil definitiv ist eine Küchenwaage kein Single
Purpose, sondern es ist the real purpose.
Es ist einfach, verstehst du, it's all about weight.
Ja, aber es hat nur ein Feature. Also es kann nur messen.
Es tut eine Dinge, aber es tut es nicht nur, um ein einziges Ziel zu erreichen,
sondern es geht ja nicht um die Funktion, sondern es geht ja um den Purpose.
Wir reden ja nicht über Single-Function-Kitchen-Accessories,
sondern Single-Purpose.
Und das ist genau das, wo dieser mentale Split bei mir ist und alles rumort und klopft von innen.
Und das ist zwar Single-Function, aber Multi-Purpose.
Ja, okay.
Sagen wir mal so, im Gegensatz dazu haben wir zwei Schneider hier,
die noch nicht in den Tiers sind.
Das eine ist ein Ananasschneider und das andere ist ein Eierschneider.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass man sie jeweils für das andere verwenden kann.
Das wäre mal interessant zu versuchen.
Aber…,
Genau, das ist nämlich der Punkt. Und wir haben nämlich beides hier sozusagen
drin. Single Purpose und Single Function.
Und da beeißt es sich. Also du kannst natürlich jetzt nochmal zusehen,
wie du das wieder gekittet bekommst, Ralf.
Und du merkst jetzt auch schon, wo das Problem ist.
Naja.
Ja, naja, was hat denn hier naja?
Also wir haben den Einwand wahrgenommen.
Als Programmierer brauchst du so erst gar nicht anfangen. Da ist die Datenbank danach im Arsch.
Was sagt denn da die KI zu?
Ja, ich wollte auch gerade sagen. Das Problem ist noch gelöst.
So, nächstes.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht zu den gerade schon entnannten Schneidern.
Bei den Eiern waren wir ja schon.
Also das Ei ist gekocht in unserem A-Tier Eierkocher von Siemens aus den 70ern.
Ja, aber dann ist es meistens weich, dann würde ich es nicht in ein Eier schneiden.
Nein, das kannst du ja genau auswählen. Im Deckel guckst du ja vorher auf das Weichmittel oder hart.
Kannst du auch harte Eier damit machen. Aber in der Tat ist auch noch so ein
Punkt gegen den Eierkocher.
Wenn man wie ich eigentlich nur harte Eier kocht, ist das mal gleich nur noch.
Aber egal, wir werden sehen, wo das hinführt.
So, jetzt haben wir also ein hart gekochtes Ei, brauchen wir jetzt einen Eierschneider.
Auch das ist ein Trollbeitrag meinerseits.
Hast du einen Eierschneider?
Ich glaube nicht.
Okay, das heißt also, du bist kein Freund des Schinkeneibrotes zum Beispiel.
Das ist mit Remoulade drunter.
Ich bin ein Freund des Schinkeneibrotes, nur halt nicht mit hartgekochten Eiern.
Sondern?
Mit Rührei.
Ah, okay. Ja, gut. Tim, hast du einen Eierschneider?
Nein, aber ich hatte mal welche. Du meinst diese harfenartigen Schneider.
Genau.
Also ich finde die eigentlich ganz geil, muss ich sagen, gerade wenn man halt
mit gekochten Eiern arbeitet und vor allem,
also mit harten Eiern und wenn man sowieso schon diesen super geilen Space Age
Orange Retro Futuristischen Eierkocher hat,
ja, dann gibt das ja sozusagen gleich den Staffelstab weiter,
weil du dann halt ein Eibrot machst, wo nicht die Eier sofort wieder runterkullern,
zumindest nicht so einfach.
und ein Eibrot ist auch generell nicht zu verachten, ist auch sehr verbreitet
wenn du mal so guckst, was du heutzutage so an belegten Broten so kaufst,
da ist das Eibrot auch immer ganz weit vorne und ich würde auch sagen zu Recht,
von daher ist es auf jeden Fall kein F-Tier.
Ja würde ich auch sagen es hat natürlich.
Die klassischen Single Purpose Problematiken, aber und hier kommen wir wieder
auf ein weiteres Problem deines Ansatzes dieser Tierlist.
Warum ist das überhaupt mein Ansatz?
Ist Single Purpose an sich schlecht oder wenn man jetzt sozusagen,
also ein Eierschneider ist zwar Single Purpose und man könnte sagen,
es ist schlecht, weil es Single Purpose ist, aber wenn man Single Purpose an
sich betrachtet, kann man ja sagen, es gibt auch guten Single Purpose.
Ja, natürlich.
Schlechten Single Purpose und das ist halt für mich eher ein guter Single Purpose,
von daher würde ich sagen, C oder B.
Also darum habe ich ja diese Formel am Anfang eingeführt.
Ja.
Da ist halt so etwas...
Was ich halt häufig brauche, das kann dann auch sehr Single-Purpose sein.
Dieser Purpose ist einfach sehr häufig gegeben.
Malik, wie ist das denn mit dir? Du hast ja deinen Eierkocher und schneidest
du deine Eier dann auch mit so einem Eierschneider.
Also ich muss zugeben, dass ich meinen Eierschneider, den ich Jahrzehnte besessen
habe, einfach auf der Straße ausgesetzt habe. Das macht man hier so im Westen.
Du hast ihn ausgewildert.
Zeichen XY.
Macht man das in Berlin auch? Man stellt so einen Karton, schreibt rein.
Ja, also bei uns im Prenzlauer Bergheim.
Ja, klar. Ich brauche ja immer alles nur bei der Meta-Ebene draußen auf die
Ablage zu legen und zehn Minuten später ist das verwertet.
Irgendwo habe ich neulich so ein Bild gesehen, da hatte jemand auch so einen
Karton, der stand auf so einer Wiese, stand dann dabei zu verschenken und unter
dem Bild stand, ich hätte vielleicht hinschreiben sollen, nicht den Tisch.
Also deswegen, ich habe so etwas besessen. Ich esse auch sehr gerne Brot mit Ei.
Und trotzdem, es gibt den Hauptgrund, warum ich nicht koche,
ist, weil danach so viel Zeug schmutzig ist, was man wieder reinigen muss.
Und das ist der klassische Fall von, da mache ich einen Schnitt, Der ist zwar toll,
dann ist das Ei wunderbar zu schneiden, aber das Messer liegt sowieso noch von
eben schmutzig da rum, weil ich den Salat geschnitten habe oder so und dann
schneide ich da halt dreimal in das Ei rein und das geht dann auch.
Das hier ist eleganter, aber Kosten und Nutzen stehen für mich in keiner Relation.
So, da bin ich absolut bei Malik. Das Saubermachen von Eierschneidern ist nämlich ein doofer Scheiß.
Dafür gibt es aber Geschirrspüler. Ja.
Sind die Single-Purpose?
Nein, die sind auch nicht in der Liste.
Also immer wubbelt da noch halt irgendwie von dem Eigelb noch drin rum.
Also ich würde mich da auch nicht über ein C bewegen.
Also ich würde so einen Eierschneider erst dann einsetzen, wenn ich mindestens
zehn Eier schneiden möchte.
Darunter würde ich das dann auch nicht tun, weil das ist so.
Gut, also D oder C? Ist das hier so?
Also nicht unter C.
Dann nehmen wir C.
Nicht über C.
Also hier, Munkelchen hat wieder ein schön Video hier gepostet,
wo man sieht, dass man mit dem Eierschneider auch Musik machen kann.
Also das ist definitiv etwas.
Bisschen Horrormusik.
Naja, also man könnte die schon...
Das ist aber schlecht gestimmt.
Es ist nicht ACDC. Das wäre doch mal ein Produkt, wenn du sozusagen den Eierschneider
mehr so als Harfe auslegst, dass er also sowohl schneidet, ja,
aber auch noch zum Musikspielen gedacht ist.
Bitte bring Markus Richter nicht auf irgendwelche Ideen.
Kennt ihr eine Spaghetti-Harfe?
Nee.
Das ist wie ein Eierschneider, nur in groß, mit noch mehr Drähten,
wo du dann einen Nudelteig ausrollst und ihn dann durch die Drähte quasi durchdrückst
und hast unten dann Spaghetti.
die dann in den Topf kommen.
Mach mal Reload bei deiner Tierlist.
Beziehungsweise Spaghetti-Gitarre wird sie auch genannt.
Ja, geht. Und?
Na, zeig mal auch dein Objekt. Ich hatte auch gerade das Internet.
Oh, ah, okay. Könnte noch mehr zoomen, aber ja.
Noch mehr?
Oh ja.
Ja.
Aber jetzt fehlen die Titel, ohne dass man zoomt.
Stimmt.
Das stimmt. Zur Laufzeit wird hier noch, okay.
Na klar, du wolltest Features haben, sonst komme ich ja nicht dazu.
Das ist das Fertigkriegen, bevor das jetzt komplett fällt.
Wollen wir den Ananasschneider hinterherdingsen? Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es sowas gibt. Erklär mir doch mal.
Also der Ananasschneider. Eine Ananas ist mit einem Messer ziemlich kompliziert zu schneiden.
Das hat schon so manche Herausforderungen.
Instagram sagt nein, aber ja.
So und dieser Ananasschneider funktioniert so, du kappst das obere Ende der
Ananas, wo also der Strunk ist, ab und unten den Boden und dann setzt du diesen
Schneider oben an und drehst ihn einfach in die Ananas rein.
Wie ein Korkenzieher.
Wie ein Korkenzieher, genau. Und wenn du unten angekommen bist,
du machst also überhaupt keine andere komplexe Bewegung, sondern drehst die ganze Zeit nur.
Und der fräst sich halt mit seiner Schneide in die Ananas und dann ziehst du
am Ende quasi das komplette essbare Innere der Ananas raus.
Der harte Strunk in der Mitte verschwindet im Ananasschneider selber.
Das heißt, aus denen hast du auch drin.
Und dann hast du eigentlich eine große Schlangenform vor dir,
wie du sie in Ananasscheiben halt kennst. Das heißt also, du hast eigentlich
perfekte Ananasscheiben.
Und dann machst du mit einem normalen Messer einen Schnitt irgendwo an der Seite.
Und dann hast du vor dir perfekt geschnitten zehn Ananasscheiben.
Oder du machst halt irgendwie acht Schnitte rein und dann hast du kleingestückelte Ananas vor dir.
Weil du halt einfach diesen Turm auch bearbeitest und schneidest.
Also ein Ralf ist auf jeden Fall so ein Verkäufer aus der Fußgängerzone, aus den 90er-Fraktion.
Jederzeit.
Ich bin wieder vollkommen überzeugt. Ich habe noch nie der Ananas geschnitten.
Ich kaufe sofort dieses Ding. Ich muss jetzt Ananas essen.
Ich gucke mal, ob das jetzt schon so weit, wenn man es noch nicht in Aktion
gesehen hat, also YouTube wird da helfen.
Ich suche mal einfach irgendein beliebiges Video dazu raus.
Ich glaube, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Lass uns mal...
Ist sexy und verbraucht keinen Platz. Ist wahrscheinlich auch noch billig.
Also es passt halt in eine Schublade noch rein.
Aber ich meine mal ehrlich, wie viel Ananas isst denn du?
Jetzt meine Freundin nicht. Die isst täglich.
Ananas?
Ja.
Wirklich?
Und das ist halt auch eine Kategorie von, wenn man Kinder hat,
braucht man es plötzlich. So, das kommt noch ein paar Mal bei mir.
Genauso wie Popcorn. So, hätten wir vorher einfach nie gebraucht.
Wenn du Kinder hast, sind das plötzlich Sachen, die dein Leben einfacher und eleganter machen.
Und diese Konstruktion ist einfach physikalisch fantastisch.
Die sind alle ähnlich aufgebaut, verschiedene Hersteller.
Du kannst dann diesen Anlassschneider noch in zwei Teile auseinanderbauen,
damit du nämlich auch den Strunk wieder rauskriegst, weil er durchaus da fest
drin ist. Es ist gut zu reinigen, das Ganze.
Und ja, tut halt einfach, was es verspricht. Genau, wir gucken jetzt gerade
das Video, wie man dann noch den Dingens abmacht.
Wie man hier sieht.
Wie man hier sieht, genau.
Es ist einfach ein Korkenzieher für Ananas, das ist perfekt.
Ja, mit Kernbohrung halt, ne?
Ja.
So, und wenn man das halt vergleicht mit dem Aufwand, Ananas mit einem klassischen
Messer zu schneiden, das ist schon echt...
Wie viel bleibt sozusagen noch nutzbarer Ananas in dem Ding zurück.
Nicht viel.
Weil die Ananas ist ja eigentlich eher...
Und jetzt sieht man nämlich hier auch, wie er durchschneidet und wie du dann...
Jetzt sieht man das hier, wie man durchschneidet.
Ja, ich habe es ja vorhin ausführlich beschrieben und das war es auch im Video nochmal zu sehen.
Ah, okay. Gut.
Also?
C.
Ja, C fände ich da angemessen. Also braucht es nicht häufig,
aber es ist ein in sich super genial konstruiertes Teil.
Okay, ist toll, aber weil es nicht so populär ist, landet es in C?
Ja.
Also ich hätte B genommen, weil wenn die Popcornschale wegen Erfindungsreichtum
da landete, finde ich, dass der Ananasschneider das auch.
Würde ich ja auch fast sagen.
Das stimmt, das ist ein gutes Argument.
Okay.
Ja.
Hat auch die richtige Farbe, sagt der Designer.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nochmal über dem Eierschneider.
Ich empfehle eine Fassung aus Edelstahl. Das hat vielleicht noch ein schönes Objekt in der Hand.
Hier kommt wieder ein schöner Internetkommentar hier irgendwie, das kennt ihr da.
Was denn?
Das ist die Long Version sozusagen sogar.
Ja, es ist jetzt glaube ich nicht so unterhaltsam ohne das Video und auch mit Video.
Ach,
das kenne ich.
Das ist was für Postshow, oder? Pineapple Pan Apple.
Pan Pineapple Pan Pan.
Pineapple, Apple Pan.
Das kennst du nicht? Klassiker.
Oh mein.
Okay, gut.
Ich kann jetzt übrigens hier nichts verschieben in der neuen Fassung.
Was?
Kannst du noch was verschieben?
Kann ich noch was verschieben?
Ah, okay. Vielleicht hattest du jetzt auch den falschen... Hatte links sich
jetzt nochmal geändert?
Nö.
Okay.
Gut. B sagt man.
Na. Schick's auf B.
Den, äh...
Ja.
Kann ich was reinwerfen, wo ich auch denke, wo ich ahne, es sei nicht kontrovers
und wahrscheinlich falsch liege.
Honiglöffel, für mich ein direkter F.
Ja.
Einfach überhaupt, das muss ich mal sagen, also jetzt trete ich wahrscheinlich
der halben Bevölkerung auf die Füße, aber Leute, wo man zu Besuch kam als Kind
und die hatten so Löffel in den Marmeladendingern, anstatt dass man da einfach
mit dem Messer rein durfte. Das hat mich immer schon abgefuckt.
Das ist so, hätte man damals entfreunden können, hätte ich es gemacht,
aber man war ja real world befreundet, dann geht das nicht.
Honiglöffel klingt für mich wie das in Schlimmen, weil es auch noch nur noch
für Honig geht. Löffel gehen wenigstens überall.
Also der Honiglöffel hat immerhin den Vorteil, dass man damit relativ tropfenfrei
den Honig tatsächlich dahin befördern kann, wo man ihn hinhaben will.
Aber das hilft nichts. Ich denke, er darf trotzdem bei F sein.
Also der Honiglöffel, den wir jetzt hier abgebildet haben, ist dieser runde,
gedrechselte Holz-Honiglöffel.
Es gibt ja auch noch das klassische Besteckprodukt Honiglöffel.
das ist ein bisschen anders.
Das ist nämlich so gedacht, dass es eigentlich ein normaler Löffel ist.
Achso, und dann kann man ihn so über den Honig hängen.
Genau, da ist nämlich der Stiel nochmal einmal so eine S-Curve und dann kann
man an den Rand des Honigglases ranhängen mit der Annahme, dass es dann in den
Honig reintropft, also in den Honigtopf zurücktropft.
Das funktioniert aber auch vor allem dann nicht, wenn der Honigtopf noch relativ gut gefüllt ist.
Und wenn man keine Kinder hat.
Das versifft doch trotzdem alles.
Ja, also Honig ist generell ein Problem. Eigentlich ist so, diese Tubenverpackungen
sind schon der beste Beitrag.
Oder nach dem Frühstück Honig wieder zuschrauben und erstmal abkärchern.
Also F.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein F.
Gut.
Eindeutig.
Das geht voll schnell hier alles.
Abwarten. Was denn mit dem Dekantierer?
Ich trinke ja keinen Alkohol.
Der Dekantierer, den rufst du auf. Den habe ich zum Schluss nochmal reingegeben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Ding, was wenige Leute kennen.
Oder zu wenige Leute, sagen wir mal so. Obwohl es auch schon seit 20 Jahren,
glaube ich, auf dem Markt ist.
Oh nein, überzeugt mich bitte nicht.
Das löst folgendes Problem. Rotwein muss belüftet werden.
Damit die Bitterstoffe ein bisschen rauskommen. Ich hatte irgendwo nochmal eine
Definition gelesen, was da chemisch genau funktioniert. Das erspare ich uns jetzt allen.
Also darum füllt man anders als Weißwein, Rotwein in sogenannte Dekantillierer.
Das sind dann so große Karaffen mit großer Oberfläche innen drin,
dass viel Luft rankommt.
Und ich habe schon wieder irgendwie ein bescheuertes Teil, was riesig viel Platz
weg braucht und ich nachher richtig aufwendig irgendwie sauber machen muss.
Oder ich schütze halt den Wein ins Glas und darf dann aber irgendwie 10 Minuten
oder 20 Minuten nicht trinken. Alles scheiße.
So, das ist ein gelöstes Problem. Dank Dekantierer aufsetzen,
wo der Rotwein, das ist ein quasi Ausschütter, der oben auf die Rotweinflasche geplöppt wird.
Das ist also auch mit so einer Gummischicht, je nachdem, also die Flaschen sind
ja nicht alle gleich breit.
Weinkorken haben ja auch eine standardisierte Größe, trotzdem der passt einfach
immer und auch fest und fällt nicht raus.
Und dann schüttet man damit den Rotwein aus und durch eine besonders clevere
Konstruktion wird der Rotwein beim Ausschütten verwirbelt.
Oh, ein Wasserwirbel.
Genau, das heißt also, und durch diese Verwirbelung, weil an der Seite noch
Luftlöcher sind, wird quasi der Wein beim Ausschütten aus der Flasche gleich
belüftet und man kann ihn direkt trinken.
So und das hört sich erstmal an wie so Fuh und naja, ob das wohl funktioniert.
Ich habe vor langer, langer Zeit in Göttingen mal mit einem echten Weinkonnoisseur
zusammen in der WG gewohnt.
Der hatte also keinen Wein getrunken unter 30 Mark damals, Euro war das noch nicht.
Also damals echt auch viel Geld.
Und wir haben dann wirklich mal eine ziemlich professionelle Testreihe aufgemacht, Wo wir also drei,
vier identische Weine einfach genommen haben und er hat mal einen klassisch
kantilieren lassen und wir haben dann quasi im, ich glaube zwei Minuten Takt
geguckt, immer wieder mal ausgeschüttet,
wie schmeckt der jetzt und auf wie viel quasi Belüftungszeit kommt denn jetzt
hier diese Konstruktion.
Und die landete bei ungefähr 25 Minuten.
Das heißt also, der Wein schmeckte dann so, als hätte man ihn 25 Minuten in
einem klassischen Kantillierer stehen lassen. Von daher...
Kantierer.
Dekantierer.
Dekanter.
So, und seitdem, das Produkt, was du da gerade zeigst, ist ein anderes.
Für das kann ich jetzt hier nicht bürgen.
Achso, ja.
Sondern ich habe also wirklich genau...
Wie man hier sieht, das weiß auch keiner. Also Dekantierer ist jetzt eigentlich,
also ist es jetzt das Teil, womit man den Rotwein ausschüttet oder wo er dann drin steht?
Nee, das mit dem Drinstehen ist einfach scheiße. Weil das braucht Platz und
ist schlecht zu reinigen und ist quasi so...
Nein, das ist der Verwirbler.
Richtig ätzend.
Für den informierten Rotwein.
Du willst den Verwirbler haben.
Informierte Rotwein ist gut.
Da sieht man schon, diese Löcher sind nämlich auch nicht symmetrisch angeordnet,
sondern halt auch in so einer leichten Spiralform.
Also das Ding funktioniert.
Unglaublich.
Wer regelmäßig Rotwein trinkt und den noch nicht kennt, kostet irgendwie sieben Euro.
Gibt es von diversen Anbietern, mehr oder weniger alle baugleich.
das ist wirklich heißer Shit.
Na dann, sag mal Buchstaben.
Also ich würde den auch irgendwo so bei diesen cleveren Erfindungen bei B einsortieren.
Es ist Alkohol, Weißwein braucht es nicht, es ist natürlich winzig,
das heißt es hat null Platzbedarf, es ist recht gut zu reinigen,
einmal unter Wasser halten, dann ist es auch wieder sauber.
Also von der Wirkung her, mit dem, und das ist, sagen wir mal,
alternativlos in Bezug auf das, was es an Zeitersparnis hat.
Das heißt, mir ist kein anderes Verfahren bekannt, was mit so viel Eleganz dieses Problem löst.
Das mit dem gut reinigen, das will ich mal in Zweifel ziehen,
wenn ich mir das Teil angucke mit den kleinen Löchern und so.
Wahrscheinlich kann man es gar nicht richtig auseinanderbauen.
Das ist richtig, aber da Flüssigkeit durchläuft, läuft auch Wasser durch und
die reinigt dann einfach den Wein weg.
Also du hältst es einfach unter einem fließenden Wasserstrahl und dann ist es sauber.
Da musst du nicht mit einer Bürste ran, Du musst dann nicht mit irgendwie Spülmittel
dran, sondern einfach unter den Wasserstrahl. Reicht völlig.
Ja, also mehr Prinzlauer Berg wird der Podcast heute nicht mehr.
Moment, Moment.
Oder Fußgängerzone, ich bin schon wieder geneigt zu kaufen.
Also ich bin absolut nicht die Zielgruppe, aber vom Konzept wieder mal überzeugt.
Das ist immer, wenn ich Ralf zuhöre, nickig.
Deswegen mache ich jetzt Podcasts mit Ultraschall.
Ich habe da die Keynotes gesehen, jetzt sitzen wir hier. Also was ist das jetzt, ein S?
Also ich hätte den jetzt auf A, glaube ich, sortiert, weil es also wirklich
in sich sehr elegant dieses Problem löst.
So S, dafür fehlt so ein bisschen das Universelle, finde ich so.
Vor allem die Verbreitung, würde ich sagen. Also über den Prenzlauer Berg hinaus.
Nach dieser Sendung.
Also ich habe das damals in Göttingen kennengelernt.
Ja, das ist auch dahin.
Ich sag mal so, ich hab keinen.
Aber trinkst du gerne Rotwein?
Ich schon.
Ab und zu mal.
Ja. Dann solltet ihr den mal probieren. Wir können ja für die nächste Freakshow,
können wir hier ein Setup machen, bringe ich den mal mit und dann trinken wir
hier mal statt Bierchen, trinken wir mal ein Rotweinchen und dann werdet ihr sehen.
Was passiert. Mein Problem ist, dass es Rotwein halt nur in 0,7er Flaschen gibt
und ich glaube, es ist keine gute Idee, eine ganze Flasche zu trinken.
Das glaube ich auch. Zumindest nicht zu dritt.
So, weiter geht's. Darf ich mal ein Hassobjekt aufrufen? Etwas,
was ich abgrundtief verachte.
Das ist eine frühe Wertung schon.
Knoblauchpressen. Ich kenne keine funktionierende Knoblauchpresse.
Und das ist jetzt keine Frage von mag man jetzt irgendwie Knoblauch oder nicht,
sondern wie ist die normale Funktion, du kannst ja gleich sagen,
was bei deiner vielleicht anders ist, aber die normale Funktion in einer Knoblauchpresse
ist, es wird halt gematscht und gequetscht und nicht irgendwie gestrichen und
nicht irgendwie geschnitten, wenn ich mit einem Messer mache.
Bei Design.
Bei Design, genau.
Ich meine, wie quetschst du ein Knoblauch ohne Knoblauchpresse?
Naja, aber wenn es ja irgendwie heißt, in die Soße kommt jetzt irgendwie eine
Knoblauchzehe, dann könnte man das ja auch mit sauberen, schönen,
ästhetisch anzuschauenden kleinen Stückchen machen, anstatt mit so einer Matschepampe.
Ja, aber dann hast du den Geschmack ja nicht.
Dann hat man, wenn man ihn da durchdrückt, hat man dann so Fäden,
die drunter hängen. Das heißt, du musst dann eigentlich trotzdem nochmal, naja.
Dann solltest du vielleicht mal frischen Knoblauch kaufen, wenn der schon Fäden zieht.
Du verstehst, was ich meine. Du hast ein Loch, durch das drückst du eine Lochmaske
und durch die drückst du eine Masse durch.
Richtig, dann schneidest du es mit dem Messer ab.
Ah, das heißt, du brauchst also noch dein Messer dazu, mit dem du den Knoblauch
auch selber hättest schneiden können.
So, und am Ende hast du aber vor allen Dingen dieses Objekt von Knoblauchpresse,
was du nicht vernünftig sauber kriegst, weil überall in den Löchern und da drüber
diese zerquetschte Paste noch irgendwie rumhängt.
Ja, und dann fängst du an, wieder mit deinem Messer daran rumzuschaben,
um irgendwie diese Löcher reinzukriegen.
Es ist so hart, dass du es auch mit dem Wasserstrahl nicht gereinigt bekommst.
Das ist einfach eine totale Vollkatastrophe versus ich nehme einfach die Knoblauchzehe.
Die schälen muss ich dir ja sowieso. Das heißt also, der dürfste Teil der Arbeit
ist schon gemacht, auch wenn ich die in die Presse reintue und hacke die einmal
in zwei Sekunden mit meinem Santoku durch.
Der Link ist schon im Chat. Ah, Knoblauchpresse von Ikea. Ich habe auch eine
von Ikea, aber nicht die.
Die ist nicht so geil. Es gibt da eine, die...
Oh Gott, wie beschreibe ich denn das? Die ist so gebaut, dass man sie so auseinanderklappen kann.
Ja, habe ich. Also so ganz auseinander und dann kommt man eigentlich überall rein.
Nein, ja, aber normalerweise hast du ja, du hast ja quasi das Gefäß,
wo unten die Löcher drin sind und den Stempel.
Und die ist aber so gebaut, dass das Gefäß, wo die Löcher drin sind,
auch nochmal auseinanderklappbar ist.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich meine hier finde. Also ich glaube schon,
eine der eleganteren zu haben, aber es ist immer noch alles Mist.
Also ich kann ja nur folgendes zu sagen. Die beste Presse, die beste Knoblauchpresse ist keine Presse.
Sondern ich bin dazu übergegangen, Knoblauch ausschließlich mit einer Microplane zuzubereiten.
Mit einer was?
Microplane.
Was ist das?
Das ist so die angesagte Küchenreibe, hat Huckel hier einst mal eingebracht.
Microplane, also es gibt Microplane-artige Dinge gibt es mittlerweile von anderen Herstellern,
aber Microplane als Hersteller hat das Ganze sehr populär gemacht.
Das sind also quasi hier diese Classic-Serie zum Beispiel, die ist ganz hervorragend.
Also die empfehle ich generell als Küchengerät, aber wir reden ja heute nicht
über Küchengeräte, sondern wir reden ja über Single-Purpose-Geräte angeblich.
So eine Microplane, hier ein Griff und sieht so ein bisschen aus wie eine normale Pfeile.
Hat aber sozusagen ganz viele kleine Löcher, wo das Metall etwas nach oben gebogen
ist, mit dem du extrem filigran Dinge zusammenfalten kannst, so reiben kannst.
Und wenn du Knoblauch nimmst und über die Micropane, dann verwandelst du ohne
viel Mühe diese Knoblauchzehe,
in einen feinen Knoblauchmus, wie ihn keine Presse der Welt herstellt. Also es ist einfach...
Ganz anderes Küchengerät, ganz andere Ergebnisse. Ich sehe ja eins,
kann ein bisschen länger dauern jetzt vielleicht als mit so einer Presse,
aber da man sowieso in der Regel nur ein oder zwei Knoblauchzehen in diesen Mousse umsetzt,
das dann aber in einer Soße sehr fein sich auflösen sehen möchte,
ist das einfach der beste Ansatz.
Aber du musst ja mit deinen Fingern den Knoblauch dann festhalten und dann rüber reiben.
Das heißt, du hast dann schon relativ viel Knoblauchsaft auch an den Fingern
dran und das geht dann drei Stunden nicht weg.
Ach, scheiß drauf. Also wer Knoblauch isst, der muss auch Knoblauch anfassen können.
Es gibt auch den Microplane-Schutzhandschuh, damit man sich nicht schneidet natürlich.
Ja, es ist weicher.
Gut, okay, also mag sein, dass das was kann, aber wir reden ja jetzt von klassischen Knoblauch.
Lustig. Es gibt da diesen Link zu dieser Knoblauchpresse, weil Ikea die zurückruft.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof.
Warum?
Irgendwas mit Metallspäne, die sich lösen können.
Aber ich glaube, meine ist schon so alt, die, ja.
Also die Knoblauchpresse von Ikea ist schon besser als die normalen Knoblauchpressen,
weil die Kraft sehr viel besser umgesetzt wird?
Nee, es geht um diese Werdefull, wie die da so heißt. Was man da jetzt an dem
Bild, naja, wenn du es wegscrollst, sieht man es nicht.
Die Leute sehen das sowieso nicht, egal ob ich das scrolle oder nicht.
Dass du quasi wie so eine Tür unten den Zylinder aufklappen kannst und dann
liegt das Lochblech, wo du durchpresst, komplett frei und man kann es relativ einfach Es bleibt.
Doch immer in diesen Löchern.
Stecken. Nein, nein.
Also das hier ist in etwa meine.
Und vor allen Dingen die Microplane, wie machst du denn die sauber?
Die Frage muss erlaubt sein.
Das ist einfach.
Ja, Roddy, das ist meine. Da kannst du also auch den eigentlichen Reibenteil
gut rausholen und es ist trotzdem scheiße zu reinigen.
Also ich plädiere für ein F, aber was weiß ich schon.
Ja, naja, aber ohne Klobbauchpresse kannst du kein Knoblauch pressen.
Ich kenne auch kein Rezept, wo man nicht mit einem fein gehackten Knoblauch
genauso weit kommt, wie mit einem gepressten Knoblauch.
Du musst halt ein bisschen mit dem Messer umgehen.
Naja, normalerweise packst du halt die Knoblauchzehe in die Presse,
kippst noch ein bisschen Öl dazu und presst dann, weil sich dann halt direkt
der Knoblauchgeschmack im Öl löst.
Ja, nun gut.
Also ich habe ja auch noch ein Tipp-Video hier reingeworfen für die,
die Knoblauch nicht schälen wollen.
Das ist dieses, man macht die Zehen auseinander, schneidet oben und unten diese
Spitze ab, tut die Zehen einfach in so ein Tupperware-Plastik-Ding und schüttelt
so lange, bis die ganzen äußeren Schalen sich gelöst haben.
Und dann kann man die blanken Zehen da so rausholen.
Naja, normalerweise kannst du auch mit dem flachen Messer, also mit der flachen
Seite auf die Knoblauch. Zehe draufdrücken, bis es einmal Knock macht.
Und dann kann man gleich weiter schnibbeln.
Und dann kannst du auch die Schale einfach abnehmen.
Okay, was ist unser Verdikt?
Also mehr als die darf hier nicht sein.
Auf jeden Fall A.
Ich koche nicht. Ich finde die Dinge auch immer super nervig. Es mag aber Gute geben.
Die, die ich bisher kennengelernt habe, wenn ich helfe bei, wenn andere Leute
kochen, helfe ich natürlich, dann fand ich das auch immer super nervig und dachte
auch, das hätte ich auch schneiden können.
Aber es macht gute gehen. Ich sage C, weil man einfach oft drauf verübt,
ich kann ja meinetwegen auch D, ist okay.
Gut.
Wer will noch was?
Jetzt kommt das, worauf wir alle gewartet haben. Worauf sich hier auch alles
zuspitzt. Das ist jetzt Peak-Sendung. Und zwar ein Slushie.
Kann mir jemand erklären, was das ist?
Das ist ein Slush-Maker.
Macht das so Slush-Eis?
Ja.
Das kann man auch für zu Hause kaufen.
Ja, das braucht dann echt viel Platz.
Habe ich vor ein paar Wochen gemacht. Fairerweise muss ich sagen,
steht nicht in der Küche, sondern im Wohnzimmer.
Weil Küche voll.
Aber sagen wir mal so, ist relativ regelmäßig im Betrieb.
Ja, vor allem heute wahrscheinlich.
Das Schöne daran ist, du kannst halt auch irgendeinen Saft nehmen,
packst rein, schaltest an.
Also wie funktioniert dieses Gerät?
Wie funktioniert das Gerät? Du hast so einen Metallzylinder,
der wird durch eine Wärmemaschine gekühlt, sodass sich dort Eis absetzt.
und dann hast du so eine Plastikschnecke, die außenrum dieses Eis immer wieder abkratzt.
Wie lange dauert das für irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, halber Liter oder sowas?
Das kommt darauf an, wie gut du es vorher gekühlt hast.
Wie viele Stunden muss ich es vorher anschalten, damit es gut kühlt?
Also wenn du was aus dem Kühlschrank nimmst?
Wenn du es aus dem Kühlschrank nimmst, naja, eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten oder so.
Okay.
Für welche Menge?
Egal. Naja, nee, nicht ganz egal. Aber so ein halber Liter, Viertelstunde ein
ganzer Liter, man kann fast zwei Liter reinmachen, habe ich allerdings noch nicht gemacht.
Da kann es ein bisschen länger dauern und dann gibt es Mischungen,
die brauchen einfach auch länger.
Und was genau machst du rein? Einfach nur Saft?
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, sagen wir mal so.
Ja gut, aber was ist so?
Was ich normalerweise mache, ist halt so, ich weiß nicht, kennst du von Proviant
die Apfelschorle? Die sehr lecker ist.
Mhm.
So was kann man reinmachen. Man kann aber auch einfach Fruchtsäfte zusammenkippen
und dann noch ein bisschen Sirup obendrauf.
Du musst mindestens 5% Zuckeranteil haben, sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Und maximal 20% Alkohol, sonst funktioniert es auch nicht. Ich würde gerade fragen.
So mein altes Chemiewissen sagt mir gerade, dass das mit dem Alkohol wahrscheinlich
sehr viel länger dauert dann.
Also mein Verdikt dafür wäre, das ist jetzt vielleicht fast ein bisschen romantische
Sichtweise, ich finde manche Dinge sollte man nicht zu Hause machen,
sondern da sollte man irgendwo hin und sich freuen, weil es dann was Besonderes ist.
Achso, so wie Popcorn.
Ja, guter Punkt.
Da würde ich mitgehen, darum ist es hier auch nur auf B.
exakt richtig. Ich habe, immer wenn ich zu Hause Popcorn mache,
ein bisschen ein schlechtes Gefühl deshalb.
Die Kinder haben mir Kinobesuch gebracht.
Genau.
Da ist schon was dran.
Ich bin jetzt Kino, fress dir das Popcorn aus der Silikonschale.
Also das finde ich ein völlig absurdes Argument.
Und es braucht einfach irre viel Platz.
Ich finde es ein völlig absurdes Argument, weil die Maschine kann nichts dafür,
dass du irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewicht.
Aber dass sie so viel Platz braucht, dafür kann sie was.
Das stimmt, viel Platz braucht sie tatsächlich, allerdings gibt es kaum eine
andere Möglichkeit, so ein kaltes Kaltgetränk.
Das stimmt. Welche Kategorie, ich habe mal kurz geguckt, Slushy Maschinen gibt
es natürlich bis in den gewerblichen, professionellen Bereich.
Gibt es überhaupt Geräte, gibt es da so ein rechts unten Modell für,
sagen wir mal, den Casual Einsatz, wo auch nicht gleich fünf verschiedene Dinger
sind, sondern nur so ein Single-Slot?
Also ich habe die Ninja Slushy und kann sie empfehlen.
Ninja Slushy. Kannst du dir so sehr empfehlen, dass du dir auch einen Link in
unseren Chat werfen würdest?
Ja.
Oh, ich kann sie übrigens auch empfehlen.
Weil es ist so heiß gerade und irgendwie finde ich die gegangen gerade ganz gut.
Die sind wahrscheinlich überall ausverkauft.
Was? In Deutschland? Schlechter Moment.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt bestellen wir die alle von der Nase weg.
Ninja Slush-Eismaschine. Also die ist, ja, das wäre ihre...
Soll ich mit dem Link noch warten? Nee, es ist ja...
Ja, die Ninjas sind aber bekannt und ein Freund von mir, der macht so richtig
Chefkoch-mäßig Fine Dining und so als Hobby, aber mit sehr, sehr viel Aufwand
und geht immer in Sternerestaurants und so und der hat genau dieses Ninja-Ding
selber in der Küche stehen.
Also wenn Arnout dieses Ding in der Küche stehen hat, muss es was können.
Also ich sage mal so, ich hatte von Ninja vorher schon einen Airfryer und war
ganz zu viel damit, weswegen ich der Firma so ein bisschen Vorabpunkte gegeben habe.
Und als das Teil dann auf den Markt kam, ich glaube dieses Jahr,
etwas früher im Jahr, gab es dann sehr viele Influencer, die irgendwie teilweise
auch Misserfolge gepostet haben damit.
also es ist so man muss sich auch ein bisschen ranarbeiten an das Gerät,
irgendwas reinkippen funktioniert nicht so gut ich habe irgendwann auch so ein
komisches Biermixgetränk das war irgend so ein,
Weißbier mit Fruchtzeug mal reingetan und da war so viel Schaumstabilisatoren
drin dass es einfach kein Slush wurde sondern irgendwie was ganz merkwürdiges also aber wir.
Reden aber hier von 350 Euro für ein kaltes Getränk. Da kannst du sehr oft das im Kino holen.
Das ist richtig, aber.
Also mindestens vierköpfige Familie und lustige Kinder.
Das ist ein Luxusobjekt, aber wir sind ja auch ein Luxuspodcast.
Natürlich sind wir das.
Und diese kurze Frage, dieser Airfryer, weil mir wird von allen gesagt,
vor allem wenn man nicht kocht, wäre das eine sinnvolle Art.
Den diskutieren wir ja heute nicht.
Ja.
Okay, es ist diskussionsnötig.
Wieso steht der Airfryer etwa nicht auf der Liste?
Nee, steht kein Airfryer auf der Liste.
Das ist nur das Gegenteil von Single Purple.
Der ist auch nicht wirklich Single Purple.
Das ist ja schon der erste Schritt hier Richtung, wie heißen diese Fiecher?
Aber Single Function.
Nee, also Airfryer passt nun wirklich nicht in die Liste.
Ganz grob, ich mag meinen Airfryer so wie er ist, weil man kann ihn auch zum
Aufbacken von Brötchen benutzen.
und ich habe auch schon so Trockenpäckchen damit getrocknet,
weil er eine Dörrfunktion hat und so weiter. Also das ist schon so.
Man macht den Ofen sehr viel weniger an.
Ein bisschen Tempo mal reinkriegen.
Okay, dann können wir was nehmen, was bestimmt alle gut finden.
Also wir müssen ihn noch einsortieren.
Der Slushy, der Slushy.
Ja.
Ich würde den B, weil es ist schon eine geile Maschine. Aber mit der Verbreitung.
Aber sehr teuer, sehr groß.
Also ich war skeptisch, aber ich sehe den Punkt, dass man einfach permanent
wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein eisgekühltes Getränk vorhält und lässt
sich einfach mit normalem Saft betreiben, das ist doch irgendwie ganz geil.
Du kannst auch einfach Saft mit Eiswürfeln drin.
Strohbedarf, hast du den gemessen?
Na ich meine, das ist ja nicht wie so ein Kühlschrank wo Eis rauskommt.
Ich glaube, er ist auch so um die 200 Watt oder so.
Permanent?
Nee, solange das Gerät läuft. Beziehungsweise der hat einen...
Also ja.
Also er hat ja auch einen Thermostat. Also sobald das fertig ist,
macht er ja immer nur ab und zu an und aus.
Also nicht permanent.
Aber während der Kühlphase.
Aber wenn es fertig ist, dann trinkst du es ja auch mehr oder weniger direkt.
Naja, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich glaube über ein C kommen wir hier nicht hinweg.
Nee.
Na gut, meinetwegen.
Das ist ja schon ein mühsam hochgeschieftes Zeh für mich, aber ich habe ja auch
gerade nichts Gehaltes zu trinken.
Ich kann ja wieder nicht verschieben.
Ganz stabil ist das hier noch.
Ja.
Aber du kannst auch mal vorbeikommen und dann führe ich dir das Gerät vor.
Wenn du vorher sagst, was du da haben willst, kann ich das dann auch bei Bedarf zubereiten.
Ja, ja, ich bin interessiert. Also auf jeden Fall.
So, ich habe mal noch was mitgebracht. Oh Gott.
Was ist zu klein? Was?
Ein Toasthalter.
Ah.
Habe ich mal mitgebracht. Also erst mal, welches Problem löst ein Toasthalter?
Warum kommt man überhaupt auf die Idee, dass man einen Toasthalter braucht?
Das ist eine gute Frage, weil das ist mal sowas, so ein F-Tier-Kandidat.
Also, man sollte nicht unterschätzen, es gibt durchaus einen Sinn oder eine
Notwendigkeit, einen Toast hinzustellen, anstatt irgendwie hinzulegen.
Denn wir wissen, ein Toast hat zwei Seiten und wenn du ihn einfach nur auf einen
Tisch legst, die Unterseite, wenn du ihn heiß aus dem Toaster rausholst,
kondensiert und weicht auf.
Das heißt, du hast oben eine normale krosse Seite, unten eine durchweichte, wabberige Seite.
Darum hast du einen Toasthalter, um den Toast hochkant abkühlen zu lassen,
sodass beide Seiten gleichzeitig kross bleiben.
Was ist das für eine Welt?
Da kommt sofort Butter und dann ist der weg.
Ansonsten kannst du keine Butter drauf machen, außer du hast dann irgendwie Butterpampe.
Die Pampe, die schmilzt schön und zieht ins Toast ein.
Lass mir meine Butterpampe.
So, und...
Eure königliche Hoheit.
Ja genau, da wollte ich jetzt so kommen. Habt ihr The Crown gesehen?
Nein.
Da gibt es dann ganz viele pseudodokumentarische Szenen von Buckingham Palace
und wie das alles so abgeht.
Und da habe ich immer ganz genau geguckt, was für einen Toasthalter hat denn
eigentlich die Queen of England? Und den hätte ich doch auch ganz gerne.
Leider Kapital der Enttäuschung. Das Set Design enttäuscht die auf ganzer Linie.
Das ist also irgendein Standardding, was mit Sicherheit nicht im Buckingham Palace steht.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Versilberten, der war auch schon so ein bisschen angeraunst
ist. Und dass er so ein bisschen angeraunst ist, hat einen Grund,
er ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Einsatz bei uns.
Das heißt, sobald man also Kinder hat, ist diese ganze theoretische Abhandlung,
die ich gerade eben hatte, völlig egal.
Du hast jetzt ein Gerät hier angeschleppt, was du selber nicht benutzt.
Genau.
Oder eine Vorrichtung.
Um mal so ein bisschen die Range halt irgendwie...
Also das Ding sieht ja ganz hübsch aus und ich bewundere den Aufwand,
der getrieben wurde, um dieses Produkt überhaupt erstmal in die Welt zu setzen.
Er könnte auch Servietten halten.
Es könnte auch Servietten halten. Es könnte auch, was weiß ich, andere Dinge halten.
Es erinnert mich enorm an Großbritannien. Also speziell an England. Sehr englisch.
Toast ist da ja auch nochmal was ganz Besonderes. Aber Toast halt längere Zeit
stehen zu lassen, ist halt irgendwie gegen die Idee des Toasts.
Also Toast muss halt einfach, weiß ich nicht, heiß gegessen werden und diese
Manier Toast irgendwie so erst mal so hinzudrapieren wie so ein Blumengebinde,
nur um ihn dann abkühlen zu lassen. Ich meine, wer will den kalten Toast.
Ja.
Kalter Toast ist ja wie warmer Slushy.
Sehr schön.
Ja, also ich habe also schon das Problem, wenn du irgendwie Toast mit Butter
und Erdbeermarmelade essen willst, dann musst du schon den ein bisschen abkühlen lassen.
Ansonsten zerfließt die Butter, das kann man mögen, aber wenn du dann noch die
Marmelade drauf machst, dann hast du da so eine komische Suppe.
Ach, herrlich. Das Fett muss so richtig schön reinreichen in den Toast.
Ist nicht meins. Trotzdem, ich glaube, wir können uns drauf einigen.
Also Butter schon vor dem Toasten drauf halte ich ein bisschen. Ich weiß ja nicht.
F finde ich jetzt ein bisschen haarsches Urteil. Ich hätte ihn jetzt bei D drin
gehabt, aber... Da werde ich mich jetzt nicht weiter mit uns tun.
Wobei, ich würde sagen, ich sehe schon, wodurch er auf D kommen könnte.
Wir könnten nämlich jetzt vorziehen, die Maiskolbenspieße.
Ja. Ja, die habe ich auch mal mitgebracht.
All die ganzen Unbenutztes noch einmal hier auf dem Tisch legen, danach in die Augen.
Pass auf, dass die Meta-Ebene nicht bald voll steht mit dem Rümpel.
So, also. Ich habe vor mir, ich glaube, den Original Weber von dem Grillhersteller.
Maiskolbenspieße, die sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie auch noch in zwei Stück
als Pärchen ineinander gesteckt werden können, damit man sich nicht aus Versehen
in der Schublade an den garstigen, spitzen Teilen irgendwo geht.
Oder nur einen findet.
Oder nur einen findet. Man braucht ja immer zwei für jeden Maiskolben.
So, das ist ein Utensil, von dem bin ich wirklich sehr überzeugt.
Wir essen viel Mais zu Hause und eben nicht aus der Dose, sondern halt irgendwie
in der Tat aus der Mikrowelle.
Und es löst einfach dieses Problem, einigermaßen würdevoll Mais zu essen am Stück.
Ja, vor allem ohne verbrannte Finger.
Weil Mais ist einfach mal sehr heiß, wenn er aus der Mikrowelle rauskommt.
Und ja, du kannst links und rechts eine Gabel reinstecken. Das funktioniert
mal gut, mal mehr, mal weniger gut, je nachdem wie hart ein Mais ist.
In der Regel nicht so geil.
In der Regel nicht so geil. Außerdem hast du dann dieses fliegende Objekt plötzlich
vor dir, weil diese beiden Gabeln links und rechts dann irgendwie so Flügel
da so rausstarken. Und all diese Probleme löst einfach dieses 4-Euro-Objekt hier.
Das tackerst du einmal links rein, einmal rechts rein. Es ist super schnell
zu reinigen. Es sieht elegant aus. Du kannst super drehen, weil es halt eine runde Form hat.
Es ist ein eigentlich perfektes Objekt.
Wir kennen alle diesen Walt Disney Zeichentrickfilm, wo der eine irgendwie Maiskolben
isst und dann hat man den Soundtrack einer Schreibmaschine dazu.
Und dann schiebt er den immer wieder zurück.
Vorschlag.
Also ich hätte den bei B drin.
B?
Ja, einfach super.
B. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Du musst das mal ausprobieren, Tim.
Ich hab das schon mal ausprobiert.
Nie wieder ohne.
Ich glaube, ich bin einfach nicht so ein Freund von Maiskolben essen.
Kostet nix, kein Platz.
Meinetwegen, B.
Ja, ich bin dafür da, dass Ralf früh ins Bett kommt.
Mit deiner Auswahl wird das hier eh nix. Wir haben hier noch irgendwie...
Wir hätten ja keine Themen, meinte er, vor der Sendung getan.
Wir hatten ja auch keine Themen.
Können wir dann über was sprechen, was zentral zu dieser Sendung gehört und
was mein Leben auch maßgeblich verändert hat?
Die Brotbackmaschine. Klar.
Ich hörte einfach eines Tages einfach Freakshow, ahnte nichts Böses und dann
wurde eine Brotbackmaschine vorgestellt.
Ich fing an zu googeln, Ich kaufte das rechts unten Modell, ich backe Brot.
Es ist mittelgut, also Bäcker können das besser als Brotmischungen,
also die man nur so kauft.
Ich bin noch, ihr wisst, ich koche nicht, ich scheue Aufwand,
aber ich liebe gutes Brot und da gibt es durchaus Leute, die ich kenne,
die selbst ihr eigenes Brot backen und zwar hier Sauerteig, Dingsbums mit diesem
ganzen Starter und dieses ganze Brimborium.
Und diese Brotbackmaschine kann ja scheinbar möglicherweise eigentlich auch
damit umgehen. Hat ja so einen Messbecher dabei.
Geht das irgendwann und dann könnte man in dieser Maschine sogar richtig gutes
Brot backen? Tim, hast du da nähere Erkenntnisse?
Nein, also die Antwort ist nein. Die Brotbackmaschine ist ein Kompromiss,
das ist einfach der Sieg der Faulheit.
Aber das ist geil, weil um ein richtiges Brot zu backen, brauchst du ganz andere
Temperaturen, brauchst du einen ganz anderen Feuchtigkeitshaushalt.
Wenn du Sauerteig machst, dann musst du ja eh sozusagen mit Hefe ansetzen und so weiter.
Und ich muss auch sagen, auch dieses Hefefach habe ich bisher auch aus Faulheit nicht benutzt.
Ich habe es mal ausprobiert. Das hat irgendwie keinen Nennenswerten-Unterschied gemacht.
Und es ist auch so, dass nicht unbedingt immer alles immer gelingt und man weiß
danach auch nicht unbedingt immer, warum.
Meistens hat es was mit der falschen Wassermenge zu tun. Das Gerät ist in der Hinsicht sehr picky.
aber auf der anderen Seite ist es halt einfach geilo weil du holst dir so eine
69 Cent Brotbackmischung irgendwie im Supermarkt, zack, bumm,
kleines Paket, 500 Gramm, fällt nicht groß ins Gewicht,
machst den Schrank voll mit verschiedenen Dingen und dann einfach abends 300
Milliliter Wasser draufkippen, Klappe zu,
piep piep piep, drei Tasten zack, return und dann gehst du ins Bett und wachst
auf, morgen von piep, piep, piep, dein Brot ist fertig.
Und die ganze Wohnung duftet nach Brot. Das ist einfach der Brüller.
Und ja, dann nimmst du das irgendwie raus, lässt es nochmal eine halbe Stunde
abkühlen und dann hast du halt einfach zwar jetzt nicht das beste Brot im Sinne von, oh geil,
Brot, was ich jetzt hier eine Woche rumstehen lassen kann und dann ist es immer noch geiles Brot.
Also es ist nicht die Art Brot, sondern es ist so die Art Brot,
die du am besten eines, maximal zweier Tage verbrauchst.
Danach ist es zu trocken. Aber,
Bis dahin ist es einfach geil und billig.
Und das einzige Brot, was ich finde, was wirklich bombastisch gut gelingt, ist Ciabatta-Brot.
Wenn man hier so, wie heißen die, in Öl eingelegten, getrockneten Tomaten und
Oliven, wenn man sowas mag, einfach klein schneiden.
Das habe ich am Anfang rum experimentiert mit diesem extra Fach und so.
Kannst du alles vergessen.
Einfach dieses Wasser rein, Brotbackmischung für Ciabatta-Brot rein und oben
so viel von diesem Tomaten- und Olivenzeug, wie du willst.
auf das Mehl da oben drauf, einfach die ganz normale, wie Julien sagen würde,
Mitte, Mitte, alles auf Mitte stellen, mittlere Größe, mittlere Dauer,
mittlere Bräunungsgröße, Mitte, Mitte, einfach erstes Programm, go.
Und das ist ein Partyknaller.
Also so frisch gebackenes Schabatta-Brot mit so Dingens mitbringen,
das ist wirklich der Kracher und das ist eben auch nicht dieses ja,
ist so Graubrot, also so Graubrot und so, die werden so okay.
So Körnerbrotkram Die Sonnenblumenkern wird besser, weil die mehr Feuchtigkeit
haben, das wird besser, aber genau, es ist jetzt nicht das Turbobrot vom Bäcker,
aber genau. So, wohin tun wir die Maschine?
Die kommt bei mir schon recht weit oben. Also ein A oder ein B muss es schon sein.
Ja, definitiv B.
Also ich hatte mal eine Brotbackmaschine und bin da überhaupt nicht froh mit
geworden. Das ist allerdings jetzt auch 25 Jahre her.
Das mag also auch sein, dass es da auch einfach mal Fortschritt gab.
Ich glaube so richtig, Tim.
Kennen Leute, die sagen, nee, Brot muss auch einfach mal im Backofen.
Alles andere ist irgendwie doof und haben
dann dafür wiederum irgendwie Spezialintensilien, wo das dann drin ist.
Das nimmt sich, glaube ich, nicht so viel.
Also, wie gesagt, es wird nicht das geilste Brot, aber es ist irgendwie...
Also ich wäre mit einem B, wäre ich zufrieden?
Ja, nimmt B.
Ja, weil es ist halt dann auch groß, ja, es ist sehr single purpose,
aber es ist halt so ein bisschen wie mit den Eierkochern.
Also Brot ist ja jetzt kein Exot.
Mhm.
Also, seit dieser Sendung benutze ich das 99 Prozent, um Brot herzustellen.
Ab und zu nur aus Abwechslungsgründen kaufe ich mal noch irgendwo Brot beim
Bäcker, Schwarzbrot oder so, aber eigentlich ist die im Dauereinsatz.
Und das ist ein deutliches Zeichen, finde ich. Aber gut, was soll ich sonst auch essen?
Reis. Hol dir einen Reiskocher.
Ja, ich mag Reis gerne, aber dann braucht man ja Soßen und Dinge,
die zu dem Reis dazu und da wird es sofort schwierig.
Deswegen brauche ich einen Airfryer und dann komme ich nochmal in die Sendung.
Ne, also ist das ein B?
Ich würde sagen, ja.
Das ist schon ein B plus Ich.
Hätte mal ein bisschen auf die 5-Stunden-Marke schielend,
Ein Verfahrensvorschlag für drei Esstier am Stück, auf die man sich vielleicht
einigen kann Ohne allzu viel Debatte Wasserkocher, Toaster Stabmixer,
Eine Küche geht nicht ohne und das sind einfach total sinnvolle Produkte.
Wasserkocher und Toaster gehe ich mit, Stabmixer hat meiner Meinung nach in
der Liste nichts zu suchen, aber das...
Wieso? Weil er nicht wirklich Single-Purpose ist.
Man kann damit sehr, sehr viele unterschiedliche Dinge tun. Also das ist irgendwie...
So, weil meinst du, dass es schon eine kleine Küchenmaschine ist?
Ja, ja.
Man pürieren über zerkleinern.
Auch hier wieder eine ziemliche Unschärfe in unserem Ziel. Wir müssen das noch
besser hinkriegen mit dem Tierlist.
Ja.
Okay, wie weit sind wir denn mit Toaster und Wasserkocher? Weil da gehe ich auch mit.
Also ich würde sagen, hat jeder, benutzt jeder, funktioniert einfach.
Wasserkocher meinst du?
Ja, auch Toaster.
Gibt es unterschiedlich gute, brauchen wir jetzt auch vielleicht nicht diskutieren.
Es gibt hervorragende Toaster, es gibt hervorragende Wasserkocher.
Ja.
Wasserkocher hatten wir auch schon mal in der Sendung ein paar.
Ja, ist ein Riesenthema.
Ja, also ja. Also bei Stabmixern.
Also ich habe den SEG Zauberstab, so ein totaler Klassiker.
Ja, absolut.
Der kann auch was und der spart halt wirklich dann auch in vielen Szenarien
halt so eine Küchenzerhexler.
Ja, ich habe auch einen Benutzchen, aber nicht so oft, aber ja.
Rein in den Suppentopf Suppe pürieren.
Ja, ich mag keine pürierten Suppen, aber das ist halt...
Was?
Ja, die sind nach dem zweiten Löffel langweilig. Ich mag lieber,
wenn die Sachen alle noch einzeln da sind. Aber gut, das ist jetzt eine andere Diskussion.
Ja, ist es.
Gut, also ich würde mich für einen Stabmixer auf einen A runterhandeln lassen.
Ja, also unter A geht das auf keinen Fall.
Wir können ihn auch auf S tun.
Der kommt ohne Stabmixer aus, aber nicht ohne Wasserkocher. Auch nicht ohne Waage.
Wenn wir schon bei solchen Verfahrensfragen sind, dann würde ich das Waffeleisen
und den Sandwichmaker gerne auch zusammen besprechen.
Schon alleine, weil ich ein Waffeleisen habe, was auch Sandwichmaker einsetzt.
Ja, das ist same, same.
Da bin ich jetzt interessiert an deinem Vorschlag, weil das habe ich auch alles
in der Tat und das ist sehr viel mehr im Einsatz, seit ich Kinder habe.
Ich sage mal so, ich habe seit ich das Ding gekauft habe, glaube ich,
einmal oder zweimal benutzt.
Welches? Achso, das kommt mir geregelt.
Mit Sandwich Maker und Waffeleisen einsetzen.
Ja, also ich kann da was zu sagen, auch weil ich den Sandwich Maker hinzugefügt habe.
Also, Sandwich Maker ist für mich so ein bisschen die Entdeckung des letzten
Jahres gewesen, weil es einfach das perfekte Ding ist für den kleinen Hunger.
Das ist sogar maligkompatibel meiner Meinung nach.
Und du kannst unglaublich viel Varianz in die Sache reinbringen.
Also ich habe jetzt immer geraspelten Käse, ein Glas Jalapenos,
so Schinkenwürfel, so Kapern.
Dann kann man auch wunderbar Pesto, für was man sonst immer keine Anwendung
hat, weil man nicht so oft Nudeln essen will, aber Pesto einfach mal so direkt auf den Toast drauf.
Und in dieser Kombination haust du das einfach in diesen Sand-Squatch-Maker
und du hast fünf Minuten später so ein heißes, geiles, knuspriges Snack.
Snack, alles drin, bisschen scharf, bisschen Käse, bisschen,
bisschen dies, bisschen Pesto, Oliven, alles ist dabei.
Und so zack, zack, zack mal eben zwischendurch. Ohne, dass du groß gekocht hast und schon bist du da.
Aber,
Du hast mit allem recht, aber das Ding, ich habe auch so ein Ding,
aber es steht bei meiner Mutter.
Warum? Weil das ist so ein Ding.
Wir reden wirklich viel über deine Mutter.
Das ist eine tolle Frau. Die kommt mal in die Sendung und dann...
Also folgendes, das Problem ist nämlich dieses, das Ding ist total super,
dann frisst man eine Woche nichts anderes, dann tut man das in den Schrank und
dann vergisst man das für ein Jahr.
Das ist halt genau so eins dieser Geräte. Also das ist mein Problem damit sozusagen.
Und deswegen, weil es dann ewig im Schrank stand, irgendwann kam meine Mutter
um die Ecke, hör mal, du hast doch nicht so ein Ding, leih mir den doch mal.
Ja, und dann habe ich vergessen, dass sie den hat. Jetzt sprechen wir drüber.
Der ist mindestens schon zwei Jahre bei ihr. Und ich glaube,
auch da nur so zweimal im Jahr im Einsatz.
Und reinigen ist scheiße.
Ich finde, das sind alles gute Argumente.
Also ich weiß nicht, bei meinem kann man die Dinger rausnehmen,
da packe ich in die Spülmaschine und gut ist, oder?
Ah ne, das geht dann bei dem nicht, den wir da haben. Ja, das ist aber so ein ganz dummer.
Weil man die Einsätze ja wechseln kann.
Ja, wenn man diese Spülmaschinen fährt, das ist doch so beschichtet.
Naja, würde ich auch nicht machen.
Sonst was? Ach, einfach nasses,
Papiertuch reinlegen, das passt schon irgendwie. So super sauber müssen die auch nicht sein.
Aber du hast einen interessanten Punkt aufgebracht, der gilt natürlich generell
für fast alle diese Geräte hier.
Sie machen alle nur Sinn, wenn man sie an einem Ort immer im direkten,
betriebsbereiten Zustand stehen hat, idealerweise sogar an Strom angeschlossen.
Also nicht bei Muttern.
Ich hab's schon erwähnt. Ihr habt zu wenig Platz in eurer Küche.
Die ihr hier baut. Das habe ich jetzt eingeführt sowohl für die Brotbackmaschine
als auch für den Sandwichmaker und ich habe relativ wenig Platz zu vergeben
und deswegen finde ich, sind das gerade so ein bisschen die Premium-Dinger.
Waffeleisen dahingehend wiederum muss definitiv ein Tier weiter drunter sein,
weil das, man macht sich nicht täglich waffeln.
Ja, es ist so eine Partymaschine.
Genau. Da brauchst du immer einen Anlass. Lecker. Ja, ist lecker,
aber du kannst nicht den ganzen Tag Waffeln essen.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich den ganzen Tag Waffeln essen kann.
Also du solltest dich den ganzen Tag Waffeln essen.
Was mich beim Waffeln machen halt so ein bisschen immer abhält,
du musst den Teig machen und dann passt der nicht auf Anhieb,
das heißt erst ab der dritten Waffel ist der dann geil.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und eigentlich ist es halt ein Party-Ding.
Wenn du für viel.
Wenn du für ein halbes Dutzend Leute Waffeln machst, das ist super,
aber nur für eine Person ist halt, naja, schwierig.
So, ich habe jetzt Hunger. Wohin mit dem Ding?
Sandwichmecker auf B, Waffeleisen auf C.
Ja, machen wir so.
Wow, jetzt geht es hier. Zack auf zack.
Tja, wir kommen in Übung. Langsam kommen wir in Übung. Dinge,
die ich nicht wusste, dass es sie gibt. Eiswürfelmaschinen, separat.
Für den Sommer natürlich ein interessantes Teil.
Wenn man keinen Slush macht.
Also, wenn man keinen Slush macht. Also, ich muss sagen, der Slushy ist tatsächlich
eine interessante Option zum Eiswürfel.
Ich meine, Eiswürfel hat den Vorteil, kannst du dann in alles reinschmeißen,
Und Slushy, weiß ich nicht, was ist denn da die Bedingungen?
Aber was ist denn jetzt der Vorteil?
Mehr als 5% Zucker und weniger als 20%.
Also diese Eiswürfelmaschinen, die funktionieren so. Die haben halt so ein Kühlelement
und die haben in der Regel so neun Finger.
Und tauchen die quasi so ins Wasser ein und dann frieren da so quasi wie so
Fingerkuppen Eiswürfel drumherum.
Deswegen haben die immer so Löcher.
Genau, deswegen haben die so Löcher, weil die auf diesen Fingern quasi wachsen.
und dann werden die noch einmal kurz warm gemacht und dann fallen die wieder
runter und dann landen die vorne in so einem Speicher.
Und dort werden sie dann irgendwie kühl gehalten.
Das Wasser, was von denen abtropft, das landet wieder unten und wird dann quasi
für die nächsten Eiswürfel weiterverwendet.
Die Dinger machen so neun Eiswürfel ungefähr in zehn Minuten.
Sechs Minuten steht hier.
Ja, manche sind schneller, ein bisschen weniger. Das hängt natürlich auch immer
sehr viel davon ab, wie warm ist es drumherum und so weiter.
Das ist schnell.
Das heißt, du hast natürlich jetzt Der Nachteil ist, du hast nicht so richtig
schöne knackige, dicke Eiswürfel, die wirklich so einen Kern haben.
Das heißt, die schmelzen halt tendenziell auch schneller weg.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Nachteil. Aber wenn du halt in einer heißen Umgebung
bist und musst irgendwie mobil nachproduzieren, sind die Dinger fix dabei und
dann kannst du halt einfach auch viele produzieren,
viele in deinen Ursaft reinwerfen oder in deinen Kaffee und dann ist das irgendwie eine geile Nummer.
Und du solltest halt vielleicht dann so einen Produktionsprozess starten,
dann läuft das Ding irgendwie mal eine Stunde, leerst regelmäßig,
packst deine Eiswürfel am besten in so ein Eisfach, also wenn du eins dabei
hast, also jetzt einen Wohnwagen zum Beispiel oder ein Wohnmobil.
Aha, Wohnwagen.
Ja, genau. Also benutzt den Automaten, um schnell diese Dinger zu produzieren,
weil es halt ewig dauern würde, die im Kühlschrank so heranzuzüchten.
So, das ist halt eigentlich der Vorteil.
Naja, ich habe zu Hause, ich habe halt diese klassischen...
Eiswürfel-Form-Dinger. Die gibt es interessanterweise halt mit Deckel,
den man so drüber schiebt.
Und das Witzige an dem Deckel ist, der hat so an dem Ende, den man so auf,
wie so eine Tagespillendose, kann man den so aufschieben.
Und der hat aber so eine komische, zackige Kante, sodass man tatsächlich immer
einzelne Eiswürfel rausmachen kann, ohne dass sie einem alle entgegenfallen.
Kannst du das mal rausholen?
Ja.
Bei Edeka gibt es die, aber ich kann.
Also ich bin auch wirklich nicht überzeugt. Ich habe immer Eiswürfel zu Hause,
weil mit unserem neuen Kühlschrank auch ein sehr geiles Eiswürfel-Kompartment mit dazu kam.
Das kann man sich so vorstellen, das ist eigentlich eine relativ klassisch anmutende
Plastikgeschichte, in der die eigentlichen Eiswürfel produziert werden.
Die sind aber gleichzeitig Deckel für eine Schale, die unten drunter ist,
in die zwei Lagen von diesen produzierten Eiswürfeln genau reinpassen.
Das heißt, du produzierst also einmal quasi zwei Lagen Eiswürfel,
packst die unten runter in den Behälter und hast dann oben drüber als Deckel
immer noch eine dritte Lage auch Eiswürfel.
So und immer wenn ich also Eiswürfel
irgendwie hole, hole ich die unten einfach aus dem Behälter raus.
Wenn der sich anfängt ein bisschen zu leeren, schütte ich einmal oben die dritte
Lage in den Behälter rein, mache neues Wasser rein, fertig.
Das heißt also, du hast eigentlich einen nie endenden Nachschub an Eiswürfeln,
musst dich aber nicht mit irgendwelchen Spezialkonstruktionen rumärgern.
Alles steht und fällt mit der Geschwindigkeit. Also so eine Eiswürfelmaschine
ist wirklich nur erforderlich, wenn du mal einen hohen Produktionsdruck hast
und du brauchst einfach in kurzer Zeit viel Eiswürfel.
Das in anderen Sinn sehe ich da nicht. Also das Ding ist bestenfalls zäh.
Ist sicherlich nicht so bekloppt wie eine Knoblauchpresse.
Also ich sag mal so, ich hab halt fünf oder so von diesen Eiswürfelbereitern
immer im Eisfach und sobald einer leer ist, fülle ich den nach und packe ihn wieder nach unten.
Ja, sagen wir mal eher so für den mobilen Einsatzer.
Ja, weil so jetzt mal eben volle Kanne irgendwie nur noch Eiswürfel.
Nee, ich finde den nicht, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es den bei EDEKA gibt.
Das ist ein relativ simples Teil und ja, ist nicht Silikon.
Ist ein bisschen auf jeden Fall speziell. Also diese Eiswürfelmaschine,
die wir hier haben, ist ja sehr, braucht viel Platz, ist sehr spezialisiert
auf, ich habe eine Party, da kommen 40 Leute.
die kämen bei mir relativ weit runter, auf ein D oder so.
Ja, hab jetzt mal ein Bild reingepackt, so ungefähr ist das Grundprinzip.
Meiner sieht ganz anders aus und ist ein kleiner und kompakter.
Also ich hätte jetzt hier auch eher ein D gezogen, so wie oft es bedarf,
dass man wirklich so viel ist.
Gut, deswegen, weiter.
So, was haben wir denn noch? So etwas, was bei mir in der Gunst echt total gestiegen
ist, was ich irgendwie 40 Jahre lang oder 45 Jahre lang ignoriert habe, Milchschäumer.
Und zwar eben nicht diese kleinen, garstigen, sich schnell drehenden,
die man irgendwo reinpackt, sondern als dezidiertes Gerät, ungefähr so die halbe
Größe von einem Wasserkocher,
die gleichzeitig warm machen und Milch oder was auch immer Kakao aufschäumen können.
Das haben wir fast täglich für die Kinder im Einsatz bei uns und gar nicht,
weil wir jetzt irgendwie da großen Latte Macchiato oder sowas mitmachen,
sondern einfach nur morgens schnellen warmen Kakao produzieren.
Das ist einfach super einfach und praktisch.
Genau, da haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen. Es gibt von Severin welche.
Die sind wirklich geil, weil du hast ein Edelstahlgefäß. Da ist dieser rotierende
Magnet mit drin, der aufschäumt.
Und weil dieses Gefäß aber quasi per Induktionsheizung geheizt wird,
kannst du dieses Gefäß einfach runternehmen und hinterher in die Spülmaschine tun.
Genau, oder schnell unter das laufende Wasser.
Oder unter das Wasser, ja.
Genau, ja.
Genau,
im Chat ist gerade der Eiswürfelbereiter, den ich meinte, erschienen mit dieser
komischen gezackten Ecke, wo man tatsächlich wirklich einzelne Eiswürfel raustun
kann, weil man kann ihn genau so weit aufschieben, dass nur ein Eiswürfel rausfällt.
Aber wenn der festklebt, ist das dann unten Silikon?
Naja, was du ja machst, du nimmst ja das Ding an beiden Enden und verwindest
es, bis alle Eiswürfel gemacht haben und locker sind.
Und wenn du dann versuchen würdest, einen einzelnen Eiswürfel rauszuholen,
dann würden sie dir alle entgegenkommen.
Deswegen hast du diesen Deckel, den du so schieben kannst, sodass du dann halt einzelne Eiswürfel...
Wir reden jetzt über Milchschweiber.
Genau.
Okay, Milchschweiber.
Ich bin völlig leidenschaftslos.
Ich nicht. Milchaufschäumer gehört auch zu meinen Top-Geräten,
weil ich natürlich auch so ein totaler Prinzlerberg,
Macchiato-Heini bin und auch mit Hafermilch funktioniert das einfach ganz hervorragend
und diese Milchschäumer, die halt selber auch noch heizen, sind einfach der
Brüller, weil die einfach so eine feine Masse machen und das ist einfach cool.
Es funktioniert auch super mit Schokolade reinmachen und so weiter.
Dadurch, dass es halt auch noch erhitzt, ist es einfach perfekt.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum Leute Schaum auf Dinge tun.
Also dieses andere, was ihr gerade beschreibt, coolen Kakao machen,
das kann ich mir noch vorstellen, aber ich bin ja auch kein Kaffeetrinker.
Aber wenn ich dann im Café gefragt werde, ob ich irgendwie meinen Kakao,
nee, wenn ich nicht gefragt werde, ich möchte nur Kakao trinken,
sage sogar noch ohne Sahne drauf, mal so, mal so.
Und dann ist da oben so Schaum drauf. Ich finde immer, das schmeckt nach nichts,
ist im Weg und hängt im Bad rum und so.
Warum will man Schaum auf Getränken? Habe ich nie verstanden.
Weil du keine Haut haben willst. Der Schaum verhindert, dass die Milch,
wenn sie sich abkühlt in der Haut bildet.
Weil du hast ja den Schaum schon obendrauf.
Und er hält den Kaffee wärmer.
Also, wo packen wir es rein? A?
Ich würde A sagen. Wenn ich sogar S. Ganz ehrlich.
Crazy.
Ja, ich wäre auch fast für S.
Also wenn man einen guten Milchaufschäumer hat, der ist schon was wert.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, wir können ja ruhig mal wieder ein Esstier machen.
Okay.
Vielleicht für die genannte Mutter mal ein Geschenk.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so der Klassiker, aber wirklich bei Single Purpose jetzt
oder Single, naja, Purpose, Function, was auch immer.
Ja. Und übrigens im Winter, man kann damit auch unheimlich gut Glühwein machen.
dann nimmt man nicht die Schaumscheibe, sondern nur die Umrührscheibe und dann
packst du da halt den Glühwein so die Tasse, die du haben willst,
misst du ab packst du rein, hast innerhalb von einer Minute perfekt temperierten Glühwein Okay.
Also ich glaube es, da kann ich mitgehen das ist so ein Hidden Champion Auf
jeden Fall Möge diese Sendung dazu beitragen dass mehr Leute dieses Wunder entdecken Okay,
Ich hätte noch so ein D- oder F-Kandidaten?
Fleischthermometer?
Framing ist wichtig.
Das ist ein Bratenthermometer. Ich sag mal so, wenn man tatsächlich Braten macht,
dann kommt man gar nicht drum rum, wenn das Fleisch gut werden soll.
Das kommt so ein bisschen auf den Braten an, würde ich sagen.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Also so ein Rinderbraten, der kann auch mal eine Stunde länger.
Nee, gerade Rind nicht. Weil wenn es zu lang ist, dann schmeckt es halt nur noch nach Schuhsohle.
Gerade Rind willst du innen drin auch so noch leicht Rosé haben,
mindestens. Wenn ich, na gut, blutig muss es jetzt nicht unbedingt sein.
Das ist auch eine Meinung, die kann, der kennt jeder.
Aber wenn du was wirklich auf dem Punkt gebraten haben willst,
im Ofen und so weiter, dann brauchst du einen Fleischthermometer.
Wenn du das nicht machst, dann halt nicht. Also...
Hast du eins im Einsatz?
Ja, selten. Also weil ich jetzt, sagen wir mal so, das letzte Mal,
als ich Schweinebraten gemacht habe, war es im Einsatz.
Das ist aber eine Weile her. Das ist eine größere Weile.
Tim, du?
Und dadurch, dass es nicht viel Platz verbraucht, du mit deinem Platz-Argument.
Das passt in die Schublade.
Also beim Fleisch-Termometer bin ich raus. Da bin ich jetzt mal ganz dermalig
und ich schiebe keine Gänse in den Ofen und keine längeren Fleischorgien,
da bin ich einfach unerfahren.
Das mache ich normalerweise auch nicht, aber wenn man das machen möchte,
kommt man um einen Fleischthermometer eigentlich nicht drum rum.
Nee, das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich kann mich da bloß nicht groß zu
äußern, wie praktisch oder wie sinnvoll die sind.
Ich würde halt jetzt erstmal sagen, okay, meinetwegen irgendwie B ist ja auch mehr ein Küchengerät.
B ist völlig in Ordnung.
Also für Steaks oder sowas braucht man es halt nicht. Dann macht man das mit
dieser Fingerdruckmethode. viel effizienter.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch ein Braten-Thermometer und kein Steak-Thermometer.
Es ist ein Fleisch-Thermometer und es wird viel für auch Grille und sowas verkauft
und da finde ich es also echt auch nicht,
ja...
Kerntemperatur messen ist schon... Wenn du ein richtig dickes Steak hast,
kann das auch schon helfen. Also...
Wie viele Steaks musst du machen, damit du diese, wie auch immer die Methode
nanntest, jetzt auch tatsächlich...
Du plädierst jetzt für ein C, ja? für ein B, meine ich.
Ein B ist schon angemessen. Das ist jetzt nicht das Gerät, ohne dass man nicht
kochen kann. Aber für diesen einen Fall.
Okay. Wo kommt jetzt plötzlich der Kaffee-Vollautomat her?
Den habe ich da mit reingeschmissen, aber den wollen wir zusammen mit Espressokocher
abhandeln. Aber ich habe gerade gesehen, man kann das nicht einzeln machen.
Okay.
Weil ich hätte nämlich jetzt ein paar Streichkandidaten hier in Anbezacht der
fortgeschrittenen Zeit.
Also den Silikonschaber würde ich auswerfen.
Genau, also Messerschärfer und Schneidbrett, dazu machen wir irgendwann mal
eine dezidierte Messerfolge.
Danke.
Ja, können wir machen.
Ich schmeiße die mal raus.
Die Eismaschine, das können wir auch relativ schnell machen. Irgendwas C oder D.
Es ist was zwischen Slushy und Eiswürfelmaschine, ne?
Naja, wo du halt richtiges Speiseeis mitmachst.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, aber es ist halt zwischen Slushy und Eiswürfelmaschine irgendwie.
Also wie viel Eis kann man essen und wie viel Platz verbraucht das?
Ja, also Eiswürfel ist schon nochmal was anderes als ein Milchspeise-Eis.
Insofern ist es ein dediziertes Gerät.
Ich darf nicht den ganzen Tag Waffeln essen. Da wird es bei Eismaschine.
Okay, aber bist du denn woanders als bei C oder D?
Nö.
Und welches von beiden?
Also ja, lass es auf D tun, weil so eine gute Eismaschine verbraucht verdammt viel Platz.
Ask me how I know.
Ich habe für meine KitchenAid so einen Aufsatz.
Den man ins Eisfach tut.
Genau, aber da ist dann auch kein Platz dafür. Wenn das Ding so riesig ist,
dann muss es halt erst mal zwei Stunden durchbühlen.
Die sind ganz schlimm. Also wenn man eine ordentliche Eismaschine haben will,
dann muss es schon auch eine mit Kältemaschine sein.
Das ist ein wiederkehrendes Thema bei mir, habe ich das Gefühl. Egal.
Ja. Nein, D passt.
Es ist.
Ein sehr spezielles Gerät für einen Zweck und verbraucht viel Platz Ich.
Freue mich auf jeden Fall sehr auf eure Messerfolge denn ich bin meinem Messer
schärfer ich habe so dieses Wasserstein Dings, ich bin da gar nicht zufrieden trotz Üben und so,
ich finde das alles sehr unbefriedigend da müsst ihr dann wirklich bitte zeitnah
eine ausführliche Sendung mit einem eindeutigen Ergebnis Ich überlege mir.
Da mal was an dem Thema, welchen ich in der Tat seit knapp 30 Jahren dran da
habe ich alles durch und alles gesehen,
genau, da würde ich dann auch fast den Zerkleinerer rein subsumieren also das
wäre jetzt eigentlich vielleicht nur noch Espresso und Kaffee Vollautomat haben was.
Ist ein Zerkleinerer? nur mal kurz,
wie so ein Mixer genau.
So ein Mixer aber in etwas kleiner, wo du halt irgendwie ein paar Möhren und
ein Sellerie und sonst was für eine Bolognese Soße drin zerhäckselt,
Chris. Das ist jetzt auch nicht der Rede wert.
Das ist aber im Wesentlichen ja auch nur ein Aufsatz für den Stabmixer, oder?
Ähnlich. Ja. Also würde ich jetzt hier mal ausklammern und die ganzen Schneidegeschichten
nochmal separat betrachten.
Dann lass uns das jetzt mal einfach beenden, indem wir jetzt noch ein bisschen
über Kaffee reden, oder?
Ja, aber der Schäler.
Der Schäler.
Der Schäler ist auch Multipurpose. Zumindest kannst du verdammt viele Dinge damit schälen.
Okay, okay.
Er kommt in die Messerfolge.
Genau, dann, damit es mal jemand gesagt hat, die 50er Jahre Sparschäler sind
einfach immer noch die besten.
Alles andere finde ich Schrott. Aber.
Also es ist ein bisschen traurig, dass wir den Sparschäler nicht diskutieren.
Ich will einfach an dieser Stelle noch ein weiteres Mal, ich habe das schon
tausendmal hier gesagt und ich sage es wieder, weil es die Wahrheit ist,
es gibt nur einen Sparschäler,
der wirklich der Erwähnung wert ist, das ist der Mastrat Sparschäler,
weil nur der Mastrat ist einfach mal geil.
Ja, wir, das,
Alle anderen sind einfach Quatsch. Glaubt es mir einfach.
Wir können den noch reinnehmen, wenn wir uns da schnell unternehmen.
Naja, du hast ja recht, dass es kein Single-Purpose-Gerät ist.
Darum geht es mir nicht. Ich wollte nur die Gelegenheit nutzen,
kurz darauf hinzuweisen, dass der Mastrat-Gemüseschäler einfach der einzige ist, den man braucht.
Probiert es aus, ihr werdet es wissen. Wir müssen uns jetzt aber noch über,
ich weiß nicht, hier ist noch ein Zerkleinerer.
Den haben wir auch in der Messe.
Also hören wir auf mit Kaffee. Und ich habe jetzt nochmal den Kaffee-Vollautomaten
da reingetan, damit klar ist, dass das nicht mit gemeint ist,
wenn man über eine Espressokanne redet.
Ja, aber zwischen dem Vollautomaten und der Espressokanne ist ja noch die Espressomaschine.
Oder meine sind es EO.
Der Kaffee-Vollautomat, Espressomaschine, also irgendwas Elektrisches und Kaffee.
Das ist für mich Kaffee-Vollautomat.
Nee, Kaffee-Vollautomat besticht ja dadurch, dass er nicht nur Kaffee macht,
sondern auch ein Mahlwerk hat und meistens auch noch Milch aufschäumt.
Deswegen Vollautomat.
Das heißt, du würdest noch eine dritte Kategorie, die zwischen diesen beiden liegt, aufrufen?
Das macht die Sache jetzt halt so schwierig.
Nee, es ist sehr einfach, weil meine These ist einfach, Espressokanne,
Esstier, Kaffeevollautomat, F.
Was? Ein Kaffeevollautomat ist wirklich das Schlimmste und Gruseligste und Ekligste,
was man sich überhaupt in die Küche stellen kann.
Ich verdamme Leute, die sowas überhaupt haben. Ich hab selber sowas gehabt und
ich bereue es zutiefst und ich Ich schäme mich dafür, weil diese Maschinen sind einfach laut,
groß, keine produziert, auch nur halbwegs leckeren Kaffee, sind eine Katastrophe
zu reinigen, sind totale Schimmelquellen vor dem Herrn,
geben die merkwürdigsten und unangenehmsten Geräusche von sich,
sind überhaupt keine nennenswerte Ersparnisse und alles, was da rauskommt,
ist so eine eklige Plörre.
Das gehört einfach bestraft.
Und wenn du Pech hast, geht das Malwerk kaputt, obwohl der Rest noch funktioniert
und du kannst das Teil trotzdem wegschmeißen, weil du nämlich den Kaffee gar
nicht mehr irgendwie in die Brühgruppe kriegst.
Also ein paar Punkte dazu. Erstmal haben wir jetzt ein bisschen das Problem,
was ist dann mit Kapsel-Kaffeemaschinen, was ist mit Senseo-Kaffeemaschinen, was ist mit...
Also alles F-Tier. Also Kapselmaschinen ist natürlich auch total F-Tier.
Das einzig Ware ist halt eine richtige...
Weil die haben...
Eine richtige Espressomaschine.
Was ist mit einer Espressomaschine? Was ist mit einer klassischen Filterkaffeemaschine?
Also das ufert dann schon ein bisschen aus, aber in Anbetracht der fortgeschrittenen Zeit.
Alles, was du über den Kaffeevollautomaten gesagt hast, ist erstmal richtig.
Mit einer Einschränkung, nämlich was den Geschmack angeht, der Sachen, die da rauskommt.
It depends. Also ich habe bei mir im Büro eine Jura D4.
Das ist schon so gehobene Mittelklasse und da kommt schon geiler,
sehr gut trinkender Espresso und Longo raus.
Vor allen Dingen, es kommt auch immer drauf an, was so oben rein.
Ist aber auch kein Vollautomat, das heißt also, da kippe ich dann einfach normale
Hafermilch rein und bin glücklich. Also nichts mit aufschäumen und sowas.
Aber alles andere, was du gesagt hast, ist völlig richtig. Diese Teile sind
dermaßen betreuungsintensiv.
Dem musst du so die Händchen halten. Ständig meckert die dieses,
da musst du reinigen. Hier musst du jetzt das Teil wieder rausziehen.
Es ist unfassbar, wie die einen irgendwie am Arbeiten halten,
dafür, dass sie einem noch irgendwie das Leben, das lohnt sich glaube ich,
wenn du irgendwie halt eine Abteilung hast mit 50 Leuten und du hast einen so
einen Teil in der Küche drin stehen.
Und 50 Leute kriegen schnell den Kaffee raus und 51 ist die arme Sau,
die dann wieder irgendwie alles warten und pflegen und Grund reinigen muss.
Mit Spezialkapseln, die man bestellen muss, die dann 20 Minuten durchlaufen
und dieser ganze Scheiß.
Also von daher, dass es auf F ist, es ist ein bisschen polemisch, aber ich kann damit...
Ich würde den Espresso-Kocher aber auch auf F tun, weil man damit keinen verünftigen Kaffee machen kann.
Was?
Das genau das, was Roddy sagt.
Ja, kommt auch nur eklige Blöcke raus.
Herr Retika!
Das Wasser ist zu heiß, der Druck ist zu niedrig.
Ach, alles richtig. Das ist totaler Quatsch.
Ich habe...
F, F, F.
Also als Kaffee-Verschmäher hätte ich einen Bonuspunkt für den Kaffee-Vollautomaten. Also.
Riecht die deutsche Wirtschaft in Schwung?
Knöpsche drücke und Kaffee trinke oder was?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung von Kaffee.
Ich mag keinen Kaffee. Der Punkt ist aber, es gibt Kaffeevollautomaten,
wenn ich in irgendwelchen Hotels oder sonst wo bin.
Da kommt auch Kakao raus. Ich mag Kakao.
Okay, jetzt bist du aber schon. Das ist jetzt kein Kaffeevollautomaten.
Okay, diese abgebildete Maschine. Da gibt es dann immer so sechs Knöpfe und
einer davon ist Kakao. Weil sonst stehe ich immer da und kriege halt nichts.
Aber das ist das Einzige, das hebt ihn nicht unbedingt vom F-Tier weg.
Ich wollte nur sagen, mit einem Espresso-Kocher wird das schwieriger.
Also der Espresso-Kocher ist gut
für Campingurlaub, wenn man die Espresso-Maschine nicht mitnehmen will.
Aber ansonsten geht das halt nicht.
Ich mache täglich meinen leckeren Kaffee, für den ich immer gelobt werde,
mit einem Espresso-Kocher.
Nichts ist falsch an einem Espresso-Kocher. Er funktioniert hervorragend und
vor allem, er ist so einfach.
kein Stromanschluss. Kaffee, Wasser rein, Hitze, Bom.
Klar, ich weiß, Hitze kommt meistens aus dem Strom. Das ist nicht das,
was ich meine, aber das ist halt nicht nochmal so ein Gerät mit User-Interface,
Buttons, Knöpfen, irgendeinen Scheiß.
Gerade weil diese Kaffee-Vollautomaten sind ja auch User-Interface technisch.
Das ist die totale Katastrophe.
Ja, da sagt ja niemand was. Wir haben den Kaffee-Vollautomaten ja auch schon zu Recht in F getan.
Nur zwischen einem Espressokocher, der halt wirklich irgendwie das halt Kaffee
Steinzeit und einem Kaffee Vollautomaten.
Kaffee einfach in seiner Urform.
Naja, Kaffee in seiner Urform wäre jetzt griechischer Kaffee oder türkischer
Kaffee, wo du das Zeug halt einfach mit Wasser aufgießt und dann irgendwie so
wie es ist aus der Tasse trinkst.
Du gießt es ja auch auf, aber du machst es halt mit einer hohen Temperatur,
mit hohem Druck, aber alles entsteht.
Ja, aber mit zu hoher Temperatur oder zu niedriger. Du hast überhaupt keine Kontrolle darüber.
Wie die Temperatur... Du brauchst auch keine Kontrolle, weil da kommt einfach
korrekter Kaffee mal raus.
Ja, eben nicht.
Wieso eben nicht?
Vielleicht gibt es noch mehr Faktoren, die nicht unbedingt nur die Maschine
betreffen. Ist es denn möglich, diesen Espresso-Koffer...
Bei Kaffee gibt es keine Einigkeit unter den Menschen. Das ist sozusagen das generelle Problem.
Also, so müssen wir jetzt leider die Sendung schließen.
Ich mach ihn auf A.
Siebträgermaschine.
Danach stelle ich die Datenbank auf Ried und Lied.
So, so.
Ja, okay.
Damit sind wir durch, oder wie?
Damit sind wir jetzt mal durch. Haben aber ein Werk getan. Hat ja super geklappt,
mein Plan um 12 Uhr nach Hause.
Hey, an mir lag es nicht, sag ich mal.
Ich hab morgen übrigens noch so einen Podcast. Das wird genauso spät.
Ah, da kann ich übrigens sagen, ich hörte wieder mal Tims rufen und dann machen
wir morgen nämlich auch eine Tierlist.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie das bei uns eskaliert. eine Sache habe ich heute
gelernt, auf gar keinen Fall viele Objekte da drin liegen haben.
Das waren zu viele.
Ich habe es Ralf gleich gesagt, dass es zu viele sind. Wir nehmen einfach genauso viele wie letztes Mal.
Es waren aber mehr.
Ich wollte eigentlich weniger haben, aber es waren halt dann so schöne Sachen dabei.
Wir hatten aber mehr jetzt.
Wir haben ja als letztes Mal.
Als letztes Mal, Ich sagte ungefähr so viele wie letztes Mal.
Weil ich hatte das Gefühl.
Dass es letztes Mal gerade so okay war, aber vielleicht waren da auch Dinge dabei.
Die Kunst liegt da drin, wirklich die Target-Kategorie gut zu fassen.
Und wir hatten jetzt hier dieses Problem mit Single-Function und Single-Purpose und so weiter.
Ich meine, ich verstehe die Konfusion, sie nicht einfach aufzulösen,
aber das ist sozusagen die Kunst. Man muss es scharf, kann ich machen.
Malik, ist es ein Geheimnis, was der Oberbegriff der Tierlist sein wird bei
euch? Oder wisst ihr das noch nicht?
Wir wissen es schon und die Tierlist ist auch schon fertig. Ich kann es droppen.
Ich will nur wissen, was ist der Themenraum.
Ja genau, dann können wir mal drauf abklopfen, ob der Sinn macht.
Der Themenraum ist Apple Moments.
Oh.
Weil es war irgendwie, also so Sachen wie iPhone Reveal 2007 von Steve Jobs und so oder Bandgate.
Das iPad aus dem Umschlag.
Sehr schön. Gefällt mir. Ja, das ist immer so. So muss man das machen.
Genau, und die Moments sind aber so vage genug, dass es halt nicht nur,
was weiß ich, Katastrophen oder nur irgendwelche neuen Produkte oder irgendwie
so, sondern U2-Album wird auf alle iPhones ausgespielt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist so ein Moment.
Ja, sehr gut. Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich habe mich...
Viel Spaß.
That's the spirit.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es da recht wenig Debatte gibt.
Sondern dass man da viel Einigkeit...
Ich schau mal, ist das erst mal so.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich meine, es ist schon klar, dass natürlich die
iPhone reviert ist S-Tier.
Wieso? War doch ein gutes Album.
Und du, du ist F-Tier. Okay, und auf wie viele kommt ihr?
Lass mich mal gerade gucken.
Ich klicke und der Link geht nicht mehr. Hast du eben irgendwas gemacht,
das meine Liste kaputt gemacht hat?
Ach ja, das hätte dir natürlich niemand sagen müssen.
Nee, die Links sollten alle noch gehen.
Ja, die Edit-URL geht. Okay, also,
2461812 habe ich jetzt gerade, wenn niemand mehr bis morgen mit einem Apple-Moment kommt.
Ja, 12 kann man.
Steve Jobs schmeißt ein Telefon von der Bühne.
Das würde ich noch dazu nehmen, ja. Nee, es war kein Telefon,
es war eine X-Hus-Kamera oder so eine Kamera.
Ich glaube, es bittet alle, das WLAN auszuschalten.
Das sind natürlich jetzt alles so Keynote-Momente, ne? Der Sarg und keine Ahnung,
also das könnte man erlieblich erweitern.
Stimmt, Phil Schiller springt von auf den Trampolin.
Welcher Sarg?
Als sie Classic macOS begraben haben, meine ich.
Ja, der Sarg.
Der Sarg?
Ja, ja, mit so einem schönen Requiem-Gedudel von der Orgel und so weiter und Nebel und allem.
Ja, also die Liste, die wir hier haben, ist auf keinen Fall erschöpfend.
Aber ich dachte auch, heute habe ich gelernt, zu viele sind problematisch.
Ja, klar, weil ich meine, das Gute ist, da kommt so viel mal rum.
Und ich fand das jetzt doch sehr gehaltvoll und sehr unterhaltsam.
Und von daher macht es total Spaß. Und ich meine, da merkt man auch irgendwie,
man muss nicht immer einer Meinung sein und man kann da auch im Diskurs viel Nuancen rauskissen.
Auch wenn ich natürlich jetzt total entsetzt bin, dass ich hier mit so so Espresso-Cora
Hassan hier unterwegs bin.
Aber guck mal, eigentlich ist das eine super Übung in Demokratie.
Das wäre auch was für Schulen oder so.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Man muss sich halt einig werden, ohne jetzt abzustimmen oder so.
Und alle sind unzufrieden. Das ist genau der perfekte Kompromiss.
Genau, und Estier, nur wenn alle der Meinung sind, es wäre Estier.
So, wollen wir ja mal einen Schluss?
Nein, das ist noch ein Thema.
You're holding it wrong.
Okay, Ralf, ich mach's dir einfach. wir machen doch einfach Outro an.
Weißt du, dann läuft die Uhr.
Malik, vielen Dank für deine Teilnahme. Audio Dump ist der Podcast.
Da könnt ihr die Apple Moments dann nachhören.
Und ja, wir kommen dann ein paar Wochen wieder zu euch. Bis dahin sagen wir Tschüss. Bis bald.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.
Tschüss und denkt an die Messer.